thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
it's going to be fast and furious with
lots of twists and turns
it's gonna be a bumpy road where
Precision is needed
Julius Brown
[Applause]
[Music]
he blundered his Knight
full of traps you saw the reaction he's
like oh crap here we go like what is
this kid got in store he's gonna be a
Checkmate right I mean that King
Levon is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over Checkmate on the board
reacts he celebrates oh hello
he is so stressed out he knows he's so
close in this one
celebrate
this is the fifth Tournament of the
Champions chapter this season long tour
is designed to decide the very best
chess player in online speed chess and
this one is a battle of generations for
that spot into the season and final we
are live from our studio in Oslo and to
keep you on top of all the action we're
back with The ogs Grandmaster David
Howell
Simon Williams and in the studio
International Master Yovan kahaska Yogi
welcome back guys good to be back here
Tanya it feels like home here in Oslo
and what a time to be back Ivanka this
season is heating up it's been a
dramatic one so far a new format what
are you most excited about in this one
well we're coming to the end of the
season as you say and oh my God everyone
is starting to get nervous as those
places to Toronto are going up for grabs
is going to be fast it's going to be
furious and talking about that can I
just say that that opening scene that
you guys shot was just the coolest thing
I've ever seen that was a lot of fun it
is going to be fast and furious chess uh
Simon you were quite the Speedy Gonzalez
on the go-kart track a lot of fun but it
also got competitive I it did yeah I
mean whenever you race David do anything
with David it's going to get a little
bit competitive but I thought my only
chance as he always beats me at chess is
to try to out driving but we will kind
of have to wait and see who won the
go-karting but it was a it was a lot of
fun loads of fun it was let's just say
that myself and Simon we're much better
chess players than we are drivers but uh
the adrenaline's pumping this
tournament's gonna be fast we're ready
we are ready and it is the race to
Toronto eight players will qualify the
winner of each of the six events and the
players who finish on top of the
leaderboard four have already booked a
spot Magnus Carlsen with two wins this
season
punched his ticket with a spectacular
final win against Fabiano caruana in the
chessable Masters not the back of the
soccer crushed the field in the Chaska
cup Fabiano caruana yet to win an event
but with his consistent performance has
accumulated enough tour points to book
his seat in Toronto let's take a look at
our leaderboards and Magnus Carlsen
still in first place with his double
mommy first with the air things Masters
Victory and then the aim chess wrap it
but with two wins he's opened up another
qualification spot through the tour
standings David tour points are critical
who's feeling the pressure yeah there's
plenty at stake for everyone now Tanya
especially as we near the end of the
season I'm looking at the top 10 here
I'm seeing Dennis lazovic also just
outside the top 10 alarisa farrugia who
need those points ideally tournament
victory in division one will Bank them a
spot in the finals but points are key at
this stage yeah those are the players in
division one in division two there are
still two names battling it out of
course we have Vladimir feather save and
also Levon aronian who will be looking
to win division two grab those 50 points
and of course grab a spot into the next
tournaments division one that is the
dream for these players a lot to fight
for a lot on the line door points as
well as the big box now one of the big
tour favorites this season has been
Wesley so but it has been a couple of
disappointing uh tournaments for the
world number eight an early exit from
the world cup and a rather forgettable
World rapid Team Championship Simon
what's going on with Wesley
it's hard to say I mean he's such a
strong player Wesley when he plays well
he can beat everyone but he needs to
finish in the top half of this
competition to qualify for the next
round so he needs to win his first
couple of matches and then he'll be safe
in the final and uh it's really down to
Wesley Wesley on his day is just one of
the best players in the world but he's
got to come out and perform him I must
say Simon I'm one of Wesley so's biggest
fans and I was sitting just a few tables
away from him at the World Cup recently
and something was off he just didn't
look himself didn't look like he wanted
to be a hit uh be there and uh yeah I'm
just hoping we see him get back to his
usual self to the Wesley we know and
love
absolutely Wesley so hasn't won a season
event yet but with door points he's on
the cusp of qualification he needs to
finish in the top four to seal the deal
but it's not going to be easy with the
Stellar cast of the Julius bear
generation cup three generations
fighting it out the veteran Pavel eliano
of tremendous experience a very a
principled player and we've got the
generation of their Peak being led by
Magnus Carlsen and the youngest player
in the way in the field 16 year old
Dennis last week Ivanka who is the
player you're most excited to watch well
I have to start off by saying Magnus
Carlsen is probably like the guy who's
won everything so he's a big favorite
but you know apart from Magnus I'm
actually going to say Fabiana caruana he
just grabbed a spot to the candidates
and he did very well at the world rapid
Team Championships yeah and I I guess I
I'm gonna be a little bit greedy and
pick two players um if I'm allowed to
and two of the younger players and
they're actually playing in the first
match so I'm picking naughty Beck who's
uh won one of these competition for
incredibly strong and his opponent uh
the Razer Ali razor and Aly Razer is so
fun to watch and he's actually just one
tutor titled Tuesday competitions
yesterday so he's on he's on great form
and I I think if one of those goes one
of those guys wins uh they could win the
whole thing there you know what we're
four very experienced players here four
very experienced commentators I'm gonna
go for the experience player of the
group Pavel elianov you might be the
underdog Magnus Castle will probably win
it but Eliana I'm hoping he has a deep
right here that's a hard take but David
going for the most experienced player
but the youngest player in the field is
a 16 year old Dennis last wig also known
as a danlas wrought Island he's fast
he's fearless and his journey to
division one had us all on the edge of
our seats
Dennis lazovic was dominant in division
two of the aim chess rapid at the age of
only 16 years old he handled Elite
opponents with ease in a best of four
match format he went 3-0 in back-to-back
matches against notable Grandmasters
David paravian and Amin tabatabai his
toughest opponent came in the form of
American Grandmaster Sam sebian in the
winners final the pair were incredibly
evenly matched drawing four games in a
row in Armageddon lazovic muscled his
way into a material and positional
Advantage with the black pieces but
since all he needed was a draw he was
more than happy to repeat moves getting
the draw and winning the match thanks to
the Double Elimination format sevian had
a chance at Redemption after clawing his
way through the losers bracket and back
into the Grand Final for a rematch once
again the game results for all draws
stuck in high level chess gridlock and
look at this draw Green these guys yeah
Armageddon this time savian had the
black pieces in Armageddon and he played
a rook and Bishop vs Rook end game into
La draw by 50 move rule securing the
match win oh my dangerous and that's it
he made the draw but it wasn't over yet
since lazovic had yet to lose a match
until then he was given another chance
in the second Grand Final true to their
form they produced only draws until an
Armageddon Sabian had a winning end game
with the white pieces on the precipice
of Victory he blundered upon and with it
the win allowing to draw and win a very
hard-fought in chess rapid we'll see how
this member of the younger generation
fairs in the Julius bear generation cup
and what a win that was don't be fooled
by his age Dennis lazovic is a dangerous
opponent and this is a huge opportunity
for him playing in division one David
we've seen some phenomenal performances
by division two winners this season
that's right for Dennis lazovic and for
everyone in division two this time they
only need to take inspiration from
Fabiano caruana and another back up to
satorof who won that Division and went
on to shine in the top division and uh
yeah they can do it this time too
seems to shine on those players who get
that division to Victory and there are
some big names of fighting former World
a championship challenge
David all Iran massive competition who's
the one player to watch out for you have
some huge names there Tanya but my eyes
will be on Vladimir fedes and level
neronian as Ivanka mentioned earlier
they have it all to play for in tall
points because they need to clinch their
spot in the tour finals
absolutely for these players a lot on
the line to get that ticket to Toronto
levonaronian fantasy of fighting for
that but it's not just division two big
big names in division three including a
former world champion that's right big
flat very popular player one of my
favorite world champions ever Vladimir
kramnik will be participating in
division three watch out as well for
anishikiri lots of big names there too
Anish guy fighting it out in division at
three the action is on big juicy
matchups all around you can follow
division two action on chess dodo's
Channel and a division's reaction on a
Grand Master Ben Feingold Channel our
focus in the studio will be in division
one with the finish line inside it is
clutch time for these players it has
been an action-packed season so far
under one minute now for
the move eight minutes and 59 seconds
beaten by one second and Magnus has had
no struggles against a car over the
board he should be happy we have a
winner Magnus Carlson takes it he wins
the air things Monsters the very first
event
oh and you see a reaction
oh no hey
is the winner of the chessable Masters
Fabiano caruana resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
[Applause]
laminated
[Music]
I think you checked it right off the
game and he reacts to that moment and
that's it we have a winner another
wins the chest up what a match
performance this has been by the world
number one okay
gosh the pin and Wesley he leaves
because it's all there we go oh my God
and we have a winner Magnus Carlsen
checkmates Wesley saw and wins the game
chess Robin
four of the 10 world top 10 are fighting
it out in the Julius pair a generation
cup and this is the action on the menu
juicy matchups all along and one that
catches my eye not a backup dosage of
taking on Ali Reza furuja Simon is there
a favorite in this one I think it's
really hard to pick a favorite they're
two brilliant players both prodigies
both great to watch both attacking
players and even could win so uh I'm
gonna say no but it's gonna be a great
match to watch it's gonna be a close
fight and Nadia back up the satra with a
tournament or a win already has booked
his spot into Toronto so it does take
the pressure off him for alireza a lot
on the line in this one the other big
matchup Wesley saw taking on eliano
Ivanka what's your prediction here well
I think that Wesley so is the firm
favorite but Pavel Eliana he is a
renowned trainer and he will be looking
to make his mark on today's stage
has worked with Boris girlfriend Magnus
Carlson Maria music for World
Championship matches he has incredible
experience it's going to be a big big
fight and we've got a clash of
generations when the 16 year old Dennis
last week takes on Fabiano caruana David
it's a tough match for Dennis where is
his best shot against Fabi it's a tough
match Carolina a big favorite on paper
but Dennis just needs to take
inspiration from the fact he actually
knocked out Fabiano from the bullet
Chess Championship earlier this year so
speed is key if he can get it to the
nervy moments of the game he has a
chance
those times crumbles can be any
enemies again
finally the big matchup with
armintavitabai taking on world number
one Magnus Carlsen Simon is Magnus
looking for that hat-trick win this
season of course he is I mean Magnus is
just winning everything at the moment
but he's got to be a little bit on his
guard against Armin who's a very very
dangerous attacking player so what I
mean needs to do here is just attack
Magnus and uh maybe something strange
could happen then
be able to throw that kind of ball in
this big matchup against the world
number one and while the players get
ready everyone watching get your phones
out and get ready to answer our trivia
of the day and here's the question
Magnus is only the second player to win
the video World Cup as the number one
seed who was the other player and if
this is a tough one you're not alone
because take a look at what happened
when David and Simon tried to get this
right
[Music]
as you know
um I'm gonna have a guess
prag
I love that he's hiding his answers
send in your answers on Twitter guys is
it still Twitter or x what are we
calling it somebody like that yeah
sending your answers on a Twitter slash
attack uh Slash X are using the hashtag
chess Champs and we will reveal the
answers at the end of the show one lucky
winner will win the very cool air things
device to step up your air quality and
David there with the device so send in
your answers and we'll send you this one
with David's kiss on it it's a big prize
to be won
and it's going to be a big big day of
Chess as the matches are about to start
let's take a look at the format of the
event we will have a best of four rapid
games the player to win two and a half
points wins the match and they start
with 15 minutes with three second
incremental move it is a double
elimination which means if you win your
match you stay on top you continue the
run in the winners bracket if you lose a
match you're not eliminated just yet you
fall down to your last life in the
losers bracket and if we get into a 2-2
tie we will have the bidding Armageddon
to the side the winner then as the clock
start taking it means we are just
moments away from liftoff we will be
starting with a Magnus versus
magnus's Instagram we saw that he's out
up in the mountains having a bit of a
chilling time oh I'm not sure
from what I heard in this particular
area of the mountains Lauren there's
actually quite a few White Knuckle
Adventures there's a zip line there's a
big hike that you can do yeah I mean
this is like white no no was it
nerve-wracking stuff is what I want to
say
oh you might be seeing some
nerve-wracking uh chests on the board as
well a big big matchups there I did see
this meme on Twitter which said the
strongest players in the world right
you've got well number one Magnus
Carlson then you have a drunk Magnus and
then you have an unwell Magnus what
about a chill up in the mountains Magnus
how dangerous is that uh it's gonna be
on the list somewhere that's for sure
yeah I can just see Magnus on his zip
wire coming down a bit James Bond music
in the background chess board in one
hand you know clocking the other then I
don't always hold on to the zip wire
with but yeah he's just very good and
he's winning everything but here he is
and uh we're getting there kickoff now
so excited I'm excited yeah and uh okay
it's not Magnus this time we will be
starting with a clash between Fabiano
caruana and Dennis lazovic who takes the
white pieces yeah I mean it looks like
Magnus to Me Maybe it's mini Magnus
Festival
he's got a lot of medals in the
background quite intimidating those
medals there so yeah
yeah it was awesome to hear that what
you just said that Dennis actually took
down Fabi in a recent bullet
Championship so it could really come
down to those critical seconds and that
could be the strategy for dunlas to try
to bring the clock down as much as
possible and force Fabi to take some big
decisions then yeah definitely uh we're
playing rapid chess here so very
different type of animal to Bullet chess
but like you say Tanya especially as
they get down to maybe move 40 move 50
when the clocks are ticking when the
nerves are dangling I mean maybe that
kind of memory will haunt Fabiano so
definitely with lazovic's kind of slow
positional style I think he might have a
chance there
and Ivanka you were in Dusseldorf the
the world rapid team championship and
what a run Fabi had there one of your
Assassin's chess he's just in good shape
and what was surprising to me was that
of course Dusseldorf came immediately
after the the World Cup and we can
actually see the players racing through
an opening called the Catalan and there
we see a queen takes the pawn and black
getting the bishop to its ideal diagonal
yeah this is one of the main positions
one of the main lines of the Catalan
opening Fabiano actually had a
traumatic experience in a very similar
line in the third place playoff losing
to aposov as black in this variation the
Catalan known as the most solid opening
for white positionally very tough uh to
kind of equalize as black look at white
space here beautiful Pawn in the center
nicely placed Queen but black is Rock
Solid and interesting that lazovic I
think that's maybe what's kind of uh
makes him stand out as a youngster just
he loves these slow types of grinds he's
very happy to just outmaneuver his
opponents which is rare normally we see
young players attacking Simon just uh
going straight for the king from the off
what do you think of this uh start to
the game yeah I mean a lot of the
younger players nowadays they're getting
far too mature for their age I feel you
know who I mean I I think when you're
young you've got to have a bit of fun
hacking and attacking but uh you know I
I just I mean
um white here uh playing as you said a
very positional line and uh he he is a
very mature player I mean uh for for his
age and he's just going for a small
Advantage by having more Pawns in the
center of the board
and those are a lot of medals uh behind
danla is quite inspiring room right
there Ivanka
it certainly is isn't it I mean they
always say it's a good idea to remind
yourself of your achievements so that
you when you go into your room you feel
good about yourself and there we can see
some more moves on the board black just
centralizing the rook and white grabbing
space there on the left with the pawns
this is a very typical idea white just
wants to overwhelm on the queen side and
at the same time just build up at the
right time for that Center of palm push
with a very mature uh opening approach
playing the Kathleen against Fabi almost
made Fabi switch off his camera and say
that I'm not ready for this one it's
gonna be a big fight here we've got
action on on the other boards as well
with Wesley so ready to take on Pavel
eliano Wesley's Thoughts with the white
pieces he really needs to switch things
up from the way we've been seeing the
last couple of months Wesley has been
struggling with form meanwhile for Pavel
alyanov this is a big opportunity in
division one yeah Pavel eliano we
shouldn't forget that he did get to
world number six I think that was around
2010 so he is one of the best players in
the world he has form uh so he can
compete against these players but of
course Wesley vastly experienced in
Rapid chess and uh yeah it's interesting
to see what kind of type of player
Wesley so will be today at the World Cup
the biggest shock for me was that in a
situation where he just needed a draw
with the white pieces Wesley started
playing 1v3 and all sorts of
uncharacteristic opening things but this
time back to what he knows best it's an
E4 opening oh the Italian an opening
that makes me tremble uh not in a good
way when I have the black pieces and one
of the main lines here Wesley following
his chessable course
yeah that's always a good idea Ivanka I
was going to ask you that with Wesley
what happened at the World Cup the world
rapid Team Championship rather
uninspired performance a qualification
to Toronto would mean so much for him
right now yeah absolutely and he's on
the brink of doing that as Simon
mentioned you know he just has to finish
in the top four and then he secured the
spot and it's really difficult actually
to play chess when you've had a run of
bad luck you know David mentioned that
Wesley's been switching things up I do
wonder whether he's perhaps prepared to
take a short-term loss in order to
advance his game in the long term but uh
we'll see Wesley playing in his very
solid style and there we see the pawn
move up to A4 grabbing space on the
queen side and we're waiting to see how
black reacts whether black will also
follow suit
or perhaps a just a reinforce the center
yeah I think it's kind of encouraging um
for Wesley fans that he's playing this
way because uh as you mentioned David he
was playing B3 against Jules uh the
French player in in the world cup and
going back to this kind of more familiar
setup I think just suggests he's taking
it very serious and uh he just wants to
get a middle game he's very comfortable
in uh it looks quite symmetrical here I
mean the Italians are really hard
opening to understand because it's very
subtle right there's so many little
things that make a difference and uh the
only difference I can see here is really
the positioning of Black's night on the
queen side David
yeah that Black Knight on C6 sometimes
misplaced white tends to have a small
advantage in these positions but so many
different setups and uh yeah the players
will bend this type of position to their
will later
um so many different ways to approach it
yeah early days in this game
absolutely and it is the Italian which
means it is going to be a slow strategic
fight but one that promises to blow up
when we will have a central break that's
the nature of these positions while we
wait for that to happen action has
started on the not the back versus
not a back ready to go again he's fresh
from quite a spectacular performance and
Dusseldorf yeah
yeah of course yeah no not Rebecca
no because I was thinking about the
World Cup here there he was eliminated
but of course in the world rapid his
team won and he was very powerful and
Dusseldorf and uh there we can see that
a Queen's Gambit the client has been
played with this bishop F4 it's very
topical line and a big moment on the
board sorry I get distracted by the
chest I can't help myself I was like
white should really be capturing that
pawn in the middle and uh yep it happens
yeah still one of the main lines uh of
this Queen's Gambit declined and Black's
Queen coming out very early watch out
for the white king it's undeveloped it's
uncastled at the moment and there are
some nasty checks if you're not careful
here uh abdusatorov of course he studied
this position before but uh I just want
to say as well both players are
relatively fresh despite the fact that
was uh playing at the world rapid Team
Championship His World Cup he left early
in round two and uh for Russia skipped
that event completely altogether so uh
these players have no excuses when it
comes to energy I'm expecting to see
lots of long fights uh long battles in
this one and
surprising right not seeing alireza to
fight it out in the World Cup a
tournament that all these top players
love and enjoy playing so much but now
he's back he seems to quite like the
Champions Chester
he does yeah he always enjoys playing
here and um one thing I like about um
alireza is the the fact that he he
doesn't play all the tournaments he is
clear that he's kind of got his own uh
own mind you know he doesn't just play
Tom's for the sake of playing he plays
when he wants to play and uh uh you kind
of we're talking about Wesley so maybe
you could even say Wesley didn't seem to
really be enjoying himself in the world
cup and uh maybe he was doing it more
because he thought he had to possibly uh
and we see another move on the board
here this is to stop that check of the
bishop which is very commonly Play
Because white of course would like to
Castle still and um it's a pretty
standard position we have here but very
excited about this match two of the
younger talents who could both have the
potential to be world champions in the
future yeah the future of uh chess or
maybe the president of Chess already in
front of the screen but when we talk
about the press in this chats we have to
talk about the world number one and he
is on the screen he is ready to start
his match against the 22 year old army
he is a dangerous aggressive player
Magnus uh from his is that a streaming
room David what's going on there yeah
whenever we see Magnus Carlsen backed up
by a lot of Chess we know he's at home
in Oslo his favorite place to play and
okay he's back home will home Comforts
suit him it's uh the Spanish the open
Spanish uh where black captures a pawn
in the center very early with the Knight
going a pawn up but gives the pawn back
this is trendy trendy stuff Magnus with
great chair Quality Air Quality all of
it but this opening it tends to be very
forceful I've seen games here analyzed
up to move 2030 who has done the better
homework uh Magnus playing a slightly
rare move on this last turn apparently
Magnus was spotted on his jet ski just
before the game going across the harbor
just getting there on time uh with that
music playing in the background you know
but uh as you say this this is a very
sharp variation isn't it this this
opening and uh it often comes down to
who's who's done the better home work
and the fact that Armin is picking us
Ivanka I guess is a an exciting sign it
means he wants a a nice sharp battle
yeah he certainly does and one of Magnus
Carlson's like biggest assets is that
he's able to switch up the openings play
unconventional thing because he's able
to draw on these extensive knowledge of
pattern recognitions and when of when
how to transpose into different
positions and different variations he's
one of the few that can do this and does
that also make him the hardest player to
prepare against yeah absolutely you know
I was talking to some Grand Masters and
they were talking about the older
generation and the differences between
the new generations and the new
generations they were saying that is all
mainly move by move is very much
calculation based they have very good
instincts but whereas Magnus is looking
at strategy as well as being phenomenal
at calculations so he's able to combine
those two qualities and just overwhelm
the younger players but of course
younger players they're adapting they're
learning new skills all the time and in
the meantime we see lots of trades on
the board and I see that black has
stolen an exchange yeah we have to jump
into the chest because Magnus Carson has
sacrificed material uh as Ivanka says
it's Rook for Bishop right now he's
sacrificed The Exchange and I've got to
say this is something I've never seen
before uh despite playing the Spanish
with both colors my whole life Magnus
coming up with rare or at least new
ideas and uh let's jump in to
investigate what's happened I think we
have to backtrack and do an action
replay this is the current position if
we do a quick count it is Rook for
Bishop but it was here that Magnus made
the decision after Black's Bishop pinned
the White Knight he said okay do your
worst I'm just gonna simply nudge your
Bishop but after Knight takes Knight he
realized uh maybe part of the plan he
cannot capture this Knight in a
desirable way for example if you take
with a queen simply your pawns will be
shattered another Pawn will drop off and
look at the mess around the white King
instead he says okay I can't take your
night I'm going to take your Bishop
instead and
what is the result we have uh okay a
weak Pawn a Target in the center but is
that enough compensation we talk about
the bishop pair
what do we think here is this a gamble
by Magnus
yeah it must be preparation I I mean we
know Magnus does gamble occasionally uh
his preparation looks pretty decent I
would say uh you pointed out that Rook
coming to the middle he's fantastic uh
light Square Bishop which you you often
get in this Spanish opening the pressure
against the center and I always love
having this Pawn as white in the middle
of the board because that pawn on E5 it
can often be the Catalyst to start an
attack so uh looks very interesting this
sacrifice to me it certainly looks
interesting to me as well because one of
the things that I'm also eyeing up is
that yeah white has this amazing Central
possibilities but also you know there is
the the H file is open
um who knows something could be coming
towards the black king and there you go
you see the Knight did move to the edge
to attack the bishop bishop relocates
and is now pointing at the age seven
square what a nice soft spot
something wicker This Way Comes maybe as
you say Ivanka something will line up
you could imagine Pawn pushing forward
the White Queen zooming out to start an
attack maybe she'll come this way as
well definite potential for an attack
for Magnus but a big material investment
and will it pay off that's the big
question Magnus in an aggressive mood
after whatever he's been doing this
morning yeah aggressive mood and Magnus
with more time on the clock than what he
started with clearly part of the prep
part of the plan things getting
dangerous for black but it is an
exchange he does amitabai has got a rook
for a bishop and that's got account for
something he's really trying to get rid
of that Bishop there trying to trade off
as many pieces as possible Magnus not
having any of it not allowing any of it
it's all about Black trying to get those
Rooks into the game how does he handle
the pressure on the king side while
trying to make the most of the material
advantage that he has well he just has
to look after the king you know just
always make sure that the black queen is
in contact with the king is able to
switch over to that other side and I
just wanted to point out one thing just
take a look magnus's clock time he
hasn't used any time which means that
Magnus is deep in preparation and of
course he's just come off this world cup
win maybe this is an idea that he
concocted for that tournament
yeah I mean this is just incredible I
know Magnus pretty well and I just don't
know where he finds the time to study
openings I mean he's always out playing
golf or uh you know jet skiing or
whatever he does and somehow he still
has time to cook up these crazy opening
ideas that nobody sees coming from a
mile away and I mean isn't isn't that
where money comes in handy because uh
you know he's he's got he's got his
second so maybe he can go jet skiing
where a poor old Peter his second is
just there slogging away finding all the
Novelties for him he's like you know it
probably does help a little bit right to
to have a team of seconds I mean uh you
know not every Grandmaster can do that
right so that's true and also these days
everyone is working with super computers
right so yeah could this just be
something that was suggested by whatever
engine Magnus is working with
yeah very well but we see the eval bar
here it says that black is doing fine
slightly better for black and that begs
the question that these kind of opening
approaches where you give up material
for the initiative is it more suitable
for this kind of a format where it's
rapid chat it really doesn't have that
amount of time to navigate through these
exactly I mean I would say only for
Rapid format or if this is your style
for me I'm gonna say as a you know I'm
famous people in commentary for being a
porn Grabber
um but here I would just be like so
scared about sacrificing material
because I would feel that pressure that
you know if I don't do something with
this material investment oh dear I've
lost the game so I can't handle that
kind of tension but if you can and if
you're very good with Dynamics and with
intuition then this is the opening for
you I have a question for you guys if
you're not playing against Magnus would
you rather be white or black here David
uh I would be black because I'm greedy
and materialistic Simon I mean do I I
even need to answer that question I mean
you know who we buy now guys and I I I
love attacking I love having the
initiative even if it's a load of
baloney I don't care so give me white
any day of the week
so it's quite a split panel with white
or black and as you said Ivanka for you
uh you would probably prefer to have the
materials yeah exactly because I
it just gives me some comfort to know
that in the long run I'm gonna win this
one but yeah look at the clock I mean
really in the think tank here he has to
be because every move carries some
poison with it and there you see he
played F6 at Tempo Magnus just plays E6
just puts the pawn there in the middle I
mean that is disconcerting yeah imagine
being I mean to better buyer right now
Magnus casting the world's best player
just throwing moves at you not blinking
not pausing and uh soon going for the
king I just wanted to say as well if we
jump in and talk about concrete moves
there might be some traps on the board
uh just before we show other games uh
here right now I was thinking why not
grab this pawn it looks like you said
hey you might as well say B be as greedy
as possible but suddenly Magnus can
simply play this quiet move this isn't
my concoction don't worry haunted G3 the
computer points out and white is winning
apparently just jumping out with the
queen and wow Magnus is doing something
very similar Bishop to D6 played he
defends his Bishop on F4 with a pawn and
watch out now if you're black for this
threat Quint H3 as Ivanka said the
target is H7 yeah maybe even Bishop
takes H7 is something you can think
about here uh giving up a whole piece as
well and this is the thing I mean it's
all well and good to say you know
Black's gonna do well Affair but you
know Checkmate ends the game right I
mean that's the point of chest the point
of Chess is to kill oh and that's what
Magnus is doing but we rarely well I say
rarely but we don't see Magnus doing
this often so I think it's great to see
I love how your move of choice was
Bishop A7 you don't want to go Queen H3
for setting up the meeting ideas but I
do like Queen history as well because
you're not only threatening it with the
bishop and queen lining up again it's
Heaven black can fight that with a move
like G6 David but once you step up with
your king and the Rook joins the body
that would be game over for black yeah
and uh just to kind of also say who
doesn't like to threaten Checkmate in
one
first thing we learned When We're Young
we talked about Generations cup when
we're kids first thing we learned
Checkmate on H7 Magnus is doing it we're
talking about all these techmates on 87
but the bar says you know what are you
even on about Black's doing absolutely
fine I'm gonna ask you to point out what
is the defensive resource against this
idea against the 87 Pawn David
um actually let's jump back in and try
and find a defense here for black
um maybe I mean as you mentioned Tanya
at some point you need to blunt the
effect of this bishop which is hitting
and hating H7 uh Pawn to G6 looks like
it needs to be played at some point I'm
not sure about the right order when the
White Queen jumps out I guess you can
set up a defense along the seventh rank
so this Pawn is overprotected from here
I don't know what happens next Magnus
will throw a few things towards you this
Pawn could step forward uh the white
Rook could join either from E1 defending
it's very strong protected Pawn maybe
long-term competition or short term as
you say Tanya could be aiming to land on
the H file either way you've got
everything covered for black but the
question is what next and your extra
material here the black Rooks they're
not doing uh good work right now so I
think this is just a long-term sacrifice
as well as a direct attack against the
black king but a critical moment foreign
he needs to be careful for the next few
moves otherwise it could and the in
Checkmate very soon he does go for the
idea of clearing up the seventh rank to
step up with the queen to try and keep
things under control on the king's side
David you pointed out that this is uh
very well a long-term sacrifice we might
not saying we might not see a Checkmate
soon but it's going to be a fun fight on
the board we also have a lot of fun
action in the dangerous Dennis versus
fabulous Fabby matchup and it is are
Rook Bond end game but I do see a lot of
weaknesses for black here yeah black has
some isolated pawns on the queen side
you look at the black a Pawn on the side
there uh the black C Pawn as well there
is opposite color Bishops so that adds a
slightly drawish tendency to this
position but with Rooks remaining on the
board I would take white all day long
just having this one Pawn chain one Pawn
Island for why everything connected
protected uh makes it so much more
harmonious it feels like a two result
game as they say uh it's gonna be a
white win or a draw Fabiano just playing
fortnite quality here just trying to
hold on yeah and I love White's last
move you know just nudging the Rook back
one square just getting ready to double
up on the a line and preserving the
Integrity of the pawn chain as well and
the clip art is so pretty with all the
pawns on dark squares I do like my
geometry and it's also a great move
because the bishop as well could step
back and also pile up on the pawn on A6
that pawn has a Target on its back and
for Abby now has to generate some
activity that's super important when you
have what we call horn weaknesses static
weaknesses you need to activate the
pieces you need to find some counter
play so I'm expecting Fabi to perhaps
double up on the B-Line with his works
and try to get into that famous opposite
color Bishop end game which is
notoriously drawn
yeah before the Rooks disappear as you
say Ivanka this one is going to be a
peace treaty a handshake but uh
definitely deceptive the evaluation bar
here it says completely level but
Fabiano pressure on him to be active and
uh accurate in here yeah your move
predicted
um yeah this one Simon slightly less fun
than the Magnus game a lot less fun
let's be honest and I can't believe how
mature this young kid is playing you
know this is the way he plays I mean
he's uh he's he's only a Nipper and uh
you know he's not he's not sacrificing
pieces he's going for the grind grinding
his opponents down and I I agree that he
has quite a nice position here he he
shouldn't lose this position every has
no weaknesses and it just looks quite
Pleasant you aren't David you inside are
great friends but absolutely different
style
I know you do enjoy your
s this position is perhaps just an
everyday position for you you know why
not it's a fun ending there are
weaknesses Simon hates it yeah I mean
there are different styles of players
yeah good player rather dodgy player
it's kind of like to sum it up but um we
you know yeah we do have quite different
styles but David I have you know can
play uh amazing attacking chess as well
and uh his calculation is is on point
and he's out calculated mean many many a
game and he's made me cry on the old
occasion too
one of these two players ground me down
in an end game and it was not David
David just beat me
coins are off the board in your game you
just just resigned
don't want to play this anymore but this
game it has been impressive the way uh
Dennis lazovic has managed his uh game
one against uh Fabi Dennis last week at
15. also one at title Tuesday and I have
to say title Tuesday is one of the
strongest chess tournaments I'm not even
talking about online I mean you've got
so many Grand Masters playing he adds
out so many of them so Fabi cannot
underestimate his 16 year old opponent
and the way this game is gone it feels
to me as if Fabi just wants to bail out
just wants to draw in this one and shut
it down you yeah and let's just jump in
to show how accurate Fabiano has been we
talk about calculation Simon Fabian is
one of the best of them and just this
last couple of moves let's go back it
was here starting The Rook trade
operation giving a check forcing one set
of Rooks off the board and it looks like
black is about to lose a pawn but
Fabiano just in time to play the move he
found Rook to B3 and the problem here
for white is it's hard to defend this
one if you step it forward then black
can simply for example block uh trade
off the Rooks uh maybe there are even
better moves maybe the black Bishop
comes in and this Pawn starts to roll so
it looks like instead there was a trade
and after route to B3 simply stuff
started coming off the board Rook takes
Pawn Rook takes pawn and now black has
one weakness but it's not enough you
need two weaknesses to win these types
of positions luckily as well as we saw
in the game black has already created a
Luft square and Escape Square for the
black king and uh to catch up with the
current position
looks pretty drawn now looks like
Fabiano has defended very very well
would be an impressive result for uh
Dennis lazowick as well to start the
Julius bear generation cup with a draw
against world number three Fabiano
caruana this is a battle of generations
we have seen what 16 year old Dan Las is
up to let's go over to the 40 year old
against Wesley saw uh the good news
Simon Queens are on and Harry the H Pawn
is also up the board that is good news I
like it when the Queens are on the board
uh you know I do play the odd ending but
um yeah I prefer a bit of tactical
action and uh yeah this is this this is
seeming very interesting look at the
white porn right in the center of the
board and uh I I would assume that that
might give white some chances of an
advantage also Black's Knight has moved
over to a very passive Square uh knights
in the room are dim there's so many
sayings Ivanka you've got you've got a
whole book of sayings about that night
haven't you give us one just give us one
saying well the only one I other one I
know is night's on the edge all off the
Hedge there you go like Humpty Dumpty
but that was a wall so not really but
yeah and and I don't know is is white
just better here David I mean is this is
that's what it looks like to me yeah I
completely agree Simon I'm surprised by
the evaluation bar still being in the
center just first glance it looks like
wait has a beautiful position and wow
Wesley's really going for it now he's uh
definitely in the mood to be aggressive
I think maybe the downside here for
white is that long term maybe you aren't
doing so well white has this Pawn on A4
and a light Square White's Queen is not
necessarily actively placed but okay
it's all about tactics and this last
move is very clever by Eliana he's going
to zoom his Queen over there we go with
a check the white king also being
slightly more vulnerable than the black
king
um so wow Eliana of 40 years old using
all of that experience to just defend
really calmly we talked about Knights on
the edge that night's gone back to the
first rank for black the back Rank and
it's holding everything together Black's
Queen side pawns were the only weakness
and now next move he's pretty much
guaranteed to win that C7 Pawn whites
for advanced pawn and maybe it's just
going to be equal maybe he's just found
a nice way to defend uh it's sometimes
in chess it might look beautiful your
position but if the opponent finds all
the correct defensive resources no
breakthrough frustrating it is
frustrating and also once black recovers
that pawn on C7 and then I turn my
attentions to white piece coordination
and I'm just thinking out at night on C4
doesn't have a point and I'm just
wondering whether actually black might
turn it around and be slightly better
because I'm just preferring his works on
the fact that his King is a little bit
more safer than white just because it
has three pawns around it
yeah all of those factors as we
mentioned first priority for elianov
next move I think he's guaranteed to
take this Pawn back but yeah watch out
for these uh types of threats this
bishop as well hanging in the air in the
center a bit loose there and okay Wesley
drops it back uh nice move there
and uh yeah why not just take this Pawn
I don't see any reason for black to be
worse here at all maybe slightly passive
Knight but White's queen as well just
feels like she's a bit stuck and could
you even maximize the position and go
I'm not going to take that pawn I'll
have it when I want Anna instead improve
the bishop
looks good Ivanka just uh pin and not
win this time but at least tickle the
opponent uh pin and tickle
is that like pen and Teller the pin
tickle pen and Teller famous magicians
yeah I think maybe
one of them was on friends once made a
cameo that's all I remember there we go
either way uh the porn has disappeared
after a trade of Rooks from elionov uh
slightly surprising now I'm not sure why
he abandoned the open file giving white
access to that for free but uh shouldn't
be too much fun done uh Wesley Lantern
925 and still everything solid for black
here everything solid but what about
that Harry the H Pawn can that prove to
be a weakness in Black's position
something that can be targeted Tanya an
advanced age Pawn is never a weakness
not with this commentary gang always a
strength oh this is Trend we'll find out
as this one progresses whether Harry
proves to be a weakness or a strength in
this one a meanwhile action is heating
up on the Magnus almond board so let's
Rush straight to that one Magnus Carlson
sacrificing an exchange out of the
opening for the initiative but it looks
like amen has managed to navigate his
way through all those check mating ideas
on H7
yeah the checkmating ideas yes but I'm
just looking at the pin idea where
White's obviously stepped upon two
squares forward and what's gonna happen
with the Knight
it's gonna just disappear off the board
it's going to be lost but then the
question is it's a material imbalance
who stands better this really reminds me
another game that Magnus actually lost
with the white pieces or he might have
turned it around at the end but he had a
similar kind of in the last I think
Champions Tour
um I can't remember who's playing but
when he sort of overpresses sometimes
it's maybe not his normal kind of style
um I I you know when he's kind of all in
and he is kind of all in here he's going
to win that night as you pointed out but
Black's going to get a lovely Center
there and those black pawns are looking
fantastic if that ever happens and well
we can see the evaluation bar as well is
uh is basically confirming that Armin
has played very very well it's so hard
to defend uh against a new idea uh but
he seems to be up to the task is so
could there be danger that Magnus is
going to lose this game definitely and
uh just one bit of insight here one tip
Magnus with a hand on hip is not a happy
Magnus I've noticed this throughout the
seasons of The Champions chess tour and
uh it definitely feels like he's missed
something or he looks frustrated at
himself because yes he can win back some
material but
I think the resulting positions in
Black's favor so hand on hips not a good
sign what about lag on chair legon chair
sorry it's a very good sign well okay
it's bad for the opponent the hand on
hip is the teapot isn't it it's like
he's gonna tip himself he wants to tip
off the the screen there and there we go
it seems a bit more chilled now he's
found an idea so uh that is the pouring
teapot it's a stance
um yeah I think we need to jump in
because it is such a wild position and
remember while positions actually do
help Amin to battle by it he loves those
uh kind of uh crazy types of positions
and okay that Knight has just
disappeared Pawn takes night I was gonna
just zoom back a couple of moves I think
what Magnus might have missed is that in
this position after Queen takes Pawn if
he had first taken the Rook maybe he had
forgotten that after Bishop takes Bishop
it looks like he's about to lose a
knight Black's Knight is pinned and
black is about to lose material but
Queen to B6 sliding across is a nasty
check next move of the night is free to
run and uh black would actually be a
pawn up here if we catch up with the
game Magnus had to do it in a different
order point to F4 but then the Rook
saved itself and uh after a couple more
moves it looks like we have this
position look at the black porns the
knights disappeared but these are going
to start running down the board a bit
later on and yeah this Bishop's holding
things up but if black ever doubles up
ever starts checking the white king look
how weak it is magnus's Monarch here in
big big trouble I'm liking Black's
position that's two pawns on a rook for
a bishop if we do the mat that's huge
your advantage for almond Tabata by
right now and with no check mating ideas
on the king's side it's something that
we're worried about for black earlier it
also started feeling like it's magnus's
king that's coming under Fire with all
these ideas that David's pointing out
totally and also I just want to point
out that white light Square Bishop locks
out of the game it's not going to play a
role in either defense or attack and
that's a problem so Magnus has to
generate counter play and I can't
actually see a way to do it I think he
has to just be on the defensive perhaps
bring the dark squared Bishop to E3 just
to protect the king and if he wants to
get aggressive perhaps uh find a role
for the Knight on H2 yeah perhaps uh
that idea you mentioned your van could
push bring the bishop back pushing a
pawn bringing the Knight forward but it
takes a long long time and a mean
meanwhile it's not just Magnus who can
threaten Checkmate he is lining up
against the white king be careful you do
not want to block this with the white
Bishop because the black Rook will
happily sacrifice itself and black is
going to Checkmate you sooner or later
sooner probably on the dark squares this
white king will not survive much longer
so huge threat wolf Magnus on the back
foot this early stage
it looks very scary I mean uh this is a
position where uh black is just
controlling the center of the board and
we we know the center is most important
part okay he's found a good move here
David and maybe now he's threatening to
bring his dark Square Bishop back but uh
it's uh it's it's still still I'd I'd
rather be black here is Rook after you
can feel really crazy for black
I was thinking about that too but one
check does not end the game that's what
I was thinking in this I was thinking
the king can hide itself right on each
one yeah I guess just to show your idea
Tanya it looks like Checkmate it's so
tempting but uh as Ivanka says the king
can hide I'm not sure which direction
maybe you go back this way just towards
the center and the game would have gone
on still crazy stuff but the evaluation
Bar says white slightly for Choice
instead I mean I think he's setting up
your idea Tanya oh my God scary stuff
for this white king oof Magnus is
walking a tightrope right now good thing
for him he's got some more time on the
clock you really need those extra
minutes to calculate a good defense now
he brings back the bishop with no Rook
F4 sacrifice in the air at least as
dangerous as before uh is this uh is
this a good way for white to keep things
together anyway
he doesn't have that material I mean but
it's actually equal in material I mean
if we count points there um and that
looked like a very natural move just to
break down
um that blockade and uh the thing is
Whites Whites pieces are very bad here
um but I'm not also sure how black
improves this position
starts with a simple king move I think
maybe uh it just comes down to boils
down to what Ivanka said White's Bishop
is stuck forever it's going to be
stirring against the wall of black pawns
and white tonight can jump as much as it
wants but it will most likely not get
anywhere uh too threatening anytime soon
so really in the balance right now could
still go either way this end game uh we
should update there have been some
results uh in the other games big
results Wesley Seoul wins his first game
against elianov and the Fabi Dennis
lazobic game one has ended in a draw but
it's all excitement and fire on this one
so David I think we're gonna stick to
this uh for a bit more
um with three pawns for a piece so a
different material balance than what we
saw before but the king is marching up
on the board and the G4 Pawn can come on
the fire soon leading from the front
that King
yeah it has to has to be a Spartan king
that's why I call it in the end game you
know you have to get active and uh there
we see the King has a spoiled for Choice
it can move to G5 attack the pawn as you
mentioned or centralize itself and the
important thing is you know we coined
this phrase like many seasons ago and
it's really cheesy but you really must
remember it when it comes to end games
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work and there
we see I mean Retreat the bishop getting
ready to move the king and then this
will be followed by improving the rook
and I learned a handy rule actually when
it comes to mobilizing the pieces choose
the one with the highest dynamic value
so in this case mobilize The Rook
improve it
it's going to be a big fight in this end
game and we will come back to this but
let's get a quick update on the Abdul
satrov furuja board another Rook pawn
and game but Oliver with an extra pawn
and the B Pawn I don't see a way for
white to actually stop that one
it looks like one-way traffic look at
the white king we talked about active
pieces in the end game white King on the
side looks super safe but what's the
point of a safe King in an end game you
need to be doing something active and
that King's not participating is simply
three verses one Black's King Black's B
Pawn that's just started pushing and the
black Rook uh will overpower the enemy
Rook here white can hold this up
temporarily but there we go black and
Bully with the idea of Rook traits looks
like one end game 101 Elementary stuff
nine seconds for another back yeah I
think this is over I mean the basic rule
I mean I say I don't really like endings
but I actually do and the basic rule is
when when you're a pawn up where'd you
put your rook and a rook ending when
you're attacking if you can get your
Rook behind the pass pawn and there was
this famous botanic game an ex-world
champion who who won a classic game is
pretty much over because you just shove
that pawn down the board as Black's
doing here and there's nothing that
white can do about that porn and I would
not be surprised if he just resigns now
so that's it get your Rook behind a pawn
second best next to the pawn and last
best is in front of the porn that's the
rule you want to stick to when you you
are using that extra Pawn on the rook
and pawn ending yeah and look at the way
he's doing it he's used his work he's
using the key
all he has to do is find shelter for
that King and wants us there it's a game
over
he's made it look really easy put the
rug behind the bun and uh probably it's
time for another back with just one
second on the clock is he gonna throw in
the towel he does give a check but the
black king just hides only one no more
checks the B Pawn is coming up on the
board and makes us move with just one
second on the clock
yeah I think we both players leaned back
have we seen a result we have farrugia
does take the win the black king hides
Behind Enemy Lines that b-pawn was about
to put another queen and that's it an
early lead with black as well for Asia
very convincing player by ali rezada uh
not the back has to play catch up in
this match and now it's back to the
Magnus versus Amin the black king has
advanced to Target the G4 Pawn with the
White Knight Finding itself in a nice
spot in the center creating his own
threats on the queen side yeah it's a
very impressive uh night I was actually
looking at this game whilst we were
discussing the nordeback ferrugia game
and I just saw that uh I mean he paid
the very committal C5 to C4 giving white
the space and so I was a bit baffled by
that and
now I'm guessing that black is going to
be just destabilizing that night and
there you go he pushes the B Pawn one
square forward yeah
interesting decisions interesting and
the Rooks have also come off since we
were last here which I think does help
the white uh defensive cause here
without Rooks on the board you don't
really have to worry about infiltrations
into your side of the board so you just
need to trade off as many pawns as
possible but I mean stretching that he
looks very happy and again it's what I
would call a two result game it feels
like only black can really win this
black has too many pawns it would take a
huge turnaround or just a blunder for
white to ever have Chances with such a
bad Bishop uh stuck there on D1 so okay
Magnus still with some work to do he's
got the time Advantage I don't really
see any logical moves lots of different
night jumps you can look for but you
have to calculate its pure calculation
despite the lack of pieces here you have
to be very careful about the black king
running in I actually think black could
have done that
um a couple of moves ago which may have
given him a decisive Advantage even
giving up his Bishop
um but that that black king has a very
natural route into into the uh position
and White's Pawns magnus's moved one of
them but they were on dark squares and
hang a minute look at the evaluation bar
here whoa what's Happening Here David I
think you're right Simon just simple
plan just start running in maybe Magnus
he's trying to trade off pawns look at
the tension here between these four uh
on the queen side but uh maybe I mean
can ignore this I don't think you should
necessarily get tempted by taking this
Pawn because you'll be left with ruins
oh he goes for this he misses a winning
opportunity because now these pawns can
maybe just be picked off uh but yeah if
he simply walked in with his King if we
go back a few moves walking in with the
King after Pawn to B3 would have been
decisive black would have been winning
now it's anyone's game again
yeah dramatic stuff was a big missed
opportunity I mean how many times you
get a chance to beat Magnus with the
black pieces and one thing I've seen
time and time again this was actually
the same in the World Cup Magna starts
very slowly in competitions and the best
time to try and get him is in those
first couple of games where he's warming
up and uh that that was a major major
chance here and I think uh I think he's
reasonably safe here right in this
position the the black pawns don't seem
very dangerous anymore
yeah I think the downside is look at
what Magnus has just done the White
Knight has now got a very safe Outpost
yes it looks passive but it's stopping
the black King's further infiltration
and it's just a fortress you can just
sit on this position forever there's no
way in for the black king and if you
don't have any past pawns that can uh
break through either white can just sit
here just King back and forth back and
forth and this is the definition of a
fortress Magnus that famous quote he's
eating his own words here he's so tired
of people repeating that quote about how
he doesn't believe in fortresses but
this one looks like he set it up and it
all comes down to this bishop color
complex so I'm in with the dark spot
Bishop can never get to that white
knight on C2 it's impossible to find a
way in with the King but he's trying to
do that but now it's all about can he
push the H Pawn and the answer seems to
be no with the light Squad Bishop
it's a bit strange putting the king back
uh you know Magnus putting the king all
the way back on F1 there I thought it
was a bit peculiar because he's allowed
the black king to step forwards uh and
you you generally don't want to allow
your opponent's king to enter into your
position but is he trying to win you
that's what I was thinking yeah speaking
maybe his idea is just to move the
Knight if allowed to more active and
there we saw that I mean actually
retreated the bishop to control that
night and yeah
yeah but the H Pawn now can you go H
well the E Pawn as well I I Magnus
moving that King so risky and look look
at the black pawns now oh my God I mean
I I can't see white ever winning this
position big threat though or the Knight
coming to D3 to give a check which would
Fork the king and the bishop yeah look
at I mean the pressure is getting to him
only a few seconds left okay he moves
his Bishop out of the range of the White
Knight yeah Magnus I was gonna say it's
mad playing for a win here what are you
doing but uh okay he's creating some
threats with all these night jumps three
pawns running though towards you it's
scary for what you reckon he knows how
to checkmate with Knight and Bishop is
that something Magnus has looked at
maybe he's never had to try it you know
he might know all these other endings
but um it would actually be great if he
does win that one I'd love to see that I
expect he will if he gets to it
um but yeah the valuation bar still
seemed even but I'm sure white is in
more danger here with the black pawns
getting very very close to queening now
Central D5 Square while the king and the
Knight defended the E and the C Pawn
from advancing so still everything under
control but it's really hard to
understand who is playing for a win in
this position yeah I think it's I mean
that's playing for the win just because
he has he can push pawns and uh the
Knight and the bishop are purely
defensive and uh there we see me in
pushing the H Pawn one square foot there
you go one square away from queening
that does tie down the light squared
Bishop to that diagonal but of course
the bishop can still move to in all
directions just along that diagonal well
that was a bit that didn't quite make
sense just so long that diagonal you can
wait still blockading all the pawns the
white king holds the e-4 and the White
Knight holds the C Pawn the bishop holds
the other Pawn uh the H Pawn there and
there we go but still it's playing with
fire and I have a feeling Magnus will
try and hustle on the clock he's going
to play a few quick moves back and forth
back and forth and then he might try
something
I think Magnus is playing for win
despite the fact he knows it should
never ever be a win for white here
um the clock could play a huge huge role
in the deciding this game but I mean he
couldn't go in for the E3 Pawn as well
you can try and attack that with your
knight combine the king in the night and
pick up that E3 Pawn at some point uh
get some real chances to come in with
the King
yeah I think he might try that now but
uh nice work there especially from I
mean putting the bishop as far away as
possible from the White Knight you don't
want to walk into an in double attacks
Knight folks there and I think this is
the problem Tanya maybe the black King's
always going to defend this e-pawn no
way to make progress here uh without
taking even further risks what a game
it's absolutely crazy it's not the both
player it's sort of in like a mutual Zig
Zone can't really improve this position
either ways now they've done maximum and
blacks bishop and King defend that E3
Pawn White's King and Knight can't make
any more progress draw the most likely
outcome now
should be unless we see a miracle here
in a bishop and night end game as Simon
predicts yeah I'd love to see that but I
I it's a bit of a pipe dream here and uh
um I mean why can't white take the other
Pawn that might be worth showing I mean
there is there is a pawn that white
could try to grab here David potentially
uh but it seems very risky because the
white king at the moment is controlling
two pawns and uh if you ever move away
from one of them things go very wrong
but that seems like the only only thing
that needs to be calculated here really
okay try something else so maybe it's
try something else let's just show King
takes porn here would actually be a huge
mistake because suddenly the black king
would be free no longer tied down to
this E Pawn the black king would walk in
and this Pawn will promote maybe even
the king will help this Pawn promote so
you cannot allow the enemy King to get
active so here we see the status quo
just being maintained this is the game
and yeah it still looks like Magnus not
taking too many risks still some night
checks in the air but we've seen
virtually this position before they're
going round in circles now trying to
tease each other trying to trick each
other yeah and it's quite quite good for
men that he does have these waiting
moves because I can tell you one thing
his clock was making me nervous he got
down to seven seconds but because he can
just Shuffle the bishop backwards and
forwards it's all okay
do you know if they repeat the position
three times is it an automatic draw
because it seems to me they repeat this
position about a hundred times now but
uh I I wouldn't be surprised they fall
into a free-fold repetition quite soon
with the King maybe dropping back now
and they are repeating they're repeating
yeah that makes sense and and I'm in
leans back and that's a draw what a
fighting game this was I'm in Tabata by
super impressive with his defense and
resilience from a difficult opening an
exchange Sacrifice by Magnus going for
the mid there a two decisive results in
this game one but Magnus Armin ended in
a draw David what was the highlight for
you well that Magnus game was really
dramatic but for me the Highlight was
that clash between the two youngsters
nordebec Abdul sotorov here with the
white pieces against alireza farouza and
I just want to talk about the theme of
invasion here look at what white did
over the next couple of movies he's
already sacrificed to porn abjector of
and instead of just bailing out towards
a draw or he invaded Bishop to ca and
look at the weird position we are left
with after the white Rook lands in the
enemy camp how often do you see three
pieces like this entrenched in the enemy
territory but this did backfire we saw
okay the White Knight starts joining the
action as well but despite the fact you
have so many active pieces this was
quickly rebuffed with a series of
exchanges and later on if we Zoom
forward we see it was actually the black
king that invaded and this is the final
position the black king was the one that
landed in the white side and this was a
win for black simply due to the Past One
risks taking from abdulf but it did
backfire
defense there by alures are keeping his
karma on his composure in that crazy
position with another bags Rooks and
Bishops into the action let's take a
look at our results uh going into a game
two of the quarterfinals two decisive
games with Wesley so and alireza ferruja
taking the lead in their match while
Magnus amen ends in a draw and Dennis
lasveg the 16 year old Grandmaster holds
world number three Fabiano caruana with
the white pieces the match continues and
we will be back with game to action
foreign
[Music]
but neither would a Sicilian Defense to
the untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
thank you
buckle up the 2023 speed Chess
Championship begins this Monday
September the 4th
16 of the strongest competitors in speed
chess will duke it out until only the
speed chess champion remains will Magnus
Carlsen continue his winning streak and
add this title to his name will Hikaru
Nakamura defend his crown or will world
champion dingler and prove his might in
faster time controls the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
begins September 4th tune in to our
stream on YouTube or twitch as always
use exclamation point SCC and chat for
all the details
calling all chess clubs you are eligible
to participate in Judith polgar's chess
connects us championship
clubs from all over the world are
invited to nominate four players to
compete in the online event on October
14th for the chance to win prizes from
chess.com chessable and Judith Polgar
herself
join us in celebrating the game that
connects us all use exclamation point
chess connects Us in chat to learn more
[Music]
thank you
this tournament is presented by Julius
bear a bank rich in Tradition and with
players and Spectators across
Generations enjoying the game chess
breaks the age barrier the most talented
eight-year-old in the world right now
then from London is a change maker and
one to watch out for and she had a very
special day out with the British prime
minister
and last day I'm at the Prime Minister
and we weren't allowed phones
inside anywhere past the first room
so my dad had to put his phone aside and
and then near that area there was also a
cat
and I just touched his towel
so and then after that um we were both
taken to the Garden to play and then
halfway through our game and the Prime
Minister came came in and he started
asking some questions to us
the Prime Minister was quite nice so and
I was quite excited to meet him as well
so he spent 15 minutes roughly talking
to us
about how we improved and how we started
stuff like that and then he had to leave
to go back to work
I think the reason I was there was
because I think we wanted the because I
think the government announced that they
were going to give some money in for
chess
to the ECF so then um Dominic Lewis and
he he arranged for me and shows to meet
us because they canceled the invitation
at first but then they found a way to
allow us in I think the government's
supporting English test Federation will
help us because it will get lots of
young people to play
and I think it will make more Grand
Masters and because also for women in
the UK I don't think we have any Grand
Masters we have women Grandmasters we're
not Grandmasters so I think that might
help
fully the government support will make
me the first Grandmaster in the UK to be
a woman
I think my friends would be surprised
and they wouldn't believe me that I got
to go to turn Downing Street to meet the
prime minister
an inspiring story there and David
there's been big news of government
funding coming in for uh chess in the UK
how do you see this changing the just
landscape for England yeah first of all
it's fantastic it shows chess is really
booming and being appreciated for its
educational qualities in terms of how
it's going to change things uh in
England in the UK I'm optimistic for the
Next Generation uh as someone who grew
up uh kind of without too much support
and I think we all kind of had to make
it on our own I'm enthusiastic now that
the players the young players that we
see there they will get coaching they
will get given opportunities and like
you said earlier Simon money can change
everything if you have teams if you have
people around you doing the right thing
you can go far so I'm optimistic and
hopefully it will grow chests throughout
the country yeah I mean I think it's a
great initiative I mean these things I
think take time it's like chess you know
to get good at chess it doesn't happen
overnight I mean you have to build it up
right from at the bottom and you you
build on those blocks so uh but a great
great thing you know the prime minister
shown an interesting chess I mean I
think this uh is is a thing that's
across the board now Chess at the moment
is very popular it's becoming more
popular around the world everywhere yeah
and what I love about it is is that it's
kind of bringing chess on different
levels first of all you have it on the
hobby level so it'll be like chess
boards and parks and public places and
then of course you have the Juniors
getting children connected to the game
so that when they're adults they can
appreciate the future stars and then of
course you have the whole Sports chess
as a profession as well so creating
those Pathways to the very top and
that's super important absolutely what a
time it is to be in the Chess World it
truly is the golden generation right now
with the opportunities and the support
and we saw burdana seven and then there
with the British prime minister and we
also have more fun coming up with bodana
here is a sneak peek of something coming
up later today on the show do you know
about Nobel prizes
not over 50 members of the afternoon
have won Nobel prizes Bertrand Russell
Winston Churchill congratul Kipling have
you heard of well you're too young you
don't know all these people
[Music]
when I gave up when I was about 31 to I
was 2 3 90 and I've only played one
greater game since then what did you say
you're rating 1900s 1800 18. even if
you're not not not ahead of me yet
you'll be ahead of me in two or three
years time
[Music]
and here is the official trophy of the
Julius bear generation cup the winner of
the event will earn their own
personalized version you can make your
bed that will be one for the winner of
the Julius bad generation cup and one
for uh the highest bid and you get your
own version as well as a VIP ticket to
the in first and Final in Toronto uh go
and make those bids at chess champs.io
and right now it is all about who will
be champion of the Julius bear
generation cup to get that ticket into
it the season end a grand final it is
time for game two action to start are
you expecting the players to make a
comeback Westy Soul won against Aliano
what does alienov need to do to switch
it up
yeah you know he just needs to forget
about the first game and just
concentrate on putting pressure on his
opponent and in order to do that he has
to pay critical stuff he has to also
remember that his past achievements he's
a great player and he had to not get
overruled by the circumstances he does
start with the white pieces in game two
and not the back alireza made it look
easy in that end game uh David how does
not the back equalize this match now
well for nordebec I think he just needs
to survive this next game he will have
the black pieces he was a bit over
ambitious a bit over aggressive in the
previous game despite the fact it was
completely level and he kind of burnt
his own Bridges so I expect a more solid
game this time and I've just sort of the
longer he stays in this match the more
chances he'll have later on
with an impressive hold against the
Magnus after a tricky tricky opening
Choice there Simon what are you
expecting from that one in game two when
Armin starts with the white pieces I'm
more the same hopefully I mean I think
he has to really push Magnus and just
try to uh get some kind of complicate
messy position that's what he did in the
first game and he got some real chances
there chances to win so uh um it's going
to be a closer match than I think people
expect it definitely that's a really
great Point uh and there we've got the
two players with us and I saw a feature
chat earlier there David you've been on
one of those chairs behind Magnus
not my uh finest to almost sober moments
but I have once or twice been in that
room actually that's where myself and
Magnus filmed our chessboard course
about end games running like a
Grandmaster
um so yeah so that is where the magic
happens where the magic happens in that
room and that's where Magnus has won a
couple of tournaments already this
season on the tour but uh yeah fair play
I mean he did incredibly well in that
first game navigating the mess the
complications and he had some serious
chances including a winning move in the
end game so he should take Confidence
from that against Magnus and also just
keeping up with the pressure that Magnus
was putting on the clock having almost
double the amount of time against almond
but very precise defense there by Armin
in the in game one yeah I mean of course
he had to navigate the opening stage I
mean that must have been very
uncomfortable because you're dealing
with preparation from the world's best
player that's scary so he handled that
very well it's even turned around so he
definitely should be feeling even more
confident now the reason I say even more
confident is that Armin is actually a
very confident player I mean he famously
lost a piece in tata steel this year and
he just carried on as if nothing had
happened and he won that game and uh
there we see Armin in his chair getting
ready for the action he looks pretty
confident right now as well going into
that game too and we saw Magnus on the
screen screen earlier it looks like he
got some sun in there are you Red
Madness it does yeah yeah so maybe yeah
that jet skiing across the harbor is
really uh really giving a bit of a maybe
tan or burn I'm not sure
um and armin's got a pretty bright room
as well isn't he you know all those
lights and they're ready for kickoff
very soon and I think the key thing is I
mean has just got to play something
quite sharp so we are starting off with
what could be an English opening it
might transpose into a king's Indian
defense okay symmetrical English instead
here David it's in honor of us Simon
Ivanka the English opening and uh in
honor of prime minister maybe for Donna
but uh yeah this one very symmetrical so
far the players have been copying each
other and Magnus is actually a
specialist I would say on the white side
of these positions he knows where to put
his pieces it takes a slower uh kind of
approach in these early stages as they
decide what porn structures to go for
which pieces to trade but uh this last
night night move we say Knights on the
rim are dim but this Knight is going to
gravitate towards the center David you
know what is a good move here and uh
it's actually an idea here I mean will
he play it will he play it should we
have a little bit push Harry push Harry
yes I I think he's gonna do it because
it's actually not a bad move in this
particular variation because black can't
stop the H Pawn going uh three squares
up the board here because he's got a
knight in the way of that advance so
H4 is a very decent move I think yeah I
mean well what is Magnus doing Tanya
you're looking at the camera
I think he's doing what we've seen him
doing so many of these events munching
on some noodles done it looks like he
was getting a bite in getting some
energy going there uh magnets for this
food but 986 Knights on the edge falling
off the Hedge bit very often we see
these nights go towards the center of
the board either through F5 or later on
even through the F7 Square once it's
vacated with that pawn now Harry the H
Pawn you guys want to see that move on
the board but does not leave some light
squares week weaknesses
it was gonna happen
uh our men's games this morning I
noticed that he did like to play H4 in
these type of structure so so maybe
Magnus is setting up for that you know
maybe this is uh oh Magnus wanted I
don't know if he's done his preparation
and we'll have done his preparation I
would have thought so and look at that
each point go though David I mean uh
that that that's quite annoying for
black because that black knight
um it's you can be a great piece but it
can also get in the way of some natural
moves I would have thought
he goes H4 he goes to H5 this one's
going to be fire on the board Magnus
Carlson instantly continues with his
development we will come back to this as
other games are taking off let's head
over to Dennis elastic playing with the
black pieces against Fabiano caruana the
first game ended in a draw and Fabi
starts with the King spawn opening yeah
Fabi famous for his 1e4 lines and okay
also famous for the Spanish Dennis
lazovic Rock Solid player he tried to
employ the Berlin Wall there the Berlin
defense but no end games after a quick
trade of minor pieces this game again
taking a slower Pace this is all about
maneuvering now Black's Pawn structure
slightly damaged you see the doubled C
pawns there but it has come at the cost
of the bishop pair so these positions
well trodden very deeply analyzed uh I
would say fabias Fabiano is probably one
of the top three players in the world at
uh kind of maneuvering these types of
positions with white and black so
interesting he's really using his uh
kind of top tier repertoire here against
lazovic shows the respect he has for his
young opponent Point E2 keeping his
options open as well which way will
White Castle we might even see a Fabiano
an aggressive Fabiano Castle on the long
side depending on what Dennis does
it would be interesting suddenly my eyes
were drawn to the air quality because I
have one of these things devices and so
I'm always monitoring it and I was like
oh a little bit higher on the CO2 levels
which does impact on concentration and
there we see the night attack the dark
squared Bishop
yeah I'm kind of interested whether
Fabiano will Castle
to the queen side to the left it's very
much his style he always plays the most
committal kind of principled Chess and
I've noticed he does this against
positional players
definitely and I think that's what the
top players do would they adapt their
Styles according to the opponent right
you try and pinpoint a weakness in the
opening maybe but you also want the type
of position where they can't show their
strength where you can slowly strangle
them make them feel uncomfortable
do you think he's trying to take Dennis
out of his comfort zone he's been
playing pretty quickly up to this point
uh Simon
yeah I mean it seems a pretty standard
position I mean uh again okay here we go
the night diving in to to win one of
those uh Bishops back and the bishop
exchange itself off uh the Berlin
probably Black's best opening nowadays
against one E4 and uh I can't I can't
say that much has really changed her so
far and I I this maneuver very typical
bringing the Black Knight right into the
center of the board
also continues to play fast and
confidently getting his Knight to those
dark Square weaknesses in a fabi's camp
we will come back to this one uh one
player who needs to make a comeback in
his match is Pavel alienov he's playing
against Wesley he starts with the white
pieces might have three on move one it's
Wesley one of the hardest players to
beat when you're when you need to make a
comeback against them yeah
well the Wesley we know at least in
recent times Wesley's been freestyling a
bit experimenting a bit being a bit more
aggressive and wow playing C5 so this is
the ready opening when white brings out
the night so early but uh with Black's
last move he was inviting a
transposition into the Sicilian for
example
um all sorts of Trump's positions white
is so flexible here now it might even
transpose to a king's Indian just with
colors reversed and it's up to Eliana of
how he decides to play this position he
goes for the slow approach no direct
confrontation in the center he's just
gonna start advancing a bit later on but
interesting both sides it feels like
they've got set strategies Wesley's
trying to provoke his opponent Eliana
saying no I'm going to stick to my calm
solid openings and attack you a bit
later on normally good advice against
Wesley theoretical uh player there
himself but I don't know Eliana of his
big strength is his openings and it
feels like he's not going kind of direct
here uh what are your thoughts on this
one Simon Ivanka yeah I mean uh he has
to win a game as well we've got to
remember that because he he lost the
first game
um he's he's not really aiming for an
advantage from this opening he's playing
he's aiming to get a position where he
can hopefully confuse Wesley Wesley can
now capture the pawn and swap the Queens
off but it's uh I think against Wesley
Wesley is so well prepared uh you you've
got to try to do something a little bit
unusual to get any chances and uh I
think that's the strategy that that
White's doing here just not go Mainline
try to draw him into a middle game that
he might not be as accustomed to but I
have to say the the speed is moving
Wesley he seems pretty comfortable as
well here
all right this is going to be another
slow grind the Pavlo you know with the
white pieces needs to try and create his
chances and another player who needs to
do just that is not the back of the
satrov who lost his first game against
alireza not the back with the black
pieces David as you mentioned for him
it's super important to just stop the
bleeding to make sure that nothing goes
too out of control because he will get
his chances with the white pieces in the
next one yeah we've seen it before
throughout the tour this season he's
crushed people when he has white he beat
level aronian in around 20 moves and
he's been playing all sorts of uh
exciting kind of spicy chests with uh
the white pieces so for a disturb I
would recommend just locking up this
game just a draw is fine you still have
two more games later in the day to
strike back white pieces next and uh
okay for Rouge meanwhile of course he
won't be taking too many risks with the
lead he does elect for the Catalan uh
fee and Catering this white Bishop on
the long diagonal and just a very solid
Choice most popular choice these days
with the white pieces it seems and I'm
just a tour of choosing one of multiple
ways here many many ways you can reply
to the Catalan okay now it is
confrontation in the center a lot of
Pawns will fly off the board and we'll
see if White's Bishop sitting there on
G2 does exert influence that tends to be
a small Advantage for white long term in
these types of positions
pretty solid stuff uh there's this
choice of opening and uh black going for
that strategy you mentioned David I
think uh of just trying to make some
exchanges and uh play the position
um but uh farouza he he plays quite a
lot of uh openings nowadays doesn't he I
mean even the London system and the
Jabara London system he's tried these
things out and we see those exchanges
now in the center uh of the board occur
and what will black recapture the Knight
not to give himself isolated pawn and
um yeah pretty normal stuff but it is
probably about that Bishop in the
Catalan is the light Square bishop ever
gonna cause black enough problems that's
the number one rule really it usually
does I have to say seven times out of
ten it's the most annoying piece on the
board and for black the whole issue is
whether he can develop his light squared
bishop and there we see that the center
pawns have been eliminated so I find
that these open positions they tend to
develop on a move by move based is
you're not talking about like big plans
you're just simply trying to activate
your pieces put them on really good
squares with some purpose
yeah hence I do tutorials last move
everything looked almost symmetrical
apart from White's Bishop that we've
been uh harping on about that but yeah
he needs to be active and
I like this last move it's still early
days I do expect fruition to have some
pressure but I'm just a tour of he's so
well prepared despite being so young and
he would only choose the setup against
the Catalan which I think is quite a
rare one uh if he knows what he's been
doing or if he knows what he should be
doing over the next few moves
over the center all dissolved and
liquidated in this one again this is
going to be a slow grind but one which
is super fun right now is the Magnus
almond board and I think we have to rush
to that because Simon the h-bond is all
the way down
286 and oh yeah it's a fun position with
the blacking in the center let's quickly
pull up the Magnus versus uh I'm in
board and there we have it magnus's King
still in the center Alvin spawn on 8-6
yeah I mean this does look very very
interesting and actually this idea of
moving the H Pawn all the way to H6 was
I this is something I never used to do
too much but um it was Alpha zero who
started this approach and then uh other
top players uh in this position you
would often captured a pawn opening up
your Rook that's what I would do to try
and attack but putting it one square
Force just tries to get that grip and
this is kind of an everlasting grip on
the king side and this is a really
committal Choice from Magnus he's taking
a lot of risks today and uh the body
language there I mean also if we're
looking at the cameras quite interesting
uh he gives up a key defender of his
King the dark Square bishop and he he's
got a lock down now White's dark Square
Bishop if white can ever open up the
center I really like White's position
then you know some break as we're seeing
there in the middle of the board
um I mean my my instinct would be that
white white is a very comfortable and
nice position here he's got the two
Bishops he's got Pawn breaks his H Pawn
is always going to cause some problems
of black in the ending
um yeah I mean uh I I prefer white
definitely here yeah I agree I prefer
whites and also one I kind of like flip
the position around I'm thinking what is
Black's plan how is he gonna get the
king to safety and uh like you say Simon
is all going to be about whether white
can just uh push one of his pawns and I
was thinking yeah I like this uh E4 E5
push I also was getting very greedy and
looking at the king side because you
know sometimes I'm just a cave woman at
heart yeah David has sussed me out I
wanted to just open some diagonals for
that dark Square Bishop which is
unchallenged yeah this bishop could
sorry potentially be beautiful and uh
yeah I think it might be a matter of
time here however I've played a lot of
Blitz with Magnus throughout my time and
I've actually had this exact structure
against him if he's able to for example
let's say white plays slowly
um okay he's actually traded off which I
like if he's uh White plays too slowly
here if Magnus is able to Castle Queen
side the black king is super safe over
there and uh suddenly white is a bit
blocked up with Bishops here versus
Knights Knights tend to favor these uh
types of positions maybe hence the last
decision instead I mean deciding okay no
slow playing he took this Knight on D6
with this bishop so it's uh kind of the
same piece configuration now but it's
all about who's pawns are weaker these
black d-pawns versus these white doubled
C pawns uh I still like white but okay
it's okay sorry that was me that was me
I was going to say an amazing pause
sacrifice there but uh it was a mouse
slipper my bad guys you excite us all
there David just testing us see if we're
we're awakened this last decision that I
am you know it's it's really quite a
nice one because you create all these
long-term strategic weaknesses in Black
spawn structure and now that night again
at the edge of the board but heading
towards the center the D5 Square the
Knight can land on to F4 come on to D5
the queen from D1 can improve its
position to Target the the dark sweat
one with Queen D2 Queen F4 ideas it just
feels like it's so much easier to play
this position with white uh to play
these natural moves ahead with white
meanwhile for Magnus again out of the
opening kind of a little stressful to be
able to hold this one you have to say
that I think Amin's got a bit of an
opening Victory here I certainly think
that and now our two resident Grand
Masters have highlighted the plan for
black which was the castle queenside to
the left you now we know that all white
has to do is actually trade off the
knights and then the black king won't be
safe
yeah
yeah and it in these kind of positions
as well I think any kind of middle game
you look at Pawn breaks Pawn breaks like
key to transforming transforming a
position and uh who has the pawn breaks
here and uh the answer must be white
white has a pawn break in the middle
white has a pawn break either way to
attack that black knight and uh black
doesn't really have any any such breaks
himself maybe one brake uh F5 and I
think that's going to help white as well
they're playing some normal Maneuvers
here now I don't think you'd want to
move the White Knight into the center
now would you I mean I think that white
knight is a really nice piece and you've
got to think about whether you want to
allow exchanges or not and I wouldn't
really want to exchange my night off for
that Bishop it feels a bit funny to do
that
um I don't know if David what would you
reckon there yeah normally I'm biased
towards Bishop Simon but here I don't
think it's the best Bishop that you're
left with it's not about what's off the
board that's forgotten it's about what
remains and uh as you say this bishop
looks a bit blunted a bit stuck kind of
staring at a water its own pawns whereas
this Black Knight looks pretty nice
right now in the center I could imagine
for example a pawn push like this one
and either white Rex's Pawn structure or
the Black Knight even gets access into
some really juicy outposts so definitely
something to hold off on uh if you're
Tabata by often they do say the threat
is stronger than the execution so
keeping that one up your sleeve for
later we'll keep Magnus guessing and it
might come with a bit more strength
later in the game first he has to solve
an issue where to put the white king
it's not just the black king that has a
choice of which side to Castle on it's
uh the white king as well I tend to
think he wants to kind of hide out in
the center or the queen side just
because you kind of want to keep
protection of your Harry Pawn uh the H
Pawn here but yeah it's not easy to
decide
oh Castle's King side I was about to say
that's the one thing I would not do I
was not expecting that either I was
gonna answer your question by saying
actually you can slide the king to the
right to the F1 square and just live
there or attempt to live there happily
ever after and both sides now have uh
Castle to the right
and yeah I'm surprised by this because I
thought White's plan was just simply to
actually take the action to the left
side of the board and just push up the a
pawn and try to open up some lines for
The Rook there
interesting position meanwhile uh black
very quickly centralizes and
full of Rich possibilities for both
sides uh it does strike me as the type
of position that Magnus quite likes as
black but objectively I think I would
still choose White
yeah very much in the balance though
yeah and the clock might be that 17th
piece that we keep talking about during
uh the Champion's chest start down to
about four and a half minutes Harry the
H Pawn could turn out to be a weakness
in these positions a once targeted uh by
either the Knight on E5 or any piece it
can become really hard to actually keep
that pawn protected so Armin now
switches up to the other side of the
board starts advancing on the queen side
to create a weakness that can be
targeted perhaps a future weakness on
the B6 Square this one's all about the
pawn game Pawn structures all along the
other game with a very similar team is
Dan Laz versus Fabi I think you guys are
gonna love the position that we have on
that one with opposite side cast links
and a very non-standard Pawn structure
wow it took me a while to see that black
king on B8 kind of camouflage there over
on the queen side because usually this
is
typical position for this opening but
the black king would be all the way on
the other side of the board so here
definitely adding some extra uh kind of
stakes adding some extra spice to this
position and like you said Tanya it's
very rare you see doubled bee pawns
actually here's Double B pawns for both
sides B squared but uh not c squared if
you have this podcast but uh yeah the
interesting position I would tend to
favor the Knight over the bishop here
because it is quite block quite closed
but I am fearful for Black's King
who do you pick here Simon
I'm well I mean I I quite like black
actually I mean uh I I think the black
king could be a weakness definitely if
white can open up some lines but I'm
just looking at Black's Rooks and and
that uh pressure right down the center
the black Brooks uh uh exert onto their
pawn and I'm also looking at the
evaluation bar which says black is
better to be honest you know let's just
throw that in there you know um but
there is a weakness in the middle of the
board and uh black has that weakness to
kind of nibble the queen can maybe come
over one square and already threaten to
take that pawn and win it so uh yeah so
maybe just a little bit better for black
here and Fabby I think has to try and
create some chances against the black
king but the only way I can do that is
something like B4 a pawn break but I
can't I can't see how that would ever be
possible in this position so uh bit of
danger for Fabby maybe here do you think
he's feeling the hit uh air quality is
great but very warm in his room uh
Fabiano here and under pressure on the
board as well yeah you mentioned uh not
feeling comfortable no not having a plan
necessarily going to be three what does
that do maybe he's just trying to tie up
the opponent's pieces and no direct
threats as far as I can see but yeah I
would I would be feeling the heat here
if I were Fabiana gotta say this is a
crafty move though because uh black
can't actually take the pawn on a D3
because the night on E6 is loose
yeah so definitely tying up the
opponent's pieces uh Rook taste Pawn is
what you want to do just to point out
your idea there Ivanka suddenly the
Knight would hang on E6 you also have to
worry about uh potential Rook takes A6
ideas if you're uh Dennis lazovic
sometimes uh this Pawn might be hanging
because the pawn on B7 is pinned right
now you're defending everything with
this Rook along the sixth rank
but yeah what next both sides a bit
stuck yeah I was just wondering also
whether this queen maneuver is also to
put there it goes on on the board to
park it on the C4 square and uh also say
well a fence is the best form of defense
and also tie the black pieces down to
the weak C5 Pawn but what about Queen B5
or something now I mean uh I mean if uh
has he played I don't know I mean if if
this this Pawn in the center of the ball
could easily just drop uh and uh I think
fabby's yeah it's a tricky position I
feel for him yeah yeah very tricky I
love that move and that's it's very much
actually in Dennis lazovic's Style Just
minimal risk if he's feeling aggressive
he might push the B Pawn but uh that
would have severe consequences for the
black king I think it's much more in his
style and having lost to him many times
on line at Blitz uh Dennis Leslie he
loves an endgame and uh Queen to B5 as
you say Simon trade-off and leave your
opponent with weaknesses logical and
quite possibly strong
Queen B5 the queen trade you see your
opponent's weaknesses and go for that
again very impressive play he's making
his debut in the Champions chest or the
youngest player this season actually to
play in division one game one it was
convincing a convincing hold for Dan Laz
and this one he with the black pieces is
the one pushing this D3 weakness that he
pointed out it's on the board a queen B5
and I'm just wondering for Fabi could
there be ideas of trading and trying to
Target those doubled b-pawns that Rook
on A1 can slide up to A5 and try and hit
on Black's weaknesses yeah I think we'll
see that Tanya uh what else can you do
as Fabiano here process of elimination
not much else
and uh there we go you'll move on the
board that's a nice spot as well because
that wasn't previously a weakness now
that's the second time in this game
we've seen Double B pawns for black and
how to defend suddenly blacks pieces
they all look perfectly placed but
slightly overworked
and uh yeah this is the downside I mean
I would have done exactly what Dennis
lazovic is doing for example it's my
style as well to go into an end game but
sometimes if you're too focused on the
type of position the concrete kind of
specifics
tend to yeah not always be perfect so
right now dilemma how to resolve this
tension with all the pawns you can take
a pawn of your own but you also lose a B
Pawn and that might just fizzle towards
a draw
interesting moment here
yeah maybe you can use your king now
potentially but I I yeah maybe maybe
it's just not an advantage that those
pawns come off because
black hasn't won that pawn he's just
exchanged that weak white porn for one
of his own so there's not really many uh
weaknesses left if uh the pawns just get
exchanged here that black can attack
very solid game again though and uh you
know this is uh kind of kind of kind of
the way a young Magnus used to play
sometimes he used to play in a similar
way you know going for the grind and
playing in what you would have thought
is a very mature style very positional
style from The Young Dennis so we're
going to be seeing a lot more of him I
think in the future aren't we loads more
do you think that playing Styles have
evolved from generation to generation
100 yeah I mean uh my generation when I
was learning when I was like I don't
know 10 years old computers weren't that
strong so uh I'm beginning holiday with
my dad uh he was a chess player as well
and we had a look at one position
um for about seven days you know and
nowadays you put that one position on
the computer for seven seconds and it
would solve it so that is the difference
but I kind of miss those days because
you can really you can really get like
uh you know involve the story of the
position and computers I've kind of
changed that a lot it's much more
concrete now the way people analyze I
hope it was at least a fun position to
analyze Simon seven days is a long time
Mainline Berlin David
all about the end game
is all about the end game in this one
meanwhile in the alien of Wesley so
match up it's all about whether eleanorf
can make a comeback he does have the
white pieces but it feels like Wesley is
the one who's managed to gain space on
the king side meanwhile Eleanor's Knight
on the edge might fall off the Hedge I'm
liking Wesley's position here I'm loving
Wesley's position you know he has the
center he has the space the evaluation
bar completely agrees he also has the
potential to open up the position when
he chooses or even push forward with the
F Pawn
just I just like it and you kind of hit
the nail on the head there Tanya it's
all about that White Knight on A4 it's
just a terrible piece it has no purpose
on the board it has no potential either
and this in effect means that
um elianov is playing a piece down on
the king side
and that's where the action will happen
you'll write your Banker I think Wesley
here he's done everything perfectly it's
about what to do next and I was about to
say he's going to start pushing his
pieces towards the king side he starts
by improving this Knight and uh sooner
or later there will be unbearable
tension on this Central Pawn look at the
bishop look at the pawn the night now
everything hitting this one and also the
just the thought of more Pawn storming
towards the white king is going to be
terrifying for weight sooner or later
and uh yeah if you ever dare open things
up if you ever release the tension then
whoops suddenly after a trade here
um at the very least black can just
simply recapture this Pawn but now it's
more pronounced the fact that this uh
White Knight is sitting on the edge of
the board uh there's always going to be
checks double attacks in the air
and yeah essentially the action is
happening where your pieces aren't it's
not just one bad piece as well in the
current position it's uh the Knight on
A4 look at the knight in E1 as well it's
just a bit stuck everything's wrong
smelly with this position
smelly is the right word yeah I mean
this is a very similar to a line
reversed and and that night which you've
both brilliantly pointed out on the the
edge of the board is is always the main
issue because you don't really have
anywhere great to maneuver that night
back to but here you've got those King
side problems as well so it just looks
really good for black this position more
space chances to attack better pieces
um what more do you want I mean Simon
that's that's a long enough list I feel
that one that's uh yeah it just it just
looks really good for for black here yes
Space Invaders you always want to win
Connect Four if you win Connect Four in
chess it means normally you have a
pretty good Pawn structure and that
means uh yeah you have a pretty good
outline pretty good chances in the game
Eliana need something magical now to
fight back but I don't see it and uh it
looks like a dark day for him darken is
a room as well not looking good on the
board meanwhile very well lit and all
those trophies uh at the back uh it's
something that has we've seen him before
in this room and it kind of gets a lot
of inspired play by Wesley and let's
point out that Wesley if he finishes in
top four it doesn't matter if he wins
the event or the next one he books his
spot into Toronto so he needs a good
start in the Julius bear generation cup
and Eleanor trying to create play on the
king side is this something real or is
this desperation
I'm I'm hesitant about this decision
just kind of basing it on those black
and white rules that were taught when we
were kids and it says never push pawns
on the side that you're weakest and he
goes and he's pushing his Pawn to H5 so
I'm thinking okay that feels a little
bit off to me but let's take a look at
the clock times I'm seeing that not that
much time remaining for both players
maybe it's worth a shot desperate times
call for different measures absolutely
Ivanka and David I think we've got to
check it out what actually happens if
Wesley was to grab that H5 Bond yeah we
need to be consistent we love pushing
the H Pawn here but uh it feels like an
exception and uh you're right Ivanka if
uh Wesley grabs this Pawn I'm assuming
you mean with the Knight first of all
then I guess the idea is to take this
Pawn but I'm saying I guess because I
don't really see it it feels like okay
I'm maybe after a trade for example uh
you're hoping that after one black piece
takes you cannot take with a pawn I
think this is eliana's idea uh because
suddenly the Knight on the edge would
hang so if you take with a piece then I
think he's banking on the fact that this
would be a fork a double attack but I
see the evaluation bar Drop Like a Rock
uh what is the idea here the winning
move for black
it could be a knight G3 but it's other
ideas as well and then jumping a knight
in I think you might be right yeah yeah
okay and even if there is a trade of
Rooks White Queen is trapped here no
matter where it goes even if you step
back Rook to F1 and material disappears
The Black Queen will start making her
way in as well this would be decisive
and we might be headed in this direction
Knight takes porn on the board great
calculation from Wesley and now if he
takes this bishop followed by taking
this Pawn we could see that winning
tactic
yeah I I think it was more desperation
that that idea and we've actually had a
rare moment in chess history here where
um the move H5 is probably not a good
move so frame it and remember that one
because uh it nearly always is a good
move but this is that one very rare
exception
um so yeah I mean this is it's just a
bad position for for white all round
um yeah that's nothing more to be said
really
yeah now you're pulling down with a bad
position as well so uh everything
against Eliana it's just that first
result influence display here he took
too many risks and it's going to
backfire yet again he's going to be on
the brink of being pushed down to the uh
elimination bracket
Wesley with the extra pawn and all the
play in the position and you might be
seeing the spectacular tactic that has
been pointed out by Simon if white tries
to Fork those two nights uh one of them
will jump into that kg3 square now the
other player who looks like he is in big
trouble is not a backup to satrobe and
he might be going to a two-point deficit
and in this format that almost feels
like like match over it's so hard to
make a comeback from that and here it's
all about comparing peace positions look
at that white Rook on D7 attacking the
pawn the Knight on e4 a monster Can't Be
Moved uh is there anything in another
box favor in this one no
I mean I I'm really worried that
actually why with this G Pawn push is
actually he ain't going to go ahead I'm
thinking that's going to be followed up
by Harry and then okay H5 I mean the
only thing in his favor is that it's his
move there you go
um no
um
I have to say uh Ali Razer for you know
he's playing so well at the moment
winning two title Tuesdays as he did uh
yesterday in a row is an incredible
achievement only kind of like Hikaru
does that on a on a sort of regular
basis and maybe Magnus but uh this yeah
this as you say Ivanka it just looks
horrible and this is an example where
Harry to H5 is a good plan as it nearly
always is because it is actually
Checkmate uh if it gets that square so
um we certainly want to get the pawn all
the way up the board there yeah and I
just want to highlight a mating that and
some of the potential pitfalls that
await this black king it has no
Defenders around it if you look at the
right half of the board the black king
has no Defenders three attacking pieces
and of course the H Pawn will add to
that for example I was thinking okay
black needs some counter play he pushes
the pawn to H6 but if he had instead
jumped to uh try and capture this white
a pawn after all you're about to promote
then look at this mating tactic the pawn
steps forward threatening Checkmate in
one move black gives himself an escape
square but after for example Knight's F6
oh not that one maybe that's even
stronger maybe bishop to F6 uh then this
is simply decisive the black king uh on
the seventh rank is such a checkmated
it's a nice one there of Rook G8 David
isn't there I mean this is maybe Worth
showing because uh this is the I think
the and uh juvanka is the expert check
mates and so are you Simon yeah this
this is the first ever Checkmate
recorded the Arabian checkmate with the
Knight and the the The Rook the first
ever recorded in in any text anywhere if
you want your chess history then
actually this is one case where I got it
but we'll come to the quiz another
moment later on another bag in big
trouble and the other player who is in
big trouble and we need to rush to that
game Magnus versus Amin look at that
Magnus is managed to create two fast
spawns on either side of the board and
the H Pawn is rushing down he doesn't
even need to do it right now he can try
and deflect that white night from
defending the H1 Square meanwhile
armin's King tied down to defending the
a pawn is there any hope for white in
this position David oh the only hope was
that maybe black got a bit Hasty and
impatient and promoted the pawn there
which would have won the White Knight
but suddenly White's king would have
raced to gobble up all the remaining
black pawns now it's simple it's a
simple case of the White Knight being
completely dominated we talked about
Knights on the edge knights in the
corner are even worse and sooner or
later Magnus will make a dart towards
that white knight first he clears up
cleans up the other side of the board
and uh earlier it's what we call the
trousers it's the A and H pawns that the
knights hate the most and when you have
two of them like that like two trouser
legs uh that is decisive and okay this
white knight is uh not gonna be able to
fight against Black's whole Army and
look it's about to buy on the camera he
was just like okay done with this one
and it's end games Magnus in end games
you cannot survive against him simple uh
simple as that and I'm pretty sure that
we're gonna see that trick that we saw
earlier with the Black Knight trying to
deflect the White Knight I'm forcing
into the corner it's gonna appear soon
oh maybe not not now
yeah just don't go Knight E4 no that's
one mood to avoid but this is very
simple
and uh yeah I mean uh two pawns up
Queen's coming
and uh yeah he's pretty good at the
ending I I do agree he knows his stuff
and like this there it is it's got to
happen now
like it's about to make a new Queen to
battle by does resign we have a result
what number one takes the lead and he
got his leg up there you're right this
is you know you we could actually just
not look at the position and guess how
Magnus is getting on right I mean as
soon as that leg goes up he's doing well
he's doing well and someone who's still
doing well is alireza farusha but
congratulations to up to store for even
making this complicated suddenly he's
given up a couple of Pawns but he has
active pieces the Black Knight now
looking much better than it was uh
Black's King in far less danger this
game is still alive
still up against it though farouza
pushing those pawns three minutes each
any hope of a comeback here
what do we think it's pretty Grim I mean
uh I guess one of one of the things I'd
be trying to do if I was black here is
try to get rid of White's Pawn on A2 uh
you know this if I can somehow attack
that pawn uh on A2 and win that pawn
then I can get I can't see how you can
do that though
um and white sea Pawn is looking very
dangerous better than it was though at
least you're not getting checkmated it's
always a good start and some chances
here yeah some chances but I feel that
they depend on the on Black's work and
it activated and look at it it's just
saddled behind White's Pawn I just don't
think that
there's going to be a rescue here that
was a beautiful move a really classy
move just caging that black Rook with
White's Knight important combo there uh
yeah fairuzia seems to be in top form
maybe it's just that freshness not
having computed it as much lately after
satoroff he needs to survive this game I
don't see a comeback from him if he goes
two games behind here not with the way
that farage is playing
but what to do active pieces for white
and a passive black Rook that's enough
let alone the two-point deficit here and
he's trying to go around with his Rook
but it would just take too long I mean
we we talked about Wesley so having a
bit of a bad uh World Cup but it's maybe
worth pointing out the naughty Beck as
well he's one of my actual outside picks
to to win the World Cup but he he got
knocked out very very early in that
competition as well so
um you know he's young he's gonna have
bad results but he's uh that that was a
bad competition for him the last one he
played him yeah it still feels like this
young generation there trying to feel
their limits trying to see how far they
can push things especially notabeck he's
kind of upped his game in terms of
aggressiveness just in the last few
months he's taking massive risks in
classical rapid Blitz all formats and
sometimes that comes with uh kind of
inconsistent results but he'll find his
uh kind of find his feet there and yeah
it might not just be in this game
unfortunately it's a really good tactic
that isn't it because I I think one of
the biggest mistakes you see in Chess at
nearly all levels I mean you go to some
of these tournaments in Britain and it's
the same sort of gentleman in their in
their 70s who have been playing the same
openings since they were 20 years old
and they they just don't want to take
any risks and mix things up but you've
got to mix things up and that might mean
you have a series of bad tournaments bad
results until you sort of uh understand
chess better and it's important to to do
that you know to take some risks there
well I I feel it there's any way to not
just get stuck in your own sort of set
ways playing I I agree with you but I'm
also quite torn on this issue because I
can appreciate that um not everyone
wants to improve
some people just actually because I had
a conversation with someone who's going
to remain nameless and and because I was
constantly pushing them to play in the
top sections and they were like why are
you doing this to me this is a
tournament this is just holiday for
surely I want to be a big fish in a
little Pond those are those exact words
but surely they'd rather win it than not
win the competition they wanted to win
the Little Pond section so they have to
still play well to win that but yeah I
see what you're saying but so I mean but
I definitely agree with you in terms of
improvement you've got to shake things
up you've got to work on all aspects of
the game like you you know if you notice
that you're weak in Dynamics you know
try to play Dynamics try to train on
them I always say get your friends
involved on those areas of Chess that
you really don't like so you don't like
endgames bring your friends and try and
study some end games it'll be much more
fun that way yeah with modern chess you
have to have a very Universal style of
player you can't be an aggressive player
or a positional player or a strategic
you can't have clear holes and gaps in
your chest to be the best and to play
and compete against the best you need to
be good in all kinds of positions so
kind of working on those weaknesses and
switching it up in the bigger picture
it's always a big payoff and these
youngsters they're so motivated and
inspired even by each other I'm sure for
uh for Noni back for example seeing the
success of let's say gokish or
pragnananda inspires him to improve his
play I know that's the case in India for
all these youngsters they're not only
good friends Rivals as well and kind of
improving together seeing the
performances of each other meanwhile
this position it looks like it's going
to be a tough task for noribbeck to get
any chances or improve here but how is
white making progress you know you're up
how many pawns is that he's up two pawns
you've got this incredible passer on C5
uh to start pushing already is it time
to go C6 I think you can you probably
can calculate your way to Victory but
being a lazy old man that I am I would
want to just slowly improve the white
keying improve uh push the importance
guess who's not a lazy old man exactly
that's why he's one of the best players
in the world if you're a lazy old man
what what does that make me
are you actually calling yourself an old
man this is uh this is really bad news
yeah but this is very clinical right it
did look like black was gonna win a pawn
but with this Rook to be seven well that
wins white a night but there is some
hope and it's a faint hope that uh black
can maybe win the a pawn and with that
keep some chances alive if he doesn't
get checkmated first which is Hazard
yeah it's also hazard in chess game
checkmates but you're right the a pawn
is still a faint hope and I expect this
is why uh naughty Beck hasn't resigned
because uh you know it's quite close to
queening and he's going for that pawn
now but the night will come to F7 and
rookie six is a big
it was a bit of an eyebrow race but it's
hard to fight this position it was a
lost position regardless but alireza
finishes his game two takes a two-point
lead against not a back ending up with a
Checkmate in that not a back with a
two-point deficit with the two-point
deficit things are heating up in this
quarterfinal match uh David what was the
big moment well there were big moments
in all of the games and I just want to
highlight in that final Clash we saw
between farrugia and Abdul sator of
Battle of the same generation there that
uh it is deciding when to take the
Queens off that can be decisive we saw
Magnus Carlson win an end game as soon
as the Queens came off and here I think
really instructive from farrugia he's
got the better structure long term due
to these really bad black e-pawns in the
center and due to this he was happy to
trade Queens not just that but he
realized that the quality of his pieces
this white Rook on the seventh rank with
all the targets this white knight coming
around to a beautiful outpost on e4 this
wedge Bishop as well Superior to its
counterpart he knew that all of that
combined would give him a decisive
Advantage really instructive went to
trade Queens when not to and here he
chose the perfect moment
very nice and also great technique there
on display by alireza in both his games
let's take a look at our scoreboard
Magnus Carlsen a turnaround in that one
and uh um lost to Magnus in game two
Magnus takes the lead Wesley saw with a
two-point lead against Eleanor Wesley
needs only a draw to wrap up this match
and it's the same for alireza which
means not a back and Eleanor are in a
must win a game we will be back with a
game's reaction don't go anywhere
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
the game find your local group or take
the lead at meetup.com chess that is
meetup.com chess and we all love to play
chess with our family and friends and he
has a very special story of one
Norwegian family where age is just a
number you know what they say families
that play together Stay Together
30.
[Music]
I'm Ingrid I'm 31.
I'm ignoring I'm 55. yeah for sure
yeah
there was a good children's chess
Community where we lived so English
joined there and I also joined that as a
smaller brother
in the beginning of the two of us and
mom realized that if she was going to
drive us and stay with us for the
tournament she might as well play and
Grandpa started when he was a kid
and who is the family chess champion
although there's no official tournament
or anything to confirm
and I think Christmas is the main season
for chess so we can play you know
between the broadcast games and so on
and they're still friends after one of
you
yeah mostly yeah it's nice to have
something to enjoy together spend time
together while having something a bit
active to do and we can also discuss and
share experiences and so on
I'm in his played every year for a while
now and he always has a lot of nice
games in the tournament so I think it's
very impressive that he's able to to
keep it going for this very intense week
every year will we see him play at 100
years old hopefully yeah I think so
[Music]
how cool is that to be able to play
chess with your grandfather and with
your parents just amazing stuff and here
are some of the big chess families
across generation the three polka
sisters do that Susan and Sophia who of
course won the great of the game uh it's
just amazing what that family has
achieved Anna and Maria music who
continue to be the top female players in
the world the van Forest family
generations of chess players there you
got Elizabeth butts with her father he's
a Grandmaster as well and of course PR
kremling and Anna crownling how was it
for you guys you do you have chess
players in your family
I wouldn't say I have chess players in
my family but I was taught by my dad
when I was five years old I was
apparently a naughty boy I dispute that
and uh to kind of quiet me to uh yeah at
least make me a bit more busy on a rainy
day he taught me chess and I'm forever
grateful yeah actually I come from a
chess playing family you know my my
whole family play chat except my mom and
I know she'll be watching so hi Mom but
uh um yeah and I actually married into a
chess playing family as well and it's
quite exciting watching the new
generation get better at chess and
they're so quick and they're so
dangerous but it was a real nice
experience you know you know every
Saturday we were famous because we were
quite a big family you know we would
have roll up in this big car and then
all of us would just get out and play
chess sometimes we would be scary
sometimes we wouldn't do so well
yeah that's the same here I got a bit of
a chess family as well I played in the
the same team as my my dad and my older
brother once and uh my older brother was
quite a lot older than me but he he
actually was pretty good and he drew a
carp off once and uh was I think
National Champion a couple times as well
so and I know your brother is
international Master as well so yeah so
I think it helps probably
um to to have that love of Chess and uh
Tanya you you've got a bit of a chess
background as well I guess not a test
background it's a bit like David no
chess players in the family but it was
my Grandad who taught me how to play he
was in the Army uh and he retired a
general he's fought man he was and he'd
have all these stories about when he was
out many times late at night or when
things would get really heavy a lot of
these army people would sit down and
have a game of chess whenever they would
get those couple of minutes so it was uh
it was a big sport in the Indian army
sort of a strategic battle game so he
always loved chess and when I was a kid
he introduced me to us and then I was
the one who taught my dad how to play so
it was a bit of a generational switch up
there
but uh yes it's uh it was an incredible
story to watch uh with the three
generations uh in that family playing
chess and right now it is going to be
about all the chess that's going to be
played in the Julius bear generation cup
as game three action is about to start
how difficult is it in this format to
make a comeback with a two-point deficit
two-point deficit you need a bit of luck
you afterwards yeah exactly you're
playing not just the best plays in the
world but if your opponents have won two
games in a row they're informed they're
full of confidence and these players
they know how to shut down games that's
the most difficult uh part especially
for someone like eliano who needs to
strike back against Wesley so one of the
most solid players out there so uh yeah
you just need to keep the games alive
and pray and Hope
be able to strike back meanwhile Magnus
takes the lead in his match against Amin
tabatabai continues to munch on some
food in a very very messy room we've
seen that before this background like
you said David great jazz great air
great hair by Magnus and some great
chess as well today yeah some great
chess and actually uh just during the
break I was playing through that last
endgame anyone who wants to learn about
night end games go and play through that
one really really instructive stuff
is doing his business usual Magnus
business is usually there in that last
game but okay so that's advice played
well we shouldn't forget that and next
game if he continues the same form he'll
have a chance I need someone who was
putting the pressure on Magnus in game
one and quite a while in game two as
well the thing with this world cup win
and Magnus as he said completed it uh
you know his entire career Arch getting
that one big win in now it's about
having fun yeah for Magnus I think chess
has always been fun you know I've
noticed that about him yeah
it's got a massive plate or something
look like a kebab to me
but yeah I was gonna say about Magnus
you know if they're ill whenever I've
seen Magnus play it always looks like
chess is his meditation this is his
place where he's comfortable I've seen
him in press conferences after he's just
lost and he's fuming but then you know
people start discussing the lines and he
immediately forgets his anger and he
gets absorbed into the game and I
remember that video of him as a kid
where he the whole family was just like
talking chilling and he there was a
Magnus with the new and chess magazine
just flicking it through things and I
also know from David that said Magnus is
always talking chess and always
following people's games and even people
that you wouldn't necessarily expect and
yeah I'm just talking because I don't
want anything about gonna eat
and there we go but we were talking
about Chess families and Magnus himself
comes from one his dad's a chess player
I've seen him play open events as well
as sisters so there is a lot of Chess
going on in the Carlson Family and we've
got the king spawn opening David what do
you make of these first few moves at the
archangels by black yeah that's right uh
early days here I like what tabataway is
doing he's still he's chosen quite an
ambitious setup for Black uh black
Bishop out there on C5 on a really nice
diagonal and okay this game is not going
to fizzle out to a quick draw Magnus
can't uh maybe guide it towards an end
game something that he might favor him
sister butter by as his chances he needs
to decide now though this pin for me is
black is always the most frustrating
thing it's kind of provoking black to
come forward uh he always see the white
Bishop drop back I assume rather than
trade-off and then Black's pawns might
start muttering G5 kingside attack do
you guys agree with the feature tap the
Messier the room the greater the genius
disagree completely strongly disagree
Simon you
yeah my room is pretty massive so yeah
definitely yeah 100 yeah Messier the
more genius you are yeah 100 I agree
yeah not that I've seen your room I just
met like uh yes welcome over anytime
David
but the chess has been equally messy in
this matchup and as you mentioned David
that an ambitious approach by uh amen
the bishop coming out the dark Squad
Bishop coming out early on keeping it
ahead of the pawn chain rather than
behind the pawn chain is there any
chance of black going all out on the
king side pushing Gary the Jeep on this
time
I should go for that especially in the
match situation A draw is fine he'll get
a chance with white in the final game of
the day but you might not get another
chance to be aggressive and uh pushing
the G Pawn breaking this pin we see
between the white dot Square bishop and
The Black Queen on the board now and
that does signal aggression we're going
to see a really imbalanced game where
black has sees space all over the board
on both flanks now black has advanced
Pawns of course comes with the downside
of creating weaknesses but
at least yeah you might potentially
throw those points even further forward
storm the white king side I really like
it but of course still complicated I
love it it's going to be a fun one Gary
the DuPont down the board it looks like
I mean he doesn't care he is playing
with the black pieces he's going for the
aggressive approach and meanwhile we've
got a kickoff in the Dennis lazawick
versus Fabiano caruana and Fabi with the
lead in his in their matchup Dennis
starts with D4 so he's switched up from
the English that we saw
oh I think it was the Catalan yes it was
a Catalan yes and a repeat second
Catalan of the day uh for Dennis lazovic
sticking to what served him pretty well
in game one where he exerted some slight
pressure on Fabiano had the very
comfortable side of a draw and uh this
match is so in the balance that I don't
blame him for staying consistent and
okay first new move of today at least uh
this A5 move a trendy type of idea
against the Catalan gaining space on the
queen side for black but I've seen this
go wrong for black as well uh often
you're not fighting for the center here
uh what are your thoughts on this
Fabiano trying to surprise his young
opponent
yeah I mean Fabiano is one of the best
prepared players I've ever seen I mean
again he's he's got the luxury of having
a a well-established team behind him uh
who helped him fight for the world
championships and that must be a great
uh Advantage I mean I'd love to have
people who are doing all the hard work
for me uh you know while I was eating my
Kebab like Magnus or something you know
it'd be great and he's moving pretty
quickly here bring the Knight out and I
also think against someone who just
can't be his experienced because of his
age uh that that trying something a
little bit different is a good strategy
to do so yeah I think it's a good Ploy
from Fabiano this yeah coming from
Fabiano I think it is a good Ploy but I
have to say it positionally is very
risky because you've broken some rules
first of all the light Square Bishop is
stuck there on C8 it doesn't have a
great future also you put the night on
C6 in front of his own pawns and this is
generally not a good idea and I love
what Dennis has done he's just moved his
ape Pawn one square up just to control
the range of that now on C6 and it's
gonna you know Fabiano has to find a
very concrete way to develop his pieces
and I suspect that's why he's pushed his
a Pawn off the board
yeah really committal stuff as you say
Ivanka and uh later there might be ideas
of the Black Knight on C6 on C6 which uh
blocks the pawns to kind of spring
forward via A5 to B3 but you've
abandoned the center this is like a
dream Catalan position for lazovic if he
can consolidate so if he can find good
squares how many are squares for his
pieces maybe a safest Square for the
White Queen but uh yeah early days I
like White's chances yeah
impressively
and earlier on I said that Fabi has
taken the lead it's actually been two
draws so I stand corrected there their
match has been even so far with a 1-1
score but the one match where uh there
is a two-point deficit Wesley so needs
only a draw to wrap up his match against
Eleanor and he starts with the white
pieces this is a big ask from melunov
even to survive game three
yeah but you know it's your chance right
you'll play first time division one
you're facing Wesley so what can you do
you just forget about what's happened
and uh smile go with it and I saw a very
interesting interview from Fabi and he
was saying that when you're in this
situation you are in a must-win
situation you have to depend on some
luck but that Norm that luck comes from
the opening and it's whether the
opponent can lock down the position or
not if they can simplify lockdown well
then sorry you're out of luck and these
top players they know how to make the
draw but uh there we see Eliana he has a
chosen to play it like um what would you
call it was this a perk is this a mix
between the modern and the hippo right
yeah and this is we saw this in the last
tour that Fabiano played this as black
against the same thing and another
player as well when a two players with
the black pieces and must win situ
situations had this exact setup we see
here and white setup seems to kind of
force this idea that black has to go
into this hippo so it's uh yeah but all
the pieces remain on the board this this
one yeah exactly there's still tension
you know white we'll have to guess a
horn break black is going to go or is it
going to be C7 C5 maybe the Deep one
maybe the E Pawn who knows but there
will be action at the later stages of
the middle game
the question that if whether you know
we'll be able to take the March 2 game 4
or not he needs to win a must win
situation and we have been seeing
players in a must win uh taking this
approach of this opening with the black
pieces which looks really passive but
the whole concept is as you said just
keep all the pieces on the board keep
the tension on the board I think Hikaru
as well played this in the World Cup uh
in must win situation so it's really
catching up on a popularity there we
will keep an eye out on this one but
we've got liftoff soon in The Other
Board where a player is in a must-win
situation and it is not a bag is he
thinking about his opening or is he
praying right now
they're both just admiring the ceiling
Beth harmonstyle no debac okay I'm
expecting E4 just spreading butter there
but uh he did become World rapid
Champion by basing his repertoire on the
English opening these youngsters they
play everything but uh either way he
needs something special from the opening
from the early stages as we were
discussing earlier still staring up
there Noddy back
let's get that game going
yeah I mean he he probably very aware of
what um
faruza also plays as well so he's just
trying to work out a system that will
give him give him some chances and uh
he's gone D4 and uh this is really his
bread and butter is it I guess it's fair
to say this is uh what he's played uh
most of the time and we're now going to
a queen's Indian and
into a Queen's Gambit pretty solid setup
from freudia here
yeah and lots of choice for black on
this next move they call this at the top
level they call it the main position uh
after grishock famously said it in an
interview because black has like eight
or nine very decent moves uh to choose
from which will lead to different types
of uh play different Natures of play and
farouza I think he uh had success in the
first game of the day if I remember
correctly by just developing his Bishop
his ducks go Bishop to E7 just getting
castled playing very traditionally very
classically so I'm surprised to see him
pause uh maybe not wanting to repeat and
okay he goes for the Rock Solid C5 this
has a very drawish reputation they call
it the Berlin of D4 yeah didn't Fabiana
caruana tell us in the interview with
Norway chess that he deliberately tries
to avoid this line because it's so
drawish yep I think all the top players
these days when I Was preparing for the
World Cup I thought okay just in case I
need a solid weapon up my sleeve maybe I
should add this but then it was just too
dry even for me wow
I think that's a red herring there
nothing is too dry foreign
[Laughter]
symmetrical Pawn structure is very
likely here and with that
winning chances for white might be
minimized yeah interesting and good
choice for furition not necessarily his
style that's the one thing I would say
he's not accustomed to playing with the
handbrake on uh he wants to play playing
chaotic positions and that served him
well so far
interesting start well a chaotic
position in this one is hard to imagine
but meanwhile chaos is on on the Magnus
board so let's head over to that one and
we see some pieces hanging Black's
attacking White's Queen on D1 the White
Knight on H4 is white forced to jump in
with the Knight to keep the material
balance well it's interesting Tanya
that's the first move that comes to my
mind jumping in Knights F5
counter-attack The Black Queen but
Magnus did just bring his Knight to that
square where it was attacked so let's do
a quick action replay of the last couple
of moves it looked like a very standard
position around here uh of course white
has these doubled e-pawns but uh black
has pushed forward with g5s weakening
himself somewhat and now Magnus Knight
to H4 beautiful move jumping in
potentially to an outpost if this Knight
is taken it is actually poisoned then
suddenly you would live to regret this
uh this is a deadly pin the Knight and
queen hit and this Knight is falling
next move this would end in a decisive
attack against the black king so the
bait was not taken here and uh Bishop to
G4 I wouldn't be surprised if Magnus
moves the queen I don't know where but
uh this attack
feels like he's hoping not to have to
avoid uh not not to go into an endgame
simply uh even if that has brought him
success so far so Knight F5 I think is
the safe option and we would see for
example a trade such as this one Queen's
disappearing and it would be two Bishops
versus two knights and in a block
position maybe the knights are okay but
uh Magnus he's gonna move as Queen and
there we go Queen's E1 same idea I like
magnus's choice because by uh keeping
the Queens on the board it follows my
rules and I have a general rule which is
when the when the kings are weak you
should keep the Queens on the board you
gotta attack and there you go and
they're talking about attack we do see I
mean quickly move his Knight to the edge
to attack the light Square Bishop where
is that piece gonna go expect it to
slide
I was gonna say C2 but then I thought
what's it doing on that square why not
just trade off a set of Bishops and then
start eyeing up the light squares again
yeah if you trade these off Simon big
attack yeah yeah yeah I mean that looks
like a really good choice as you say
because you've got this beautiful Square
for the night there and uh I think also
keeping the bishop was something you you
could have considered on the on the
diagonal and I just don't like the look
of Black's King side uh black Black's
King side is so weak and as Ivanka
pointed out here as uh it's got loads of
holes doesn't it around it and uh if you
can ever get the white knight to just
jump in at the right time it's it's
going to be a disaster for black so
Black's got some problems to overcome in
this situation and like yeah he has
moved the bishop back so well well found
there just trying to get rid of defender
of that square it's also worth noting
that the White Knight can't really be
captured because
um white will put black in a really
horrible pin there and black is just
losing so I don't even know what I'd do
if I was black here I mean this is this
is uncomfortable I feel for for black
disposition yeah I don't think you can
afford to trade light squared Bishops
that black Bishop is near needed to
trade off for that white knight if it
ever jumps in so I mean has to just drop
his Bishop back somewhere and I hope
that Magnus cannot stir up any uh attack
in the next few moves still not too uh
much to worry about here I think but
certainly unpleasant uh at least
slightly for black right now
is working as magic
I don't know I feel like this is one of
the one of those positions where black
has 99 Problems
exactly maybe a bishop is one actually
exactly yeah no I mean I'm just I'm just
looking at it I was like okay the night
is going to jump into F5 as David
indicated and then the white pawns Harry
Simon's favorite piece will just move
itself two squares forward I mean I
guess the one thing that black has in
its favor is that there aren't too many
pieces so to speak on the board like I
said Brooks have left oh I don't know
don't like it and we were so excited to
see this G5 move on the board felt like
ambitious play but it sort of come back
to bite Black's position I thought it
was really risky actually I mean you oh
and there we see Bishop takes Bishop
99 problems and a bishop is one
definitely yeah that looks horrible
doesn't it I mean look at that square
what a square that that white knight is
found and you know you you might even
have some tactics here but simply this
move just seems so strong right yeah
with the Knight on F5 I mean will not
survive uh it's gonna be Checkmate
surely here that white knight is going
to be the uh the main piece of course
but if white can add the queen add The
Rook to the attack
surely that black king is living a
Charmed Life at some point you might be
able to break in the center but Magnus
first he'll get his pieces ready Black's
Knight on the A5 Square as well not
looking great either so I'm very much
loving White's position but yeah as you
say no breakthrough yet so uh a means
banking on the fact that he can survive
the next few moves and maybe long term
black has chances if he can get their
Queens off the board with a slightly uh
more harmonious Pawn structure so Magnus
in charge here but I mean still fighting
what do we think of the of the game wow
Simon just as uh just I say it Harry
that's uh I was a good move pretty much
always we did see one case we should let
down the side but obviously you want to
open up the black king because of your
fantastic White Knight you've got a rook
if you can get the bishop into the
attack as well and I'm just gonna be
thinking you know first things get in
you open up the H line and then all guns
are high on that H file
now the bishop is coming into the game
Sorry David no go on no I was just gonna
say now the bishop is introduced into
the attack I mean it's all going wrong
yeah it's all going wrong let's show
what uh we think Magnus might be up to
in the next few moves uh he has some
very natural moves at his disposal uh
just to mention here if black had taken
back with the pawn which and if you want
to do strategically structurally here
with your Pawn structure then white does
have moves such as just advancing the
king bringing the Rook to the H file and
this looks disastrous at least from a
human point of view even if black can
survive instead he took with a rook to
keep the H5 closed and uh Ivanka Bishop
joining the attack now all the pieces in
the party attacking The Rook attacking
the Knight what to do next if the Rook
drops back
I mean at the very least the queen can
start coming
feels like something's lining up against
this Knight yeah every white piece is
around the the week and black king here
and there uh we should remind everyone
if Magnus wins this game he he wins the
match because he's already won one game
so uh this is this is a great
opportunity for him and uh yeah I mean
okay he's also playing on the other side
now just to uh show his dominance
incredible full board awareness we see
that by Magnus all the time you know
you're focused on one side of the board
and then suddenly you realize that
there's stuff going on on the queen side
as well so he's asking questions to that
black knight also fixing that B5 bond
which can at some point prove to be a
weakness but to my mind it feels that
that Black Knight on A5 was actually a
White's friend it's at the edge of the
board so what's the deeper concept of
actually pushing it back towards his own
King
think maybe the idea was just to make
sure it stays in Black side of the board
if White had played Queen to F3 first
maybe the Black Knight jumps in this way
starts harassing white from behind and
like you say Tanya just full board
awareness Magnus is so kind of uh
concerned about not allowing black any
activity at all that he's happy to just
spend a Tempo uh pushing the Black
Knight towards the center and this is
the position and it's like we said black
is just stuck you can never really bring
this Knight back to challenge on F5
firstly you never threaten to take it
but if you do actually step back then
simply white traits capped out the way
and a knight Falls next move uh so black
is just really really Frozen right now
actually more is Black's next move if
you just pass can you even make a move
just gonna wait with the nightmare yeah
Grim defense it's horrible retreating
yeah I mean I think if you were sitting
here and you're playing Magnus you're
kind of like it's time to think about
what you're gonna eat for dinner isn't
it around around this point I feel so
fast playing you Simon here I start to
feel the same attack for free it's one
of those positions I can can play you
just throw everything at Black's King
basically and what I've actually
realizing that night from F5 you want to
get rid of it open up the Apple line an
impactful way of doing that 96 always in
the air you have to watch out for 96 986
and picking up that night on F6 so there
could be an immediate threat that I'm
going to think about he's shaking his
head not happy with his position
I think it's gone I I don't see how he's
gonna you know as you say he struggled
to find a move area in actual facts and
white
can just move the Knight he can build up
as well so yeah looking very good for
Magnus at the moment
wow interesting quote there from uh
twitch chat oh Knight and F5 being worth
at least a queen I would say that's
slightly hyperbolic but not nf5 is good
bless you Simon was that a reaction to
the court yeah excuse me reaction to uh
Black's position here yes
take the camera away
great work there yeah cheers just put it
on me as soon as I sneeze and feel
dis-hacked but this night on F5 that's
not a night that's a dragon that's a
monster then uh yeah it's all about
white putting on the pressure on the f
file and now he's literally going down
on the clock as well under six minutes
but the position that's really hard to
defend even if you had all the time in
the world
I missed that phrase Ivanka octo Knight
with its tentacles eight tentacles
around the White Knight controlling so
many squares uh yeah beautiful piece it
is a beautiful piece and actually I
learned when the night actually reached
reaches the sixth row this is a white
knight reaches the sixth row and is
supported it doesn't become an octo
Knight it is in fact the Kraken so uh
yeah there you go
to my story together yeah I think it
actually came from Peter spedler he
called it the Kraken yeah and yeah I
mean the sad state of the matter for
black is that they just have to Sound
the Horn Retreat and I like David's
suggestion of just moving the Knight
back to protect his own King and uh
after all
one of the things when you are playing a
defensive type of position you know you
just got to be optimistic I mean
especially if you have such a position
like this where you're expected nine
times out of ten to lose uh oh a Magnus
now striking in the center you go back I
go forward is what he says no you know
what I do if I was black here
I just resigned we need to know I know
it is one of those moments so you you
could be quite tempted actually and just
uh go and have a nice dinner you know
take away maybe a bit of magnus's
comparable I had a vision of you like
Superman with your t-shirt on really
yeah very interesting to know that yeah
just resign yeah this position is big
trouble for black and with that last one
trade it looks like Magnus has sold his
Central Bond structure problem and
created another Square for the night to
retreat to to E3 uh where you can start
targeting the F7 Pawn I've been checking
his head he's trying to create some play
of his own
but it looks like it's not going to be
enough the night falls back to G3 C3
pawns defended F7 hanging
smelly yeah it's getting worse and worse
Magnus is just slowly methodically
improving his pieces look at that the
Knight and F5 was glorious but it was in
the way of White's Queen and Rook so he
Maneuvers it takes two Tempe well spent
uh to the side of the board but
attacking this F6 pawn and not just as
he corrected his own Pawn structure over
the last few moves Magnus he's made sure
all of his four pieces there let's
forget the king for now the other four
are all zeroed in now on Black's F6 pawn
and that pawn is going to fall once that
pawn Falls the black king will be even
more vulnerable and this is the closing
stages of this game just he hasn't even
done anything too special Magnus it was
as soon as he landed that night in F5
it's been clinical
has been merciless right and I I find
that this is a very instructive game
from Magnus like the way that he struck
out in the center and the way that he
pushed back the knight from A5 put it on
a bad Square beautiful
yeah and poor I mean he loves to be an
attacker he loves to be on the front
foot creating threats but this uh this
game especially and the closing stages
of the previous game Magnus has just
shut things down uh not even a hint of
activity not even a hint of counter play
and that's the most frustrating thing in
chess when you open it doesn't give you
a chance
and okay forced to retreat there we go
breakthrough wow did you see that it's
just
it's just so accurate right you know
because you most people would be like oh
look at that
kickson is like nope no no no I'm just
gonna turn the screw yeah and I've now
just make use of the fact that the
Knight on C6 is loose I remember that
one before pushing that knight from 35
to C6 and suddenly everything falls into
place Magnus he plays he wins it's just
how it goes in chess
doctor it's just uh everyone just seems
to be moving to his beat all the pieces
landing on the screen this is a killer
oh god oh he's enjoying himself a bit
too much here isn't anything yeah this
is I think we should show why black on
take on E6 David yeah let's just show
those last two moves and give them the
credit they deserve first of all in this
position when you could cash in with a
pawn nope Magnus steps forward E5
hitting that loose piece as Ivanka
mentioned and not just that but pushing
the pawn forward to become a uh
protective passport in a moment because
Quinn takes porn simply walks into a
double attack the Knight Retreats that
is a fork and this would be resign time
actually this is happening right now
that porn could not be tolerated but
black is losing material and not just
that but the pawn in the middle on F6
will fall next move as well
this one is just over no chance of a
fight back for I mean to better buy that
would be much over not just game over
Magnus wins this he does take the match
right now and if I wouldn't be surprised
if I'm in just resigned in this position
it's so difficult to even uh think of a
way to continue or create some play with
the black pieces right now if he can
bring himself to resign I think he
probably would but like you say this is
a match situation
you never won a game by resigning so
perhaps string it out a little bit more
who was it who said that no one won a
game by resigning
not me someone with a big brain that's
for sure I'm well up for resigning just
resign that's it just get you know other
things to do right this this looks like
it's about to finish any moment he does
fall back with the queen and the king
recaptures in G6 that's playing with
fire yeah at least he's keeping this F6
Pawn alive so right now the material
deficit is minimized it's uh White
having a rook for blacks tonight in porn
so actually only technically one point
down but it's just the fact that uh well
actually another pornstar
missed that one I was just gonna say
it's just the fact that black king is so
open you don't even need to take this
Pawn you could have gone for checkmate
Magnus but no he's just doing the maths
here he's counting collecting doing
everything and you see on the camera
Tabata by knows that despite the fact
he's kind of wrapped his king and the
black king up in Cotton wool here it's
not gonna prolong the inevitable forever
White's Bishop will just Retreat white
has a majority three versus two in terms
of Pawns on the queen side as well
and uh yeah it's slow but sure at this
point
it has been uh quite a fight by Amin if
you don't look at the scoreline I don't
think it tells the full score story
Magnus winning this taking it in three
matches the games were a lot closer than
what it seems uh if you just take a look
at the scorecard I mean half his chances
especially in that game one yeah maybe
maybe game two as well as you mentioned
and uh he has played very into Point
enterprising chess and uh I think that
that game one was maybe key I mean when
you get a chance against Magnus you've
got to take it you don't generally get
more than one chance against Magnus and
uh he could have won that ending and
actually taken a lead in the match and
uh obviously now things are really bad
he's hanging on here but yeah it's not
going the way he wants and that's the
thing with the top players uh in the
world some kind of super strong
Grandmasters like I mean to about to buy
they can match them step foot by step
but when it comes down to the crunch
moments that Killer Instinct just seems
to be a bit sharper with players like
Magnus Fabiano these kind of really
Elite Grand Masters spot everything they
very rarely blunder very rarely miss an
opportunity and kind of incrementally
they seem to rack up the wins
so yeah it's been so close this match
like you say Tanya doesn't kind of
reflect it in the score line but Magnus
is going to take it yeah
he's making it look easy now continues
to put pressure on the clock as well you
can look at him and you know from the
body language that he knows that this is
over and Simon the point that you were
making that against Magnus you don't get
chances if you get that one chance you
better grab it with both hands it
reminds me of what happened in the World
Cup right with Winston kaima he's the
only player who actually defeated Magnus
took the lead in the match in that
second game Knight takes E4 could have
been a completely different story he had
that one chance you let it go and then
Magnus was uh back in it and went on to
win the World Cup and right now it looks
like he is about to take this match C6
played Magnus perhaps just thinking
about what is the quickest way to
Victory here
yeah support for Choice that's the
problem you could start pushing pawns on
the queen side if you there we go if you
want to be really sadistic I was going
to say uh just slowly but surely now the
white B Pawn is stepping forward be
careful here it's black black queen
cannot go and take White's Pawn in the
center the Deep Pawn because the white
Rook will capture the Knight on E7 jump
out the way and White's Bishop
indirectly hits the black queen uh okay
to battle by blocks it which makes sense
when you have Knights but uh Magnus will
create a passport and combining that
with uh some threats some hints against
the black king should overwhelm Black's
defenses
feels like a kind of a slow way of
playing it Magnus he hasn't killed it
off in the most brutal way but he's
still almost guaranteed at this point
yeah
so what do you say when you're winning
you know slow and steady wins the race
it doesn't matter whether you win in 60
moves or 40 moves and there we see
Magnus pushing his Pawn forward he's
getting ready to perhaps push the B Pawn
as well and create another past porn
Magnus is playing great stuff yeah I
have a question for you Simon would you
rather win in 20 moves just a quick
brutal miniature or would you rather win
a 100 move long torture game
David Davids depends what I'm doing in
the evening
generally I'd probably like to you know
do something in the evening so give give
me a bit of brutality and I will take it
but I think I know the answer to this
one David if you had a choice between a
20 move miniature King hunt brilliency
Prize or let's say 150 moves to you 150
move grind eight hours later break the
Guinness Book of Records oh yeah all the
restaurants are shut no bars are open
all the Arbiters are sleeping which one
would you prefer I would take a 300 move
150th rookie numbers
I think we're about to see a result
Bishop to E3 last movement that's it
it's done Magnus Carlsen takes the
witchy I'm in tabatabai resigns and with
that everything is over the queen has
attacked the 861 is hanging hanging and
Magnus there on his phone uh wraps up
his match in just three games there
turning stockfish off Joe Joe
Simon
Magnus with his victory lots of uh
lots of big moments in that one we will
check in with that but action is still
on in the Wesley matchup can Wesley do
what Magnus has done wrap this up in
three games he looks close Wesley so
firstly look at the clock he's got
double his opponent's time there
secondly look at the board it's really
blocked right now black has no activity
whatsoever The Black Queen what was she
doing hanging out in the corner there uh
Black's pieces just struggling for air
and uh he has a grip Wesley I'm not sure
it's enough for a big Advantage the
evaluation Bar says yes white is in
control but he doesn't need to win
remember he just needs to draw so even
if he's just maneuvering maneuvering and
he should be pretty happy pretty safe
here and there we go he improves his
Bishop elianov uphill struggle of course
winning with black on demand just to
stay alive in the match but uh okay on
the plus side for him still a lot of
pieces uh remaining so if eventually
some fine day the position does explode
then uh at least he'll hope that he has
enough potential there
to fight back but Wesley just boa
constrictor mode right now it totally is
you know and there you see Wesley with
that last bishop move getting ready to
set up some kind of Bishop and queen
battery on the A5 pawn and while Eliana
had to do this he had to press that red
button and initiate chaos and here comes
the Breakthrough but white is very well
placed to meet us
yep
still a bit messy though I mean uh I
think he had to try this move I mean
he's got to win he's got a complicated
position and at least he's generating
some play in the king side so uh it's
it's kind of like a force move I feel
that one yeah F5 and we're live uh as a
good friend of ours would say and
actually the black Rook which I wasn't
giving much credit a few moves ago if
you look at the black Rook on A7 it's
ready to swing across like a double
Rooks there stack them up and you kind
of go all in on the king side I'm not
sure how you have a Checkmate White's
King those double G Pawns in front of
the white king keep it nice and safe uh
safely protected potentially but yeah
he's got to do this uh hustle mode now
from Eliana he needs to up the pace up
the tempo that's the one thing because
things will explode uh he's trying his
best to make them do so but two minutes
isn't really enough to kind of work your
way through that maze later on so okay
he needs to just speed up get that black
queen across to the king side bring all
your pieces towards the white king and
then pray and then
maybe something will work in Black's
favor I mean I mean like the way that
black will try to open up the position
is to push that F Pawn one square
forward and try to destabilize the king
side and uh well you asked David and
they played the queen moves to C7 it's
getting ready to transfer I was going to
say to the E7 Square yeah maybe even
back to d8 just to evacuate the seventh
rank for the other black Rook but yeah
either way the black queen was the worst
place piece
good kind of Chess wisdom in general to
improve a piece that's not doing too
much and eliano if we should mention
he's very strong when uh kind of there's
Harmony in his position
um he's very solid of course as well but
when his pieces are kind of doing good
work he tends to kind of have great
technique uh when he has the advantage
he can be ruthless so okay Knight F1
Wesley's trying to maneuver very slow
very mysterious I've got to say uh
potentially as well sacrificing a pawn
at least short-term sacrificing
something because black can take in the
center now is this the moment for black
to open things up
yeah or continue with that clever Queen
maneuver and go F4 I I quite like
Black's position and this also if you
can play this then you should but I was
a little bit worried that white could
close down that King Side by playing G4
here uh there might be other options as
well but if Wesley can keep the lines
closed on the king side then he will uh
get the result that he needs to draw or
a win so maybe it may be a key moment
here David yeah potentially a key moment
uh I'm very attracted to move G4 as well
I guess the one downside is it does
weaken Harry yeah this H4 Pawn could be
targeted either by The Black Queen uh or
maybe by the black Bishop at some point
and yeah if you could kind of push this
Pawn one square back white has a full
Fortress you'll never break through his
black uh so critical moment if you
cannot push forward you don't really
want to open things up if you take this
Pawn as well then uh black actually has
a nice choice you can take with a rook
attack a few pawns there you can even
contemplate taking with the pawn because
suddenly you have an advantage in terms
of majority poor majority side and
trading these dark Square Bishops might
well suit black here
um fighting really well maybe I didn't
give him enough credit earlier uh the
time's still not in his favor but he's
at least asking difficult questions of
Wesley and there we see Wesley moving
his Knight to the edge of the board
I feel like Wesley is trying to keep
control at all costs and there we do see
ponte's point
and I was actually expecting Wesley to
capture that pawn one move earlier just
embrace the chaos it is what it is
don't make passive decisions
now which way does black recapture on F4
with the Rook with the pawn yeah or
maybe you can also consider taking on H4
possibly I think the one problem that
Pavel has with the black pizzas here
though is that yeah he's going to open
up White's King but his pieces are not
really active enough at the moment the
the Black Knight is too far away from
the action Black's dark Square Bishop
needs a bit of work and it's only the
queen and maybe The Rook was really
working so you know if you can get those
pieces coming in somehow then he he will
better get some chances but there's a
lot of work to get those pieces uh into
the game here you know White's piece is
much more centralized in comparison uh
as you mentioned there you can always
give a check for example Black's Queen
can even land on F2 giving a check but
white has full control the white King's
actually pretty safe in the corner uh
protected by its Knight you can see the
nerves on Eliana over there he's leaning
forward suddenly readjusting his body
position under 20 seconds not easy and
he's gambling he's going all in now at
this last move he's double upped his
Rooks but what is the threat unless
there's a direct threat direct
breakthrough then he's giving up more
pawns more material is it Rook F2 and
Rook takes G2 is is one idea I mean at
least you could create a Checkmate idea
there uh and uh Wesley's stopping that
immediately uh by bringing his Knight in
I mean it's still a very murky position
this Wesley is an incredible calculator
but if I was white here I'd be a little
bit scared I have to say uh with those
black pieces so near my king yeah I mean
the rook's now working aren't they the
Brooks are now working and the light
Square Bishop on E6 is gonna jump into
H3 and threaten checkmate
this is getting chaotic this was a
bullet game I think I'd choose black but
uh Wesley has two minutes to spare he
needs to use them wisely he needs to
somehow rebuff this queen uh kick her
out of White's Camp release the pressure
it's not obvious the White Knight can
jump out the way there's an attack on
the third rank against the black queen
but where to jump not obvious big
threats it's the kind of position that
you just completely disregard the eval
bar it means nothing it's anyone's game
right now with eliano going for white
skin and there it is Ivanka your idea of
getting the bishop to join the attack
the body as well but Dave albar says
that Westy's defense is on point getting
that Rook to hold on to that Knight F3
was the accurate way to go forward
it's amazing that you found that move I
mean and I think without the evaluation
bar
um which the players don't obviously
have uh you you'd have no idea what's
going on here okay whites are pouring up
but
um it there there are some threats uh
Brewing around the king now and this is
a great move I love this move if you can
get the Queens off it goes back to what
you said juvanka earlier if you're
defending get the Queen's off if you're
attacking keep the Queens on and if he
can get the Queens off which he has done
then that's gonna give his position a
lot of safety there I'd imagine
yeah that that's helped a lot right that
that Queen exchange yeah that is uh kind
of textbook defense there just pure
defense actually all of Wesley's pieces
holding things together and forcing the
Queens off the black queen couldn't have
stayed on because it would have been
trapped two one oh
minimum which is one second on the clock
but it's not gonna help
us because now black has sold all why
does all all the problems no Checkmate
and he's up no I was gonna say he's upon
but it's actually level materials the
Avon and the bishop pair as well oh yeah
and a minute on the clock six seconds
for Eleanor what a porn as well on A4 as
well it's just gonna March all the way
to A8 and well Wesley remember he just
needs a drawer as well oh yeah it's a
dream scenario one second oh
wow a second fun is about to drop but he
might you might just trade the Rooks and
then go on to pick up that D6 Pawn yeah
he's trying some tricks here hitting
White's Bishop on C7 uh with the black
Rook but yeah actually if Wesley just
wants to lock this down with a draw you
can even trade off Rooks go into an
opposite color Bishop position but yeah
why not grab a second Pawn
plenty of time here for Wesley 40
seconds should be enough to bank this
could even take the Knight couldn't you
just go opposite kind of Bishop
um you only need to draw as white here
um so it it's it's looking looking like
drawers very close or a win for Wesley
as well is is pretty good option in here
as well
why not I should say
and this is a check white king will move
the Black Knight will jump out the way
premise may be no good squares for this
Black Knight and this oh go to some do
some calculation here White's Rook is
attacked can you take this black Bishop
off the board no why not keep it safe
yeah with an extra extra two pawns this
time yeah because he's the king of
guiding games towards safety not maybe
objectively best but enough more than
sufficient uh for at least a draw that
is required well there is some danger
but it's very tiny if you put your king
in the wrong square like I was thinking
age three maybe the black pawns could
start advancing and trap the white king
in a mating net thinking about checking
it in that position yeah it's always
let's not forget it's Wesley and he's
just not going to give any chances to
his exactly and that's why he put his
King on the bottom there was no danger
whatsoever and
now the black king is uh coming in I
have to say I I like what pavel's doing
here in a really bad situation he is
coordinating his remaining pieces uh is
he just gonna take the draw here he
can't no he's got to play for the win
it's always as bad as losing as losing
yeah you might as well play and uh it's
three pawns down though
I mean oh this is not easy right I think
yeah and that's it bubble resigns after
losing the third pawn and Wesley with
3-0 wraps it up in three games as well
we still have action on and there it is
there he is uh Wesley with a dominating
performance at the start of the Julius
bear generation cup
and we've still got games on
and not a back up to such off can he
survive can he take his match to game
four
wow this uh firstly it's like looks
slightly chaotic but it's about to clear
up and it's gonna clear up in for
rouge's favor we jumped in just as we're
about to see a result this Knight check
gains an important Tempo next move
Black's Bishop picks up the White Knight
peace up and he's gonna go through
yeah huge update sorry Simon that Fabio
just lost his game he blundered and lost
his game
which means that he has to win the
fourth game against Dennis last week
Dennis last week takes the lead in his
match wow
maybe uh the only match which we've got
going on actually I think all the other
matches have been wrapped up so uh I
mean Fabby losing that would be that'd
be a really uh shocking result I'd say
yeah 16 year old I mean this is the
generation cup but what a result that
was and we have to mention it was
self-inflicted Fabiano blundering in
what should be quite a well-known Rook
end game I think with a bit more time on
the clock Fabiano would have uh been
able to hold the draw here under some
pressure white has an extra Pawn Dennis
lazovic with white but it was this move
in a moment uh here that cost him that
valuable Half Point Fabiano instead of
for example just retreating the black
king to a nice safe Square staying in
touch with this uh weak F6 Pawn Fabiano
went wrong he simply waited with his
Rook but then it was too late the white
Rook now able to cut the coordination
between the black king and porn this
Pawn now is simply doomed and look at
what happened yes he was able to give a
couple of checks Fabiano he was even
able to trade off Rooks but the extra
porn King of Porn end games here this
allowed white to of outmaneuver the
black king Fabiano resigned because for
example here the white king outflanks
its counterpart slowly makes its way
towards the lone Pawn wow what a result
we had
this is uh the biggest upset that we've
had in today's matches with Dennis
lazovic's 16 year old making his debut
in the Champions chess store division
one taking the lead Fabiano caruana has
to win on demand or he goes down into
the loser's bracket and these are our
score lines three matches decided in
three games and only one will go on to
game four who was the most impressive
player for you today so far
[Music]
they've all been impressive but all the
winners have been impressive but I've
been also very surprised at how Ali Reza
farisa made it look so easy against
someone like nordebec Abdul sotarov
because let's not forget nor the back
was World rapid champion at 17 years old
and for farisha to defeat him three
times
that was unusual for me
what a performance it was by alireza
ferrugia we will go into a short break
but we will be back with the Julius bear
generation cup action with Fabi in a
must win situation don't go anywhere
[Music]
either would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
thank you
Magnus Carlsen also taking the match in
just three games against
and these are they're accuracy rates at
92.6 percent quite a great performance
but I mean he also put up a big fight
88.5 create score great accuracy there
but it was the World Champ the world
number one follow world champion and the
world rapid in this champion and the
World Cup winner who Reigns Supreme in
that one yeah absolutely he was so
powerful right oh Magnus yeah it all
turned on that one opportunity in the
first game I mean maybe could have taken
it sorry in the end game but in the end
once Magnus got his chance he jumped on
it yeah he's just playing such great
chess at the moment isn't he Magnus I
mean he's just won the World Cup and uh
he's winning these events left right and
Center can anyone stop do we think
anyone at all no yeah it's looking
difficult right because Magnus are just
one nearly everything in the world you
know won the World Cup and like about
five-time world champion and today very
impressive after that first game where
he looked a little bit shaky
and we are being joined by world number
one and Magnus Carlton Magnus
congratulations on today's win and also
on the huge World Cup victory it's been
a big week for you how are you feeling
uh I'm feeling uh okay
um
yeah I'm very happy with uh with the
World Cup of course and uh
um yeah it's good to win today as well
it was a short match we wrapped it up in
three games interesting games how would
you sum up your fight against Damian
um yeah I think
I think generally he played
fairly well in the in the first game
like he responded well to the
um to the opening that I I played and uh
after that
played uh fairly
well generally quite good chess and then
the next two games he was um
yeah he was not very good so even though
I did not feel so good I
my brain was kind of um kind of fried
from the beginning and it was still
fairly straightforward
yeah it looked really convincing to us
as well and Magnus we saw on your social
media on Instagram that you after your
World Cup victory went up to the
mountains and had a little bit of a
break is uh was that you just resetting
unwinding and getting ready for this
tournament
yeah for sure but I do think that I
spent a little too much energy working
um
and biking the last couple of couple of
days so that's why I didn't really have
too much energy today but um it was um
was it was fun it was great to be um be
out in nature
and I
do remind
today as well
as well
you know even though
um
um even though the last two games
weren't so good
um perhaps with the
some some changes you know some new
people
to to work with better influences maybe
you can um
he can play even better
Magnus uh you're saying better
influences are you talking about Hans
Neiman right now
I'm talking about influences in in
general
all right fair enough magnesnarchess.com
released the statement regarding Hans
and we'll see him return to competition
soon uh one year ago exactly in the
Julius bear generation cup we all were
here and we saw what happened what were
your thoughts on this next chapter in
The Saga and especially if he comes to
compete in the Champions chess store
next
no comments
okay fair enough uh uh Simon
um yeah I was just wondering if you've
had a chance to celebrate your World Cup
victory Magnus and um if not are you
gonna celebrate it and how
um yeah I um I had a good celebration
last weekend and
um feels really good to have one so now
I'm trying to
um you know move on Play and play the
next tournament
um Magnus are you looking for a hat
trick win here because you've already
punched your ticket into the Toronto
finals and uh you've had to win so
what's your big motivation for this one
from the fight that I tried to win when
I when I play and I like playing rapid
chess
it's a great start congratulations on
your win and good luck for your matches
coming up
thank you
Magnus Carlsen uh with some advice for
his opponent Aman tabatabai saying about
having better influence but also saying
that no comment on the statements that
were released about Hans Neiman coming
back to competition
what did you guys make of that
no comment
oh it's just interesting right to to
hear Magnus clearly very relaxed you did
well today he's happy with it and um
yeah as for the advice I I don't know
pretty cryptic stuff though yeah so I
mean uh you can see I had a little smile
there when he was saying it so there's
something going on there in the
background to I didn't really feel like
pushing him there though too much you
know I was a bit worried actually I
didn't quite know where he was going to
go with that but yeah I mean but it just
just kind of like piggyback on his
advice about influences I think it's a
good idea to have a positive circle of
people around you
it was uh yeah it was quite interesting
because I asked him up front if he was
talking about Hansen he just said not
just being better influences would you
would you make Simon with Hans coming
back into competition
thank you for asking me that question no
comment
um well I I did see hans's um like
Twitter post yesterday
um which which I you know I made me
laugh I have to say you need a baddie
right in in like these things in in like
wrestling you needed the Baddie in in
every kind of sport you need that
character and hands is is the perfect
body right I mean uh but it depends on
your Viewpoint right because you could
also kind of go Star Wars about it and
go like well Hans is like the rebel he's
just a you know 20 year old and he's
been accused of being suspicious with
this play and you know now he's kind of
having to prove himself well he has
cheated you know he's admitted to
cheating isn't he so that that's the
thing and um I mean I I wonder if the
other players are going to be
comfortable playing against him knowing
that but of course people do do deserve
a second chance as well uh but um he
didn't seem very apologetic in the
Twitter post yesterday
by saying do you miss me
I do miss him so yeah
plaque so and he is I was so dramatic
because it was the three of you who were
calling out the action last year at the
Julius bad generation cup when we saw
Magnus refusing to play against
um against Hans and now in his uh
statement he said that he will be
willing to play against Hans if paired
against each other is that a matchup
that you guys are looking forward to of
course it's gonna be really dramatic I I
mean everyone wants to see that match up
right because everyone wants to see how
is it going to develop and uh whether
Hans you know he's been building up the
hype you know can he live up to that so
I would I would be waiting with that
with eager eyes and I'm kind of hoping
it will be in maybe the plans maybe the
next tournament in the Champions gesture
store yeah and uh I think even if we
just strip It Back to Basics no matter
which side of the fence you're on Hans
is a very good chess player I mean I'd
just love to see him play again and uh
he's sort of super young so much
potential maybe he could still win the
Tour you know a good place to play in
the next tournament him versus Magnus in
the final we'd all love to see it right
chess is in uh for a fantastic time it's
going to be a lot of fun to watch this
entire Saga unfold with Hans Neiman
returning to competitive chess on
chess.com you might be seeing a Magnus
versus hands and match up really soon
but for now it is eyes all eyes on the
Dennis lazowick versus
sabiano caruana Fabi has to win on
demand the 16 year old Dan Laz has taken
the lead winning their last game what a
performance it has been drawing the
first two games in a convincing way and
then he takes the lead and it's big
pressure on wall number three Fabiano
caruana yes he has to win on demand and
as happy says himself that is not an
easy task and does depend a little bit
on luck and there we go it's kickoff
kickoff it's another Spanish opening
this time the Berlin and uh an ante
Berlin Fabiano sticks to his guns this
didn't work out too well for him in game
two of the day uh when these two clashed
earlier looked like lasovix sorted his
opening problems very very
straightforwardly so what does Carolina
have up his sleeve
feels like a decent solid start to the
game lazovic plays this B6 move as far
as I know that's quite rare and okay
Fabiano the first pause of the game
he hits the white uh sorry here it's the
black Central Pawn on E5 there and this
will take again a slower turn but I
don't know if this is a good strategy
lazovic he's proven time and time again
he's so good in these kind of build up
type of uh scenarios where he can just
have some stability and outmaneuver his
opponents later okay karawana slide
across with his King there very subtle
he's releasing his F Pawn though so
maybe he does have aggressive intentions
here
in the early stages
yeah I mean he's got to win so the idea
is to clearly move the Knight and then
throw the F Pawn forwards try to start
an attack against blank's King and uh I
this is quite a mysterious move I think
as you mentioned David the black played
B6
um because I I don't I don't really see
the point now you're actually going to
move your light Square Bishop as black
to a fianchetto square well that seems
kind of stupid there because you've got
a pawn in the way uh are you gonna move
it to the A6 Square I don't really see
the point of that either so I I don't
get uh this this B6 move entirely myself
and uh and I I like White's approach
trying to punish and maybe a slow Move
Like That by getting ready to to open up
the position as quickly as possible so
um makes a lot of sense
yeah and uh Fabiano looks pretty chilled
I would be stressed out I must win
situation uh facing potentially being
knocked down to the other bracket by the
youngest player uh in the tournament but
yeah he's been here before this is where
experience counts right we talk about
Battle of the generations the older you
are the more you've seen the more you've
kind of been in situations like this and
if it comes down to those crunch moments
Fabiano will make the right decisions
and of course he's had a lot of playing
well in knockout tournaments uh just in
recent history Fabiano at the World Cup
where he's been in must win situations
before
do you think fatigue is going to be a
factor for Fabi in this event he had
this incredible run at the World Cup
finishing third with a long long
tournament and then being induced off
for the world a rapid Team Championship
uh is energy and fatigue going to be a
factor here it has to be a factor but I
also happen to know that fabiani works
really hard on his physique you know
he's always looking at endurance and
I don't know whether it's a secret or
not but he's quite into like cold water
exposure and just being as tough as he
can be
yeah I must admit from the brief time
that I worked with Fabiano back in 2015
he was going swimming every morning and
I'm the worst swimmer ever like I'm I
can barely stay afloat and he was just
in the lanes he was like uh doing uh
what do you call them lengths uh yeah
he's in great shape Fabiano and
something he actively works on so I
think fatigue would affect most of us
but uh for him for Magnus the likes of
those uh very very top players not such
an issue meanwhile dancing around with
the knights and this has been shut down
by lazovic a lot of porn moves by black
Simon is this uh kind of is this the red
flag to the ball oh yeah I would have
thought so I mean uh I mean moving the
F4 now seems so logical uh just trying
to open up the position I mean maybe
other moves you can consider yeah you
could consider moving a knight in
straight away but that that I don't know
if it's working or not it's a
interesting move but obviously it's a
bit stupid but I kind of like the idea
of it because it's a bit stupid but F4
seems Seems like the the normal move to
play I'm just mentioning Knight to F5 I
mean just just because you know it is is
fun probably not good but it's fun and
you can throw the queen in and uh and
probably resign in a couple of moves but
you know yeah you you have to analyze
these things because you misplaced black
king and uh I think the black King's
quite safe here though because you can't
break through on the the e-file at all
so F4 must be the mood to play Let's
play something else though another
another move which has has a lot of
point to it stopping Black from castling
so Black's gonna try to Castle Queen
side now I guess is is the idea
definitely and I'm really surprised
actually Fabian has committed his pieces
now especially this bishop to H6 because
as you say Black's just going the other
way he's just gonna laugh at these two
pieces he's saying okay you stopped me
from casting kingside but what are your
pieces doing there mate and uh feels
like Fabiano okay he's got a very
complicated position that's first step
when you need to win but I think he's
maybe got a bit over uh excited there
okay playing on both sides of the board
though
these top players are very good at
switching their focus and now suddenly
if you Castle prematurely as black you
might be hit by the move B4 don't take
this Pawn now because suddenly a double
attack against the two black bishops
simultaneously uh whoops me and my
arrows as usual these two black bishops
hit
still complicated
still super complicated and whilst you
have the board up there I mean is it
Daft for the king to actually walk its
way to the the B7 Square Walk This Way
Walk This Way
[Laughter]
yeah nice idea uh okay he keeps his
options open uh less committal here
lazovic he drops his Bishop back just
preempting that pawn push uh preempting
point to B4 and instead ready to Castle
queenside next move opposite side
castling we've seen it before between
these two and it led to an exciting game
there too so lazovic I would say he's
maybe won the opening battle objectively
but in terms of kind of uh long term
still everything to play for when you're
in a must win a win-on-demand game this
is the kind of outcome you want as well
even with the white pieces I mean it
promises to be a chaotic battle
especially if a Dench uh Dennis chooses
to go with the the queen side gasoline
and with king size castling out of the
question I think it's the kind of fight
that Fabi with the math situation was
hoping for
totally agree yeah I mean I I won't pay
too much attention to the evaluation bar
it's going to be about King safety and
uh it looks to me like black probably
will Castle queenside but then there are
many breaks which can try to open up the
black king so you mentioned B4 uh there
could be a C4 at some point as well
coming up the board and so yeah so it's
going to be a very interesting
double-edged position and if you need to
win and this guy he seems like the new
rock right I mean like he's only 16 I
think it wasn't uh it's so hard to get a
complicated messy uh complex position
against so even though the evaluation
bar doesn't like it perfect position to
get in a must win situation
I was going to say the same thing as
well very interesting decision by Fabi
just to push the Jeep on one square
um is he getting ready to perhaps move
the Knight back and then slowly push the
F the two Pawn Yeah it's really
mysterious because okay Dennis uh reacts
very quickly here but uh yeah if you
ever push this F1 forward whether you
preempt it by kind of putting your
knight back first just watch out for
this long Square uh this light Square
diagonal to open up we could imagine the
black Bishop simply retreating in which
diagonal does the white king sit on it
is this one as well no light squared
Bishop to compete uh for white here and
at the right moment you're strike
forward you push this Pawn forward kind
of destroy that diagonal and you control
all the light squares I really love
Black's position here I've got to say
I'm slightly biased I played these
positions myself mostly as black but uh
it definitely feels like Fabiano lacking
a plan right now uh the other move we
mentioned before comes with far less
effect uh especially with this black
Bishop now sitting nice and pretty on on
D6 you could maybe bypass this or even
trade off and uh ivanka's idea of
putting the King on B7 I think should be
relative be safe you bring the Rook
across next so okay Fabi just waiting
with his queen queen to E2
it's gonna take a maneuvering phase now
uh this position and it looks like black
pieces maybe slightly better place than
whites
but that white Bishop on H6 right it's
kind of it looks like it's a piece
that's out of play but it really stops
black from expanding on the king's side
so it's it's sort of playing a defensive
role as well making sure that black
doesn't get that pawn star ruling so I
like that he's put that Bishop there
there and Ivanka your idea of rerouting
that knight from G2 to E3 and then
jumping to C4 and a potential b-pawn
break uh fabi's got some trumps in the
position and if we didn't have the eval
bar I feel like it's not it's the kind
of position where it would be really
hard to call who is better here yeah I
mean it totally depends on the
effectiveness of their plans and also
whether you blunder or not let's put it
like and the bishop of the European it's
stalling its virtue is suddenly
relocates itself I must admit I did
think about playing Bishop H6 I was very
happy that Fabi played it and then
suddenly when everyone was like oh this
is not a good move I was like okay now
I'm understanding why because the bishop
I guess was out of play and
fuzzy has to do something that's the
problem and David's already highlighted
the dangers of going F2 to F4 you know
open up the light squares but then what
else do you do with white pieces if you
yeah there's just no coordination
between both sides of the board you need
some plan from my experience uh in these
types of positions you need a pawn
Breakers white as you mentioned Ivanka
it's either pushing F4 as we highlighted
a moment ago or pushing D4 D4 is
impossible for the near future because
Black's light squared Bishop is peering
down that diagonal and uh yeah you don't
necessarily want to open things up too
soon with a king on a light Square it
definitely feels like Fabiano it's been
inconsistent you brought this bishop
back to H6 he retreated it he put his
King in the corner on a light Square
suddenly he doesn't want to open up the
position because his King's stuck on
that square
um so it feels like kind of playing move
by move not necessarily kind of a
cohesive plan right now and Dennis
lazovic meanwhile slowly improving his
pieces that black king now super safe
rock solid behind that wall of Pawns The
Black Queen slightly improved and
hinting actually that black is the one
with pawnbricks F6 to F5 that F Pawn for
black about to step forward looks really
beautiful actually the more I look at it
it's still kind of in the balance
roughly but maybe I'm influencing but
yeah it feels
really really harmonious for black is it
one of those moments where you just need
to go all in and think about sacrificing
upon before trying to create some play
even if it's desperate is it time to go
all in with that
yeah let's uh check it out you've got to
time it but as you say Tanya wow he's
actually building up for it he's getting
ready to push before it's too late and
uh very good David way too many times
it's become a bit stale just like let's
position her but before
um is definitely a kind of the plan the
whole idea is you need some counter play
against this black king but how are you
ever going to break through you're
supported here as the black king by a
wall of pieces a whole Army on this side
I don't really see any danger at all
even if Denis lazovic ignores this and
starts pushing uh on the other side of
the board yeah I have an idea but only
an idea if black does nothing so I'm
like okay first that you go C4 and B4
I'll give you another move your Banker
yeah
yeah but I realized that there is a
consequence that you can actually just
uh
stop the bee Pawn from advancing every
time you play C4 you can meet that with
A4
just a ready on passant here if the pawn
steps two squares forward you take it as
if it moves one and uh yeah here white
does have fractured bones at least here
you could make an argument that you're
threatening something against the black
king definitely feels like Fabi has some
hope for activity but Dennis lazovic
really principled consistent he does
strike in the center
and yeah it feels like some threats
maybe of trapping this white Bishop
Fabiana says no Mutual attacks right now
on different flanks it's getting fun I
know you guys are saying that it's very
difficult for white to find something on
the queen side but I still think that
there are threats and problems that
Dennis lazovic needs to be careful about
and once again it feels like a Race So
what's Black's respond here do you block
down do you just shut down all player on
the on the queen side with A4
could do but then uh C4
C4 threatening to trap this bishop catch
it on the edge of the board Black's King
I guess would have to vacate now have to
move somewhere uh just to give the
bishop an escape Square
well some counter play though for white
I mean it just it looks quite messy to
me I mean now I'm sure black is doing
well but uh you know with this attack
inside castle and it can quickly change
if you play one mistake and uh I I think
it's just who's gonna be quickest there
in this kind of position
who would you take Simon you're the
attacker and here both sides are trying
to attack each other again I've seen the
evaluation bars it's really hard to say
white but I I mean I don't know white
Smooths are easier to play you know okay
you can play C4 you can you can create
these Frets in the easier way black has
to think about the approach to play does
black push the f-bourne does black
capture uh in the middle or or build up
the pressure so it's easier for white to
play which is I guess the advantage
being white here
yeah actually if you push the F Pawn
immediately like White's King is gonna
be challenged right because white is
practically forced to play Pawn takes
Pawn
let's check it out Ivanka talk us
through that variation yeah so I didn't
calculate that much but it just went
well you know if I want to give it that
Bishop a square you have to go ponte's
pawn and after the recapture then you
can step forward to D4 and then the big
question is
is black going to be playing like Queen
diving into H3 and just ignoring
everything going on the offensive
it's tempting
um I guess let's say black players say
just safe move moving the road to safety
what's White's next move still ideas
like you say attacking this Knight bring
the queen in
this white King's Super weak here I mean
if you go C4 I mean
white I don't know why yeah I don't want
to say it but like I'm kind of like you
know it's one of those positions where
it it can go either way I feel still at
this point it's
like soon where you need to be super
accurate
montage and we see a move her husband
played he decided to
Trin that is a mistake and gives away a
lot of your advantage and that's what
happens in these kind of tricky
positions yeah we were right all along
yeah white was doing well all along no
question at all so you eat my words
attacking instincts why but why why open
up the a file yeah I mean that just
seems completely crazy right you didn't
need to open up the a files as as black
in that position at all so it does it
does seem kind of it seems a bit too
crazy you know crazy decision now so
yeah I'll still say black even though
I've seen the evaluation bar move quite
significantly it isn't Dennis lazovic's
type of position either we mentioned
he's a grinder actually despite his
young age he loves his end games loves
his kind of solidity stability and here
it's just chaos as you've both been
mentioning
so still Auto playful Fabi definitely
not out of this one
look at that with every move uh the bar
seems to like White's position more and
more so again it's all about precision
and I think when we sit with engines or
computers it's kind of easy to see or to
say that uh you know this move gets a
big Advantage but when you're playing if
the if the margin for Advantage is
really just one move it's so easy to go
wrong and that's exactly what we saw in
the last couple of moves then last with
a really good position and now it's all
Fabi who's playing but how does he
continue Ivanka is it going to be your
idea of trying to push the seep on yeah
I mean I would be attracted to that
because I like to push pawns and also
the white king is pretty safe it's
always a good idea to consider what your
opponent is going to do as well I've
learned that lesson throughout this year
and the last year that was my biggest
mistake and there we see Fabi step back
with his Bishop
that's an interesting move I'm trying to
I guess he wants to move the Knight to
the center and then
yeah that's actually quite a nice move
yeah I mean it's uh it's also just
guarding the pawn uh well white has this
open a file which I think I had no idea
why Dennis allowed white to get this
open a file you know you don't open up
lines where your king is and uh
um also moving the black queen back one
square that seemed quite passive you
know I mean you have to try this now
this G5 move but it's a race it's just a
race situation does E5 work as well
David that's also a big question right
it's getting super messy I mean E5 at
first I thought okay it traps this
bishop this bishop has nowhere to go but
you are pinned along the e-file and this
might seem unattractive uh for Fabiano
because it would allow G4
counter-attacking against the White
Knight but this position just gets crazy
there are tactics all over the place and
just I mean I peeked at the computer
here because I'm confused why it said
white is just winning and it says wow
just Queen to E4 I was thinking that and
then Rick takes Bishop bang bang you've
seen it all yeah Bishop I've been doing
a lot of tactics that's been my training
and here Queen takes C6 you just simply
trap the king you've given up a rook to
lure it to the edge of the board see how
you file again davidger again that's the
killing you know this is the big mistake
that Dennis made just open up a line in
front of his King so it looks like this
is very strong for Fabiano but if he
doesn't find this variation and I think
not the first move but the second move
is the most difficult one if he misses
kind of uh misunderstands this or
miscalculates this then actually we
could see the advantage suddenly
disappear so it's that type of position
but he has spotted it E5 very powerful
move he's back in this so you're the
first move of that line and now with no
squares for the bishop G4 is going to
happen on the board you've got to go on
the offense to defend that bishop and
then the big critical moment will Fabi
go for Queen E4 David is that the only
way for white to keep his advantage I
wish I knew Tanya I've only got one line
of the engine here but uh for example
let's say what else can white do I mean
you cannot take this bishop you're
pinned the White Queen would fall uh so
process of elimination you don't want to
do that one if you Knight is attacked
you might want to move it but this does
allow black for example to offer a trade
of Queens pick up the e-pawn at the same
time it feels like the path is very very
narrow it kind of forced to find the
winning move there aren't you because uh
you've got to get the queen out the pin
and uh you put it on say Square you
attack as well so it's kind of like
quite logical in it moment see four on
the board big moment so Quint E4 is
winning for Fabiano it's actually a
double attack as you say Simon threats
along this diagonal Rook takes Bishop is
a threat and uh Pawn takes Bishop is a
threat now that your queen is defended
on e4
Fabiano he's got enough time under eight
minutes he should be finding a move like
this he's so good at calculation and if
he finds it he might just be winning
which means that we will get the bidding
Armageddon because Fabi has to win this
game to force a die break he goes from
Knight to E4
still strong still strong the evaluation
bar at least confirms that
what's going on here David
let's I think we might have to jump back
in it's just pure mess right now attack
is met by counter-attack on every single
turn and this is a similar idea maybe
not as brutal as the one we just saw but
simply the idea is to break this pin and
it does rely on the fact that actually
yes you can a counter attack against the
White Queen but once this because Bishop
is captured you have no time to take it
because at the very end white lands with
the pawn on E7 and it's a fork a double
attack uh yes the black pawn is strong
on E2 but it goes nowhere so this is
winning and for example after Pawn takes
Knight if black simply recaptures then a
really nice clearance sacrifice the
Knight jumps out the way because loose
pieces drop off as we all know and this
black queen is undefended this is a
check and when the Knight is captured I
think we take the queen game over Fabian
has calculated that and it should be
enough
what to do if you're Dennis lazovic
maybe you're going down a piece
again same tactic if you try and take in
the center maybe if you take this way
for example with a bishop same concept
right at the very end there's again this
night sacrifice Night Out The Way with a
valuable check winning the black queen
next move
looks good for white
tactics so not Queen E4 but Knight E4
also very precise and good calculation
there by Fabian it's so crazy that
Black's Bishop center of the ward is
trapped no squares and we've just seen
this huge turnaround in just a few moves
it looked like black had everything
under control
yeah opening the a file I hitting
pinpointed at Simon just that one
mistake and it's turned around
yeah it just seemed too risky to open up
those lines uh on that side of the board
and uh yeah I can't see anything at all
now uh for black uh the only thing I
mean you can try taking on F3 and
moving your queen somewhere off to the
capture on D6 but it
but then the defenses start to fall yeah
but I don't know what else you can do
here you can't really go a piece down
you might as well just just resign If
You're Gonna Go piece down say because
you're still getting attacked as well
right if you go a piece down it's not
just a piece it's a peace and you're and
you're getting checkmated so everything
is just dropping 94 at a really really
good move there even even stronger it
seems than our Queen E4 move which is
all say a winning option as well yeah
just these top players every time they
need a clutch win they always seem to
Magic something out of the hat and their
nerves are so strong so experienced of
course Fabiano just a great game I mean
I was criticizing his opening I was
saying it's a stale position but I mean
this is a dream suddenly it's turned all
around and uh it was just the style his
understanding is far deeper than uh most
of us of course Fabiano
he knew that it had potential and that
was the main thing yeah it was the kind
of position that both sides needed to
play very accurately and yeah it was
also I was remembering your point where
you're like these days you have to be a
universal player you can't just focus on
just grinding out those end games you
also have to be good at Dynamics and
Fabi
he excels in calculation he excels in
attack and
this is just kind of the story but I'm
desperately trying to think of something
and I agree with you Simon the best
thing I can see is Pawn takes Knight and
then that's the only thing I can see to
me move the queen to some random square
and I know it's not good strategy but
just pray I mean you can bring the Queen
near White's King at least and uh so you
can take the Knight and then go Queen H4
is the best thing I can think of here
but I do not believe it at all because
White's attack is is coming and whites
King is really safe after a simple mover
as well I mean this is this is just
horrendous isn't it
um but you're right maybe maybe we've
actually or Fabi has now located
Dennis's weak point he's really good in
technical positions but in his complex
positions even at the computer
preferred his structure and I'm sure
black was doing well when it got
complicated he hasn't found the right
course of action and if I was if I was
playing him I'd certainly be trying to
pinpoint that in future future games as
well
um but I don't know can you find
anything David here that you can even
try it's just finding a you know would
you actually try in this position it's
you know he's under a under a minute
that's true I mean I always say you know
when you're defending when you have a
hopeless position be an optimist and I
guess the only thing that I can see is
Simon's kind of indicated okay and he
moves his Bishop to C5 wow what a move
just putting the bishop on a square can
be captured in two different ways but uh
it looked hopeless anyway that other
variation looked like black was facing
facing an attack with nothing to show
for it at least here he's saying okay
you can take my Bishop but it won't come
with an attack against the black queen
there's not going to be any of those
discovered attacks uh with the Knight
jumping out the way with the check
interesting I mean it's mind-boggling
this position almost uh Fabiano of
course we know at this point with the
evaluation bar that he's winning but
what is the way to put the boot in
what's the way to clinch it do you just
take that Bishop
it's the option that we've got to check
right and fabi's got enough time to
actually calculate and find the right
way forward but a really interesting
takeaway there what you mentioned Simon
about uh this perhaps potential weakness
uh for Dennis lazovic when it comes to
these concrete complicated positions and
it's something of a takeaway even for
the 16 year old to work on what happens
if Fabi goes for the most direct line
David capturing that Bishop in C5 I
think he's winning I think he can just
play Simple chess okay you're up a piece
temporarily black will of course restore
the material balance take the White
Knight but if you just simply recapture
black is facing this attack we've seen
it before in multiple variations now
along the b and a files uh this king is
being hit if you try to release the
tension for example with Knight takes
Pawn okay Fabio goes for something else
I was about to say here you can just
move the queen for example it's just an
ongoing attack but Fabiano wants more
and uh what does he play he drops his
Knight back so he's simply trying to
threaten his Bishop which is trapped uh
the pawn hits the White Queen this has
just been played by Dennis and I'm
expecting the queen to retreat I'm not
sure which Square might not make a
difference and The Bishop's just trapped
yeah Randall you
just lost so I like this approach by
Fabi he doesn't rush in with grabbing
the bishop just saves his own pieces and
it looks like Dennis is going to end up
down a bishop any tricks in the position
Simon you're the trick master
do you see anything here well I mean I I
if I was black I would try to bring my
queen try to bring my queen over towards
White's King and swing The Rook around
and pray uh and that's the only thing I
can see so I play Rook F5 next and and
then probably resign very soon but at
least I give it a go you know
um so I don't see anything else and uh
to try I guess the problem is if you try
to threaten Checkmate on G2 white can
simply defend that with his Queen offer
a queen trade piece up and uh Simon I
love your other idea wow that's
unfortunately yeah unfortunately a bit
slow and probably can be ignored after
Pawn takes porn if you try this firstly
white can continue
just capturing everything checking but
uh White's Queen can always just swoop
to the rescue if needed there's not any
tricks then I mean I don't think there's
any tricks in the position at all and
White's winning a piece and it's white
so it's white who's attacking right and
he has one a piece here so it has Dennis
jettison that piece for a couple of
Pawns he still has the G4 Pawn black has
some really scary pawns the F3 Pawn as
well but uh the rest of his position
falling apart and okay he's trying to
hold things together that Rook the Black
Knight in the center is the glue but
what is the Tipping Point
I was thinking of attacking the night
with the porn the D4 seems to win
another piece yeah so how many pieces
you want it's a bit greedy well one
one's enough right so well two two is
better one can never have enough Simon
that's true just there's too many
winning moves there right this is the
problem yeah support for Choice Fabby
let's just show those two moves uh that
were suggested there Pawn to D4 uh I
also love your knight to C4 with the
same idea Tanya uh just overwhelming
this Knight proportion to default looks
like it does the job if you move the
Knight of course just to show this
tactic yet again Knight to C5 check and
this time it's The Rook that will take
the black queen and this one is just
game over you're just gonna be
overwhelmingly ahead of material
it's gonna go to play off yeah it looks
like we're gonna get the bidding
Armageddon now and we're using dot
favors uh Dennis or Fabi
and this is the best case scenario for
Fabi to get there to start with yeah I
mean fappy will get there
um I I I think Dennis is going to be
more annoyed right because he he kind of
had this he had the better opportunity
just needed to try and keep the position
more controlled so I I think fappy will
also gaining strength uh from this win
and probably nowhere to Target Dennis as
well so just try to make the position
complicated
um so yeah be very interesting
Armageddon and which I think we're gonna
get now and we've seen these momentum
shifts when players make a comeback and
the one to win that final rapid game
going into the Armageddon there's a lot
of confidence boost and it can be
difficult psychological situation to
deal with for the player who's lost yeah
it can be because you're going into a
playoff feeling very annoyed and it does
feel that there's a big reset and uh
there well still the position is pretty
fascinating with the pawn coming to F2
but um down to Pieces yeah it is down
two pieces and Black's King is still
under Fire but then White's King
is unsafe
and whilst the game is still alive you
must not write off it's the ability for
a human to blunder and let's not unless
I forget that light Squad Bishop David
it falls back to C6 and you can imagine
threats along the diagonal yeah at least
the outline of a potential attack
counter-attacked by Dennis lazovic he's
found one good idea here and uh this
white king won't feel too safe no matter
where it ends up uh but yeah it is two
pieces and that's a significant term
Factor yeah one of the white Knights
will eventually sit on e4 and plug that
diagonal I guess but okay he's staying
alive and uh as the BG's note that is
the way to the way to do it oh I like it
so yeah Dennis lazovic really creative
I've got to say just kind of bringing
his Bishop to B5 over to C6 he's scaring
Fabiano he knows he's losing objectively
but that's the most you can do just keep
the game going just play for tricks and
hope the opponent gets nervous he does
it he doesn't even care about
recapturing any pawn uh but after the
trade on C5 Bishop C6 and Fabi just
plants his Knight blocking that diet
signal these extra two pieces they count
for something they do count for
something also the clock counts for
something lasovic there on 10 seconds
you know just getting that three second
bonus if I move not a lot of time but
he's doing what every good Hustler is
needs to do you know don't care about
material just throw your pieces forward
and hope for the best and well
hustling is not in fact enough because
uh well Fabi has worked everything out
and that Rook on A7 it's going to be
poisonous
unfortunately that can be defended in
various ways yeah Knight D6 would be a
mistake there
he's found a way to defend it and uh
give a check as well and
still playing on still going
You're Gonna block that with the bishop
because of the Rook jumping on to the E8
Square as well so Rook D7 on the board
but it's impressive how Dennis has kept
the game alive despite being uh two
pieces done so many players would just
give up just just resign but Dana is
here putting on uh putting on move after
move and saying not today
yeah not right now I mean he's got one
trick here you could I thought you could
take on e4 and try to try something
there but I'm yeah I still think he
should probably just resign and let's
just show your tricks Simon
unfortunately just hoping unfortunately
here you could give up your queen and it
looks like you've got a background
Checkmate but uh unfortunately the white
Bishop is uh doing its defensive Duty
here I can drop back defended by its
Rook I'm hoping you'd take with a rook
there so it was like that was the only
chance that I take on e4 I just see what
you capture with then you know maybe
I'll have some chance well that that is
the idea is in play so for instance if
uh Fabi moved the bishop to E5 but of
course he didn't yeah I mean if Abby
really wants to lose this game he
probably can but he's gonna have to try
really hard
um as too many pieces on that it looks
like it's gonna be black skin that's
about to get checkmated now yeah I'm
really instructed from Fabi he gives up
his Rook for a bishop but Black's Bishop
was the final hope there and now the
white king is never ever threatened
along the diagonal it's one way traffic
too much material big attack and Dennis
lazovic resigns wow it's over and we do
get the bidding Armageddon as Fabiano
caruana makes a comeback wins with uh
with the white pieces there and what a
fight this was uh by Fabi creating his
chances he really knows how uh to get
the best out of these positions kind of
like The Comeback King and there is
Dennis lazowick he will be fighting it
out in the bidding Armageddon a format
which might even end up favoring Dennis
because it becomes more random more
mistakes can happen there is no
increment but what around this was uh
David take us through some of the big
insights there yeah for me I just want
to highlight one moment where I think
Dennis lazovic would love to have the
game again this one mistake potentially
cost him uh Victory against Fabiano and
it was here white has just Advanced the
pawn to B4 trying to open up lines
against the black king and we all know
how that turned out in the end it was
the black king that was hunted down and
uh here he could have prevented all of
that by simply locking up the queen side
pushing the pawn to A4
still the game is complicated still full
of tension but at least he would have
rendered these white Rooks Irrelevant
for the near future after Pawn to C4
trying to trap this bishop he could have
simply moved his King out the way and
the game would have gone on still very
tense instead he allowed lines to open
and it backfired and this was our exact
same moment that we were all torn apart
about whether we'd pick white or black
and it felt like Dennis had everything
under control but a difficult difficult
moment making the wrong choice and Fabi
grabbed that opportunity won that game
the chest for the day isn't over even
though three matches were wrapped up in
three games we do get the very exciting
Armageddon and we will be back with the
players bids on the other side of this
break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
another youngster with Anand in her name
eight-year-old vadana sivanandan is
already making waves in the Chess World
with her big wins now whether it's
hanging out with eight-year-olds or 80
year olds it's no problem for this young
Superstar
[Music]
I've been a member since 1986 nearly 40
years it's just a beautiful building
very nice staff lovely place
my name is Pisa Lee I am 79 80 later
this year I'm won the British Chess
Championship when I was 21 and I played
in the England team for about 10 years
my name is
aged eight my ratings around 1800 and I
won the world's underwright girls rapid
and Blitz championships ladies are
allowed in now but they used not to be
here until 20 years ago would you like
to see a bit of the club in theory no
one under 14 should go in the club
[Music]
so I've always been into problem solving
everything I do I do I play bridge as
well I do crosswords I do number games
I'm a medical statistician so I call
myself a problem solver
I started liking the pieces and I wanted
to take them and keep them so then my
dad said I could play in chess instead
do you know about Nobel prizes
over 50 members of the afternoon have
won Nobel prizes Bertram Russell Winston
Churchill gradual Kipling have you heard
of well you're too young you don't know
all these people
[Music]
tactically I'm quite I'm still quite
strong I can still give me a position in
the paper white to play and win the
first move I think of is usually the
answer I think I'm quite good at the
return games but I'm not sure about my
weakness this is the more I think it
most expensive real library in the world
after British museum
[Music]
this is the Darwin chair have you heard
of Charles Darwin
they play between each other chess can I
go up the stairs do you want to go up
the stairs I've never been up the stairs
let's go up the stairs this is high
when I gave up when I was about 31 to I
was 2 3 90 and I've only played one
greater game since then what did you say
you're racing 1900s 1800 18. even if
you're not not ahead of me yet you'll be
ahead of me in two or three years time
foreign
generation cup including taking on the
big challenge of playing the 79 year old
Peter Lee that's going to be a lot of
fun uh and you've had some experience
Simon of playing against bordana I did
yeah I mean she's she's really really
nice uh girl and um I went to a talk at
a chess club and she was there I put a
really hard puzzle on um on the
demonstration board and there was about
40 people there she solved it within
seconds it was like a eight move
combination and I thought this kid is
amazing then she beat me at the symbol I
actually found out later that someone
had shown her the puzzle before so no
wonder she solved it in seconds but um
she was really she's really really
talented uh incredibly strong player and
a really nice person as well so uh great
future she has yeah she's eight years
old she is the world under eight
Champion she's already won a second
place in the British Blitz women
Championship so a bright bright future
ahead of bodana and she can take so much
inspiration and motivation from the
youngsters across the world who have
been shaking up the World Elite and
David I want to throw this to you first
who make it to your top five players
under 20. oh okay the pressure's on this
is probably the hardest question I've
ever been asked Tanya because there are
so many talented Juniors out there these
days I've got my piece of paper oh no
spoilers number five top under 20 player
I've gone for Vincent kymer
I mean we saw what he did he nearly took
down Magnus Carlson at the World Cup
Germany's number one I believe and uh
yeah bright future ahead number four
I've been Manu Mishra world's youngest
ever Grand Master he's still very young
he's had some great results recently
uh number three good cash just because I
mean he's in the top 20 he's only 17. he
seems to be upgrading his uh play every
single year and then two players who are
very familiar to audiences of the
Champions chess tour number two nordebec
Abdul satorov
didn't have his best day today but he's
been there he's done it before World
rapper champion of course and number one
ragnananda
I yeah I would have maybe had a
different order before the World Cup but
Prague at the World Cup just so so
impressive
yeah solid list yeah a very solid list
moment I have to say my list is pretty
similar so obviously great minds think
alike we'll come to your van because a
bit later on
yeah I mean I'd love to copy your
results but you always hide your
blooming answers in the quiz
um but my list is quite kind of similar
but it's different order so I've I mean
they weren't really in a particular
order
um but they kind of were number five was
Vincent kymer
um who beat Magnus Carlson quite
recently so he's he's a brilliant player
uh number four is gookesh well I have to
be honest there's so many Indian players
and it's so hard to pick them and I
don't really want to disclude any of
them number three prag Legend brilliant
player I mean he could be world champion
number two nordie Beck
um didn't do so well today we've really
taken businesses I know I know and
number one I was just Googling to see if
he was actually at the right age uh was
Ali Razer faroogia
um
he's over 20. he turned 20 in June Simon
Okay well I you know that was a good
list
there you go list you know he's kind of
around that age
fast we'll make it 20 and under just to
adjust the rules for science thank you
very much yeah well I I I need to make a
statement about my list because the
players that everyone mentioned I had in
a different list so I was like let's not
repeat let's actually introduce the
world to other talents
so I have top five bibisara asawbeva now
she is a woman's World Blitz Champion
for two years in a row she's just 19 and
I think she's going to be one of the
strongest women in the world watch the
space and then I have 13 year old Alice
Lee she just became an international
Master she's from the states she's just
gonna be a grand master pretty soon and
she's incredible and then I also have
Christopher you because I remember him
from the Champions chess tour I mean
he's also had great results in the US
Championship the Wesley so and also
super quick at the puzzle rush and all
those things he's super strong and then
I have abimani Mishra for reasons that
they've mentioned because he was the
youngest GM in the world and number one
because Vincent o'climber didn't feature
in my other list I thought well no no
prank what's wrong with prime
he was in my office yeah
that's it basically he's coming out I
have a lot of the names that you
mentioned also in on the list this one's
been a tough one to pick top five
players under 20 mine is super similar
to uh Simon and David I start with
Winston kaima for his World Cup
performance but also because his coach
is Peter lecko and I know that means
great things in the future for Winston
my number four is Arjun aragassi because
he's still under 20 Simon I did my job
he turns 20 on I think 3rd of September
so he's still under 20 and then not the
back of the central at number three
again a tough day in the office but we
all know that he is a big Prodigy and
one of the big favorites to fight for
that world title and number two for me
is pragna Nanda I'm dying to see what he
does in the car candidates in 2024 such
a big Talent such a great personality as
well he's really come into his own it's
always fun to watch him play and to give
those interviews and for me number one
has to be the current world number seven
he's 27.50 plus he's 17 years old and
for me that is uh the number one under
20 players so I've got three Indians and
I could have picked another five but I
mixed it up a little bit with the clocks
are ticking and I believe that we will
be getting the bits really soon but
before that let's take a look at the
very destructive format Armageddon it is
just one game and uh the the bid winner
gets to choose the color he plays with
the time that the bid with usually picks
black black does get result odds which
means that white has to win on demand
and the white starts with the base time
which is 15 minutes we will get the bids
really soon and of course there is no
increment of flagging is not only a lot
it's highly recommended and it is a big
part of Armageddon we are getting the
bids in let's take a look and super
close there Fabiano caruana bidding with
nine minutes 58 seconds but it is done
his last awake who wins the bid with 9
minutes 30 seconds super close fight
there then last will start with the
black pieces uh Fabi starts with base
time Fabi will have the white pieces
which means that Fabi has to win a draw
means then last wins the match
yeah Fabiano he needs lightning to
strike twice in a row he did just win
with white so he takes that confidence
boost with him and now he does start
with an extra five and a half minutes
should be very very relevant and here we
go quick start to the game will we see a
repeat for the third time in the day
there we go yes it is this anti-berlin
variation of the Spanish and Dennis
lazovic going back to what he played in
game two and uh okay I yeah I think
Dennis has a good shot despite the fact
he starts with less time because he did
knock out Fabiana from the bullet Chess
Championship and that is relevant
especially with no increment absolutely
and it was so close
how do you think that's going to affect
Fabi Fabi would have definitely wanted
to play with the black pieces but losing
out on the bid with less than 30 seconds
I mean that was some Mind Games there
with the by then last yeah I I think so
but at the same time Abby is so
pragmatic right he's been in the
situation many many times so he's just
gonna be unbothered by the result of the
Armageddon bidding and move on to the
actual game because he has to focus he's
now in a must win situation and I think
it's easier to be in a must-win
situation and have that extra time
especially when you have no increment
because you can just as long as you keep
the position tense you can just flag
them with by drawing out the game for as
long as possible and five and a half
minutes extra on the clock but Dennis
gets the result odds what do you think
about the payoff for this uh it that's
like a good bit to me David it felt like
a good bid just historically throughout
the tour this season we've seen bids of
around eight minutes eight and a half
minutes still be successful for those
who chose black who won the bidding so
nine and a half does feel like a luxury
especially if you're a quick uh quick
player quick on the mouse like Dennis
lazovic uh of course he needs to get rid
of the ghosts from the previous game
where it did go against him but this
time he's got more pieces off the board
Kings on the same side this time feels
like uh things in his favor he's also
made 16 moves in just over 30 40 seconds
uh Dennis lazovic so very very quick
more time than what he started with
right because he bid no he bit nine
minutes uh 30 seconds so almost the nine
minute Mark here with super fast playing
look at Fabi Harry the H Bond he needs
to get aggressive because winning is
really the only result for white hair
and what are we expecting are we
expecting that pawn to March further
down the board
yeah I think so yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean he said hey yeah you have to don't
you and the only danger of that is you
you open up maybe the the G file uh but
he he's got to play this yeah I mean
otherwise what's the point of pushing it
in the first place and again even though
the evaluation part is pretty even I
mean it seems like I I think Fabio will
be quite happy uh he's managed to open
up the black king a little bit he's
still got one Pawn lever he can use
which he's now preparing he's got F4
which I think is an important push and
if you can get that move in he could
also open up his Bishop so uh a very
tense position black is also very solid
so yeah it's uh it's again uh nothing
decided as of yet
are you impressed how fast Fabi is
playing now it's moved 20 he's only
spent an hour a minute and 30 seconds uh
especially on the white side normally
you do have that luxury to kind of take
time especially big decisions being made
a set of Rooks off the board now
yeah fast start for both but it's quite
a simple position and that does tend to
favor lazovic especially withdraw odds
how dangerous do you think it is for
white to start opening up the position
uh he has to do something soon if he
wants to win I'd be very tempted to play
F4 here if it worked uh you've got to be
a bit careful because as you say you are
weakening your king at the same time
you've also got D4 move uh you know uh
so you've got a couple of couple of
levers you can play uh with the white
pieces here I mean F4 though maybe maybe
it's not quite working could you also
waste time and uh by that I mean just
draw out the game for even longer by
going Rook A7 Rook A1 then maybe
prepared D4 then maybe prefer F4 you
know just keep the opponents guess that
yeah yeah he's doing it he's doing this
sadistically so yeah there tend to be
two strategies and Armageddon one is to
just wait and wait and wait wait uh for
your opponents to clock to take down but
also for the tension to build uh yeah
the second is just straight for the
throat tactics Galore calculation and
hope your opponent Burns time there and
uh feels like fabi's got both up his
sleeve if uh depending how he wants to
work this position I like this one
anyway just asks a question and then we
see the evaluation bar jump after maybe
the most natural move in the position
for lasovic perhaps it's just because
the seventh rank now whites Rook really
well placed for the position to open and
he's got a breaking as well now and uh
wise pieces are really coming to life I
mean if you imagine that pawn is
captured the White Knight Will dive in
threatening a number of horrible things
that's threatening to checks there it's
threatening the black pawn and if you
don't capture the white Pawn then uh
well I mean uh white white has this very
useful Center anyway
so black trying to just hold that point
in the middle the E5 Point seems
actually key here if you can hold the E5
point you might better hold your
position as black here yeah really nice
move there stabilizing and again
something that lazovic's very very good
at I think I've used to him uh more
times than I can count in bullet chess
so I know his skills there but seven
minutes yeah it will be a race against
the clock eventually how can Fabi ask
questions
but unless there's no obvious move for
white hair there's no obvious follow-up
to his last uh couple of turns there is
a cheap threat which is you can just
move the Knight to G3 and threaten a
check and uh
and then see what happens next the cheap
tricks are the best you anchor Force the
opponents to burn time on the clock this
is a check due to the pin on the G file
and how to deal with it it's not 100
obvious I'd have to just fall back with
the King and try and get out of that bin
oh the bar reacts apparently this would
be a losing move maybe because the
Knight jumps in threats of taking this
bishop and of checking on it David maybe
another Square so that you can actually
grab on F5 when the Knight jumps in yeah
you're right Tanya that would be far
safer and probably what Dennis last of
it would have played instead Fabiano
pushes forward it's the three-point
attack in the center here
and uh he's just hinting that he might
push this one this one might take later
keeping his options open and the King
does drop back maybe you can make it a
full pawn attack soon
or maybe five with that four as well
maybe yeah maybe the five yeah and might
as well push the g-pawn by that point
yeah go for it getting off on going six
are better than three yeah uh I mean why
why should I mean it seems like white is
a little bit more comfortable here but
you're right what is what is the plan
here and uh black is maintaining that
solid point in the middle of the board
while the the Knight now comes around
and the thread is in the air Knight F5
it might not be a check but it's
threatening a fork and that Bishop on D6
as well because I Rook on A7 it em
threats along the seventh rank so
Black's got to sidestep Knight F5 yeah
if that black Bishop is ever dislodged
then White's Rook will just cash in and
just take everything off the board okay
he Dodges to the side to King H7 there
feels weird it feels loose for some
reason my instincts are just saying
that's all wrong just maybe because I'm
allowing some checks but lots of it
because nurses still he's not scared I
think
you know ghosts here it'd be lovely if
white can move the king to the other
side of the board here I mean uh you
know may I mean I kind of be thinking
about putting the King on E2 and going
Rook A1 but uh I I don't know I mean do
you have any other breaks here uh it's
not so easy to find
the middle
and maybe you wanted to stop any
potential Queen trade offers with Queen
E6 because I came from 87 also got the
G6 Pawn so Queen E6 could have been in
there and D5 just takes away more space
and more squares from uh Dennis so just
cramping down in the position
also by locking it you kind of ensure
that it's a longer game uh you don't
allow the opponent like you say Tanya to
force the queen trade or at least gain
that kind of uh simplification take
pieces off the board make the task
easier with the clock ticking so I like
it blocking it up there Fabi and with
the center stable is actually possible
now to reroute the bishop put it on a
more active square and there we see
lazovic come in with the Knight
threatened the pawn on B3
but black has got some decent squares
for his pieces as well here I mean that
night uh it might be pushed away by the
B Pawn but at the moment it's pretty
good and the the bishop of blacks is
very stable in the center of the board
so uh it looks like black is fairly
solid at the moment at least yeah the
evaluation bar okay drops but I was
going to say it is a bit deceptive
because it looks like black has got
everything under control in order to
kind of turn this advice white Advantage
transform it into something tangible
it's not going to be easy at all it
might take some very sophisticated
Maneuvers or uh kind of a tactical
breakthrough later and now Dennis last
week everything's protected I love this
last move just shuffling the black king
but he is forced back with his Knight
and uh okay what next for Fabi he needs
some momentum again threatening this
Knight F5 check it's so annoying for
lazovic every time he tries to
consolidate that same idea pops up
and here he comes the bishop drops back
to C1 threatening Bishop H6 and oh look
at that King go no I'm in the middle of
the board
starting to look a little bit dangerous
black isn't it I mean black black is uh
kind of running out of moves there uh
and all those pieces huddled in the
center of the board but can white apply
any more pressure instead just bringing
a piece to a better Square there just
keeping the pressure on there and the
structure you have a trap there because
uh black can't get greedy and grab the
pawn on B4 because the bishop would
actually grab the pawn on B6 in fact for
C7 C7 is pretty seven would be dangerous
as well he's setting up stuff on the
edge file so Dennis lazovic looking for
gun to play as well with the queen and
the roof potentially lining up starting
to thread some checks along H2 but that
Knight on G3 is also a really great
defender for Fabi yeah I mean maybe
white should start bringing the king
king now to C6
do the walk with the king
um I mean you love Simon but I might
just be a profit later especially if the
Queens come off yeah
well actually the black queen cannot
move she has to guard the E6 Square this
is true so Queen X7 actually runs into
Queen E6 check yeah just to show and
this would end in a devastating
checkmating attack uh yeah you cannot go
active with the black queen you're kind
of tied down the only piece you can
really move is this Black Brook where's
it going well the question is I guess
whether black can set up yeah you've
highlighted F5 yeah and unfortunately
the consequence of that is that you
abandon the G5 Square so then you'd have
to work out Bishop G5 check
and again the king under heavy pressure
I can see that white knight the idea of
it the white Knight's trying to come to
B5 to the queen side but it was actually
very nicely situated on G3 and I you
know because it stops all the black's
counter playing maybe this King maneuver
is not actually so stupid because black
can't move anything as much as I can see
you know you can't beat the queen is
black you can't be the bishop your Rook
can't really go anywhere so
um okay well taking away the square for
the king what are you doing
and now now what you do but but Dennis
is just sitting here right he's just
basically saying I'm gonna have to wait
I'm sitting can you improve your
position that's up to you to decide
I feel that the position perhaps might
turn on a white exchanging dark Square
Bishops or Bishops yeah maybe bishop C1
then yeah Bishop C1 and maybe if you can
arrange it kind of uh have the Knight
recapture the bishop
or even just Bishop C1 Bishop B3 and
then you can continue building your
picture after as well I really like your
idea of getting rid of one of the very
key pieces the pillar in Black's
position that Bishop on D6 and Fabi
they're taking a bit of a thinker
because he's placed all his pieces and
it's on the board great call that your
Banker uh yeah this makes a lot of sense
you want to try and trade off that dark
squared bishop and leave black with all
passive pieces on the board
and what does lasovic do here I was
about to praise His uh use of the clock
playing so quickly but yeah yeah he goes
for Rook to be it are we expecting
Bishop to A3 and then just trade off and
then come back to A7
yeah certainly looks like a good option
but also I quite like this because
fabi's plan is just to draw out the
position make Elizabeth burn that time
on the clock before taking any committed
decisions and uh Queen H3 is a nice
effective move and Eric moves to a
blunder
why is it a such a big mistake
whatever it was Fabi misses it
David what happened there
um apparently the dot squared Bishop
trade there would have been winning for
white the white Rook would have broken
through on the seventh Rank and it would
have been game over Fabi went the wrong
way with his bishop and the game's still
alive Dennis lazovic still curling up
into a ball still no breakthrough and
the clocks are ticking
and no increment and that knight from F1
you were pointing out the B5 Square it
could be headed to the C4 Square now to
try and Target that Bishop on D6 so
rerouting at Knight D2 94 he comes back
he's allowing a check on it but it's I
think one of those cases where it's just
a check the king simply steps back up
and there's no danger for black there
although you do get him to use time on
the clock
and remember when you don't get any any
time every second counts for 92 plate
this is horrible with black isn't it and
the problem is that black can't do
anything Black's just moving backwards
and forwards and Fabby is just improving
his position every move I mean actually
the more is really bad for black
I mean you can't even get any active
play anywhere on the board now you've
got no moves your kings week pieces
can't move I I think fabi's got this got
this one in the back and I think it's
too late now but maybe he missed an
opportunity there lazovic to lash out
with F5 I think abandoning the h-file
allowing the White Queen to sit on this
beautiful square and kind of peering
down the diagonal controlling any
potential activity this is just decisive
and he's maximized every single piece
now Fabiano Rook perfect on the seventh
rank Queen just uh beautifully flexible
and yeah the White Knight now is going
to do the work it's going to trade off
just kind of uh just eliminate that
black defender on D6 and it's going to
be game over
effect mix of tactics aggressive play
with position strategic play by Fabi a
rerouting maneuvering the pieces getting
rid of the Defenders along with taking
away more space D5 B5 but also combining
it with tactics and it comes back to
that very Universal approach that these
the very best players in the world have
yeah absolutely I feel like this has
been a model game
yeah absolutely and now all I'm
expecting Fabi to do is maybe just uh
drop the bishop back to C1 and get ready
to re just capture the bishop with his
Knight
D6 it's held everything together for so
long but it's about to be eliminated
about to be traded off and Black's
Position will likely collapse you can
maybe take it off now but as you say
your uncle y Rush why not just kind of
prepare it he's been doing everything
maneuvering so beautifully Fabiano and
wow he cashes it now and that's a
sacrifice but it's all to do with the
seventh Frank look at that white Rook
look how many targets it has
this is a winning move yeah you can't
capture with the Knight you have to take
it back with the pawn the bishop jumps
in The Rook is hanging the defender of
the D7 uh Knight is this just busted uh
tactical finish to a very strategic
Masterpiece by Fabi yeah that was just a
boom moment from Fabi what a tactical
blow at the end and Dennis Retreats the
bishop but Bishop takes Rick with check
Queen check is at least one way to win
now but yeah there it is and uh this is
completely completely over now the queen
will intercept
maybe you missed this one Fabiano I mean
it's easy to miss at least he's gonna
have to work slightly harder slightly
longer um like you say Simon it's
totally winning you could even trade the
Queens off and that end game is winning
but Fabiano wanted to deliver checkmate
yeah if you keep the Queen's on now his
Rook is attacked the queen is attacked
yeah I mean white white is should be
winning this quite easily but still yeah
maybe Black's got better chances now
yeah but there is one big Pitfall do not
put the white Rook on B7 because it
looks really tempting to hold the
seventh rank but you will not have a
square
let's just highlight that okay not that
square let's just go back and if the
Rook had landed on B7 then yeah as you
say you're like a suddenly full
turnaround 360 and this Rook is trapped
nothing to do no way to extricate it
instead Fabiano uses the A6 square and I
think the winning plan here at the right
moment will just be to leave this Rook
on a nice safe square and then start
improving the king maybe bring it round
like Simon Says push the pawn and uh
your overwhelming black on both sides of
the board
um these pawns will tie down the
weakness of these pawns will tie down
the Black Knight and these pawns will
overwhelm the black Bishop
should be winning it still takes a while
yeah there's nothing black can do still
here that that's the issue so okay well
he's trying to improve his Bishop trying
to get it onto a slightly better square
and control uh the white Pawn from
coming forward so you gotta try and keep
that blockade if you can maybe it's got
better for black than it was can the
black have a fortress so for instance if
he can put the bishop on B6 and maybe
re-route the king D6 and just
I mean if I go Rook C6 now then try to
get my king in it looks very
uncomfortable there might be other ways
to play he has I mean this uh this uh
stops yeah black ever coordinating I
think this move because you can never
move your knight because I take pawn and
here comes the king where you've also
got F4 as well at the right time so it
still looks winning for white but
Black's fighting do we think the clocks
might play a factor two minutes 40
against four minutes now this is the
closest it's ever been on the clock
since the beginning of the game David
this is uh the Armageddon the clocks are
definitely gonna play a factor and I
don't think either of the players are
gonna give up uh going to try to flag
each other which means that black has to
be super fast Dennis has to make his
moves really quickly of course white has
all the trumps with that break with F4
and now that the Rook on C6 cuts off
black skin the Black Knight is really
stuck you can't go Knight C5 and go Pawn
hunting because the b-pawn starts
rolling down the board so Rook C6 I
think was a really key move there Simon
keeping everything under control but now
Fabi are touching the three minute Mark
so things could get chaotic on the clock
still a lot to fight for here for black
yeah I mean the valuation bar is saying
it's completely winning but it's not
entirely clear how you how you uh uh put
this in the back of the net now I mean
the white King has to come in and
where's it coming okay maybe it's
heading for A6 and just to push the B
Pawn this could be uh or A5 something
like that displays all your king side
pawns on light squares defend them and
then just go ahead marching with the
King but the bishop from B6 takes away
all the key squares for the white king
to come in yeah it does a good job I
mean it might be Zig swing at some point
maybe and uh yeah here it comes this
King coming in and we're also trying to
get into D5 at the right moment and uh
is it just me or just Fabiano looks
slightly frustrated like his his head
went to his hand he's like come on there
must have been a win I should have
finished this off by now and suddenly
the clocks it's only 25 seconds between
them oh and that's a mistake yeah it is
so natural though that can't be a big
mistake I wouldn't afford could it I
mean pushing the pawn there looks normal
and the clocks are almost level now
maybe this is a mistake because now the
white king is no longer free to just
Journey towards the queen side the white
king is needed to hold everything
together in the center and on the king
side and suddenly no breakthrough
yeah he's running but now black for the
first time has counter play yeah I think
this might turn I'm going to say it now
I think lazovic might save this wow yeah
I mean evaluation bars nearly said it's
equal here as well so I should have said
earlier
okay but uh you I don't know I still
feel that white has excellent chances
Rook check and now you have to capture
the pawn in the middle but then yeah
you're right the G3 Pawn will fall how
do you how do you improve this as white
with it being super difficult for the
king to March up to assist that B Pawn
you've got to get B6 in but for that you
need your King on the other side of the
board and now with this King side
hanging that's super hard to achieve I
think the tables have done and David you
pointed out that Dennis lasovic he's
super good with technique oh you know
when positions on super chaotic super
messy is when Dennis really thrives and
I think we're seeing those kind of end
games emerge right now it might be
trouble for Fabi yeah he might be 16 but
he plays like a 60 year old it's all
about stabilizing control and then he'll
outmaneuver opponents later and okay
he's snapped off the pawn yes the whites
have white people has reached B7 but it
will not go any further suddenly look
out for Black's G Pawn rolling time
Dennis is up on the clock now yeah he is
I mean fabby's only got a minute 40 left
and Knight C5 is he able to defend that
B Pawn and this is uh oh my words he's
trying to attack The Rook you can just
take the Rook oh wow David Bishop B5 is
a check we've got a shot maybe he'll
play it
Fabiano has blundered but it wasn't
winning any longer he had to gamble this
is the gamble he's taking but white is
not even threatening to make a new Queen
if the white Rook is off the board black
Bishop will come back and take on E5
he misses it wow he misses Knight Dixie
six he would have won the game on the
spot the spot and it's a turn around
potentially yet again
the bar is going a little bit crazy
there wow this is crazy the tension but
look at the time I think it's going to
come down to that clock as well let's
just quickly show here Dennis lazovic
could have clinched it on the spot by
taking this Rook off the board and after
the Knight is recaptured uh when white
makes a new Queen when it does become a
queen after Bishop takes Pawn this is a
double attack a fork and the queen would
fall black would win instead look at
what we're left with now wow the game if
we catch up with it it's Bishop of the
Knight and pawn against the queen
but I've had this kind of concoction
bishop and Knight against the porn I
couldn't win it it's probably a drug she
can't get the king in right yeah yeah
but there are all these certain setups
where black skin is on a check the
bishop is on G7 and I think the Knight
is around that King they there's no way
for white to actually make progress
there and you can set up a program a
fortress but with just under a minute no
increment no one cares about a fortress
here because you're gonna play it and
you flag your opponent
just on the clock right I mean this is
it you just got to keep an eye on the
clock now and they're both under a
minute right by look wait one second if
you can't make any progress you can't
claim a door right and I'm a kitten
no no claiming drawers oh I think this
is supposed to be a technical win but it
takes 200 moves or saying this is one of
those weird endings where you're right
the Knight needs to go to that square
and does black knives defend it looks
like he's putting the Knight on the
right Square I don't know it's on the
night Square it's going to be a miracle
though with 30 seconds to hold off the
White Queen for 50 moves yeah you need a
lot of luck and a lot of skill a lot of
mouth speed 30 seconds this what a
pretty crazy Armageddon this has been
one move away from winning and again I
came down to these tactics but that was
a really simple tactics for them for
Dennis to miss with one and a half
minutes on the clock you would back back
and him finding that you would bet
everything on him finding that but uh
nope he didn't and he now needs to
defend this
still holding off defending really well
but 20 seconds is I mean 50 moves as
well that's that's probably the the
nearest to a draw you can get here is uh
is hang on a second the game will
automatically finish right after well
yeah up to 50 moves after 50 moves but
what's the time 15 seconds it has to not
defend the board he has to defend the
clock right now yeah but he's so good at
bullet she has his knee so he should be
should be okay here on time but it's all
about the pre-moves and the last capture
was almost 76 so he needs to survive
without losing a piece to move 126 here
Dennis lazovic another 20 moves that is
David we're at move hundred and six
right now 10 seconds left though to do
that I mean it's not a lot of time seven
and he's moving up has to pre-move 126
it is the magic number for Dennis
lazowick 15 moves away but he's about to
get checked later
is coming up he loses the bishop oh no
he's got to wait another 50 moves which
is not gonna happen here and I think
fabby's done it unbelievable
this is uh crazy right
there we go Fabiano takes the win he was
winning on the board he also won on the
clock and relief on his face
three reacts that was definitely a
really fun five his face what an army
Garden that was uh Dennis lazawick one
move away from winning after a big
blunder but a blind spot by both these
players a huge mess and a big flagging
fight that turned out to be David you've
got to take us through the big moment in
the game oh that was just one big moment
Fabiano had let the wind slip but he
gambled and that gamble eventually paid
off but it was this moment it should be
a draw now this position Fabiana said
okay I'm just gonna go all in I'm gonna
push this Pawn forward if you do not
find this move Knight takes Rook then
actually white is going to be winning
and just to show that again Knight takes
Rook would have won whether white queens
and allows Bishop takes Pawn or whether
white takes this Knight first same
result black is simply winning here
black will pick up the queen and game
over instead Dennis missed this with one
minute and a half on his clock he played
Knight back to D7 and Fabiano could have
clinched it on the spot pretty much if
he had taken this Pawn with this rook
and deflected White Knight we would have
got the same end game but white keeping
an extra Pawn instead we saw Queen vs
Bishop Knight and porn and eventually
finally with seconds to spare Fabiano
did get the win
an absolute a roller coaster of an
Armageddon let's take a look at our
score line for the winners quarterfinals
this is day one of the Julius bad
generation cup and what amazing action
we've had with three matches wrapping up
in just three games Magnus Carlton was
he saw alireza ferrugia stay on in the
winners bracket and as does Fabiano
caruana after a very very dramatic
Armageddon there which could have gone
either ways and we do have Favi joining
us Fabi what a crazy finish to that
match and how are you feeling right now
yeah it was uh
no it was such a crazy game and yeah I'm
still trying to uh get my heart rate
down a little bit
also I I there was just one moment when
the game is over I mean of course I was
completely winning at some point in the
game
I blundered Queenie eight I just like
didn't even see he has this move I
thought games over after Queen h8
and then of course he could have taken
on um he could have just taken my Rook
um when I played E5 I mean he has Bishop
takes E5 would check and he and I resign
so I was about I I even had my my uh
Mouse on the resign button at this
moment
but uh but then yeah he gave me another
chance and
and I wasn't making progress but of
course with no increment it's pretty
much impossible to defend against the
queen
did you spot Knight E6 uh as soon as you
played E5 what happened there
yeah I saw it as soon as I played E5
otherwise I probably would have played
D6
uh I didn't play D6 because I thought
Knight B7 Rook E7 I win the night but he
has bishop and pawn and and I'll never
win this most likely
but of course it's better than resigning
immediately after E5 but somehow he has
just some you know in the in these games
uh with these Split Second decisions
sometimes a mistake ends up working out
for you so there's there's always an
element of luck so even though E5 was of
course a terrible mistake it probably
ended up winning me the game
and uh and that's sometimes how these
things turn out so of course it is kind
of a miraculous uh win for me on the
other hand I did feel like I was out
playing him very cleanly and then uh and
then suddenly I missed Queen Aid and I
have to work all over again
to win the position which was certainly
winning before I played Queen h8
and I have to say that he's very very
resilient he's really holding on
um even in the most difficult situation
so so definitely very very performant
and uh Fabiano this is the generation
cup what do you make of 16 year old
Dennis lazovic's chances uh of making it
to the very top of World Chess
yeah I'm not too familiar with his play
uh I do think he's very impressive but
it's only really based off of this match
that I have some experience with him so
it's maybe it's too early to say in
general and also I I probably wouldn't
be the best person to ask but but
certainly he has a bright future
and Fabi jumping back to the match again
uh in game three Dennis won and took the
lead game four you made a very important
and a very uh it was an awesome game to
watch she made your comeback how did you
get ready for game four how did you make
that switch uh with your mindset
okay I didn't really get ready too much
I mean I've been in this situation quite
often recently that I have to to win a
game on demand so I managed to to find a
way to stand to stay calm in these
situations sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't
but uh but it's not an unusual situation
so I don't really panic when I get into
it and um
and yeah I mean I I felt uh
like this was similar to let's say my
match against artemia in earlier this
year in the Champions chess tour where I
was also in a must-win situation I've
had this against Magnus uh against
Wesley also in the World Cup twice
yeah twice against Prague when I didn't
manage and also against
um
uh in the last match I played I I did I
did kind of manage against the boss off
uh in a classical game so it's it's 50
50. sometimes you manage sometimes you
don't
and uh Fabiano as far as I can work out
I think you've played maybe the most
games out of anyone in uh World Chester
for the last month uh how are your
energy levels feeling
well I I don't know because there's
there's this other player called Hans
Neiman who who plays pretty much uh
every single day and sometimes he plays
more than 30 Games a month so I'm not
sure I'm catching up quite to him but I
but I have I haven't really really
active recently and uh yeah okay my
energy levels are are a bit up and down
after the World Cup they were pretty
much at the bottom and and I was
traveling yesterday so I I got back
around 7 pm and I played uh
10 a.m at my time this morning so at
least I had a little bit of time to
sleep I managed to sleep like 10 hours
which was unusual when you're jet lagged
um so I wasn't feeling too tired or
anything but of course
it is nice too
or I am looking forward to getting some
rest whenever I do get it
and uh Fabi speaking of Hansa with
chescom's statement about him coming
back into competitive play and I know
that this is a topic that you have
covered on your c-squad podcast I just
wanted to get your views and thoughts on
uh perhaps even seeing him in the
Champions chess store
yeah I'm looking forward to playing Hans
again I I haven't played him since the
US championship and we we were playing
quite a bit online in in the rapid Chess
Championship when it was happening last
year and uh and title Tuesday and so on
so personally I'm happy to see him back
I don't really know the details of what
went down but uh
but yeah I think it's it's good for
chess overall when in general when all
the most interesting and also strongest
players in the world are playing
it's really nice to hear and uh Fabi we
are getting a confirmation that you are
playing Magnus tomorrow in the winter
semi-finals so looking ahead at that
match your thoughts
well I'm happy to be there because of
course I I could have been in the losers
bracket after this match very very
easily so I'm happy to be playing Magnus
again and it's sort of like I think I've
I've usually managed up in magnus's side
of the bracket so we we were supposed to
play or like we were kind of slated to
play in um
in this second event but we didn't
because our time we have beat Magnus and
then we did play in the one previous to
this
uh and and Magnus beat me two and a half
one and a half so I'm hoping to get some
Revenge of course I don't expect it to
be
uh to be easy of course my playing
Magnus is always a colossal struggle but
but hopefully I'll be up to the task
we're really excited about the matchup
as well if I wish you all the best and
once again a big congratulations not
just for today but also for your uh
amazing performance month long uh
qualifying for the candidates third at
the World Cup and of course in
Dusseldorf what a run you had it's been
awesome to watch you play
thank you Tonya
Fabiano caruana will be taking on Magnus
Carlsen tomorrow that is a big matchup
that we're all excited about and this
was the big match of today Dennis
lazovic almost did it he took the lead
winning that third game and in the
Armageddon as Fabi said it himself
Knight takes E6 would have changed the
storyline but it was Fabiano caruana who
reigned Supreme in the end taking the
match in the Armageddon let's take a
look at our
quarterfinals a bracket and there we
have it Magnus plays
against Fabi in the winners semi-finals
and Wesley store will be playing against
Oliver two very exciting matchups but
before that we will have the losers
round one and they are on their last
lives
two players will be eliminated tomorrow
it is not about taking on elenov and
Dennis lazowick against the Armen by
Simon what a day of Chess we've had
certain times action what was the big
highlight for you uh the Armageddon game
I mean that that was so exciting I mean
that E5 uh I don't know if he knew it
was a bluff or he realized it was a
bluff for then even after that E5 movie
you know it was very hard to predict uh
who was gonna go through so we're very
exciting Armageddon game there yeah I
was super excited by that you know if it
hadn't been for that I would have said
actually everyone winning in three games
I mean how often do you see that I was
expecting much more matches to finish
um in the spinal stages in the
Armageddon yeah and uh the Armageddon
was exciting but we shouldn't forget
that some of the favorites including
Magnus Carlson for arugia Wesley so they
started with a bang and uh I mean those
semi-finals tomorrow so so juicy and of
course yeah just a great start to the
tournament
it really has the sector
the drama that is coming up in the
Julius bear generation
comes seems to be super exciting with
the matchups and what a day of Chess
we've had so many incredible games and
highlights all along and it wasn't just
in division one big matchups and big
results in division two as well Levon
arunian who is fighting for those very
critical tour points did take down Ralph
mama dog it's a big fight in division
two David specially for that ticket into
division one of the next event that's
right so all of those who did win uh in
this first round in the round of 16 they
will be confident that they can go far
Bank those points for Iranian feathersev
naponishi actually Serana as well who's
doing pretty decently on the tour
standings this was a big day
a big day and the action is just getting
started we also had a lot of action on
Twitter with all of you sending us
your answers to our trivia of the day
which was Magnus is only the second
player to win the fide World Cup as the
number one seed who was the other
players player and we did we do have a
winner but before that let's take a look
at the David and Simon revealing the
answer
okay so my answer is uh aronium
and you dated
for Earth girl fan foreign
[Laughter]
well done there David with that answer
2009 Boris girlfriend the only other
player apart from Magnus who is seated
number one and who won the World Cup he
went on to play uh the world
championship match against Magnus
against against
in 2012 and this is our winner of the
day it is Adam Connell who is a huge
congratulations from all of us in the
studio you got this one right and you do
win the air things device right here
this one is coming your way and uh it's
going to be a lot of fun in the Julius
bear generation cup as the action
continues guys this has been a fantastic
day so much drama with three match wins
with just three games and then the
incredible Fabi Armageddon against
Dennis last week and we're just getting
started we will be back with day two
action we'll see you same time same
place
[Music]
will he play it
was gonna happen
it's over I don't think he saw that man
his expression there
99 problems that a bishop is one
definitely yeah
both Fabiano takes the win he was
winning on the board he also won on the
clock and relief on his face
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you